ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
अ प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस एक बार जल्दी बता
दीजिए मुझे कि [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मेरी आवाज बिल्कुल क्लियर आ रही है आप
लोगों को बिल्कुल क्लियर कट कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है ऑडियो में
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
माय फर्स्ट लाइव ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट
सभी को आवाज आ रही है क्लियर सभी बता
दीजिए एक बार ताकि कंफर्मेशन मिल जाए मुझे
एक बार तो फिर हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस ओके यस सर सब कुछ
क्लियर है ठीक है चलो मैं इनफॉर्म भी यहां
पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
सो सभी हमारे साथ आ चुके हैं, जुड़ चुके
हैं। बहुत बढ़िया है। अच्छी अच्छी बात है।
एंड लेट मी सी हाउ मेनी पीपल हैव जॉइ टिल
नाउ। एक बार देख लेते हैं कितने लोग आ
चुके हैं अभी तक। [खांसने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सो टिल नाउ
62 पीपल हैव जॉइंड। बाकी सभी को आने देते
हैं तभी स्टार्ट करेंगे।
बाकी सभी को आने देते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फटाफट आई थिंक अभी आ रहे हैं सभी लोग
ज्वाइन कर रहे हैं। गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ
यू। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। अ वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू। कैसे हैं आप लोग?
एकदम बढ़िया हैं। मजे में हैं?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बता दीजिए पहले तो।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
1001 पीपल आर हियर नाउ ओके ग्रेट अच्छी
बात है।
ओके
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। सो 115 115 लोग आ चुके हैं हमारे
साथ। अच्छी बात है। बहुत बढ़िया है। बिफोर
वी स्टार्ट। चलिए आज का सेशन बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग होगा। आज का सेशन
और भी इंटरेस्टिंग होगा। मैं ये बोलूंगा।
बहुत तो होता ही है हमेशा होता ही है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बट आप
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] में से नोटिस
कर रहे हैं कि फर्स्ट डे पे हमारे साथ 350
लोगों ने लगभग जॉइ किया था। सेकंड डे पे
लगभग 250 के आसपास और आज 150 के आसपास कर
रहे हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] व्हाट इट मींस?
व्हाट इट मीन? इट मींस कि स्ट्रेंथ
धीरे-धीरे ये लोग कम कर रहे हैं। आई थिंक
इट्स लेस नाउ। बट कोई बात नहीं
चलेगा।
नॉट एन इशू। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां, मेरा काम है आप लोगों को ट्रेनिंग
देना, एक एक रियल ट्रेनिंग देना, एक जॉब
ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग देना फ्री में। एंड वो
काम मैं आपके लिए कर रहा हूं। आई होप आप
उसको जो है अच्छे से गैब करेंगे, अच्छे से
गैस्प करेंगे उस चीज को एंड उसको
बेनिफिशियल बनाएंगे खुद के लिए। बस मैं
यही कहूंगा। बाकी मुझे
उन लोगों से स्पेसिफिक मतलब है जो लाइव
में आते हैं। एंड मैं आपको यकीन के साथ
बोलता हूं। मैं आपको एक गारंटी के साथ
बोलता हूं। और आज से एक चीज शुरू कर रहे
हैं। आज से
[खांसने की आवाज़] एक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चीज जो है मैं
आप लोगों को बताना चाहता हूं। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वीक में तीन
क्लास प्लीज। एक वीक में तीन क्लास तो हो
ही जाएगी यार। एक वीक में तीन क्लास तो
आराम से हो जाएगी। वो अभी भी पिछले बार भी
हुई है। ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। अब हो जाएगी।
कोई इशू नहीं है। बट आप लोग आते नहीं हो
ना? जैसे-जैसे आप लोग कम आना शुरू करोगे
फ्रीक्वेंसी वीडियो की और कम हो जाएगी।
मैं आपको पहले ही बोल चुका हूं और इस बार
फिर से बोलता हूं। ये आपके हाथ में है कि
इस ट्रेनिंग को कितना फास्ट और कितना
जल्दी-जल्दी लाना है और कितने टाइम में
कंप्लीट करना है। इट्स टोटली अप टू यू।
हमारे हाथ में नहीं है वो। मैंने आपको
पहले ही कहा है। अगर मैं आपको इस लेवल की
ट्रेनिंग दे रहा हूं जो कोई नहीं देता।
जनरली कोई नहीं देता। कोई नहीं प्रोवाइड
करता यार। और आप जाके YouTube पे सर्च जाओ
YouTube पे सर्च करो अभी कर लो सर्च अगर
कोई ऐसा कोई लाइव वगैरह आपको पढ़ा रहा है
एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग वो भी इस बात को बोल के
कि ये एक एल1 की जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग है तो
मैं गारंटी बोल रहा हूं ना मैं अभी आपके
सामने लाइव अपनी चैनल को डिलीट कर दूंगा
अगर आप जाके मुझे एक भी बता दो कोई बता दो
मुझे कि एक भी सर हां ऐसी ट्रेनिंग लाइव
चल रही है किसी चैनल पे हिंदी में बताओ
मुझे कोई चल रहा है कहीं पे बताओ देख के
बताओ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चल रहा है तो बताओ कोई भी ट्रेनिंग कोई भी
YouTube पे पूरी YouTube की मैं बात कर
रहा हूं। ऐसी लाइव कोई एसओसी ट्रेनिंग दे
रहा है तो इफ यू फाउंड समवन तो मैं गारंटी
के साथ आप जो बोलोगे वैसा कर दूंगा। जैसा
बोलोगे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बट मैं खुद जानता हूं ना यार मैं खुद ही
रिसर्च करके बैठा रहता हूं। मैं खुद ही
मुझे पता होता है कि क्या क्या चल रहा है,
कहां चल रहा है। यही काम है। है ना?
कितने दिन का होगा कोर्स? उससे क्या मतलब
है यार? मान के चल लो थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स
बस। हालांकि उससे मतलब नहीं रखना चाहिए
आपको अभी। बट थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बक बंटी कोर्स के लिए एथिकल हैकिंग की
नॉलेज है कि नहीं? वो सब बेसिक बिगिनर्स
हैं। हेलो नितेश सर आपने कहा था कि हमें
कुछ खुद से टॉपिक एक्सप्लोर करने चाहिए।
अगर क्लास के बीच में या एंड में आप
रिसर्च टॉपिक का नाम क्लियरली बता दें।
नाम नहीं बताना है ब्रदर। नाम नहीं बताना
है। नाम की बात यहां नहीं है। आप समझे आप
आई थिंक समझे नहीं मेरी बात को। रिसर्च
टॉपिक्स का मतलब था कि जो भी मैं टॉपिक
करा रहा हूं ड्यूरिंग द क्लास उनमें से वो
जो टॉपिक्स हैं जो जो इंपॉर्टेंट आपको
लगते हैं उन टॉपिक्स को पिक कीजिए और उन
पे जो है ना रिसर्च कीजिए, एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए। अब जैसे मैंने मित्र्रे फ्रेमवर्क
बताया या मित्र्रे का नाम लिया या
मित्र्रे जो भी बोलते हो आप तो उस पे
थोड़ा सा करना शुरू कर दिया। थ्रेट का नाम
लिया। थ्रेट इज अ टॉपिक। उस पे थोड़ा सा
एक्सप्लोर कर लिया। कुछ इस तरीके से।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
राइट? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] चलिए
स्टार्ट करते हैं। आज मुझे मैं स्टार्ट तो
कर रहा हूं बट मुझे कुछ खास मजा नहीं आ
रहा है। ये आपके अटेंडेंस को देख के। कम
से कम 200 लोग तो होने चाहिए थे एटलीस्ट।
एटलीस्ट 200 लोग होने चाहिए थी कम से कम
एटलीस्ट जिस तरीके की हमारी ओपनिंग हुई थी
बट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अगर नहीं है
तो मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अ
फ्रीक्वेंसी क्लास कि आप लोग जो बोल रहे
हैं दो बार तीन दिन होना चाहिए चार दिन
होना चाहिए मैं तो बोल रहा हूं मैं डेली
लेकर आ जाऊंगा मैं डेली आपके लिए क्लास
लेकर आ सकता हूं बट आप उतना एक्टिव रहेंगे
ही नहीं मुझे पता है वो फिर आपका लॉस हो
जाएगा इसलिए मैं डेली तो नहीं लाऊंगा
लेकिन हां अगर यह फ्रीक्वेंसी डिले हुई तो
आपके कारण होगी वो मैं उसमें कुछ नहीं कर
सकता एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर दैट आप जितना
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जोश दिखाओगे मैं
उससे डबल जोश में रहूंगा। यानी कि जोश
आपका ठंडा हुआ तो मेरा भी थोड़ा कम हो
जाएगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। राइट? अब वो तो
मेरा मोटिव है कि मैं आपको ट्रेनिंग दूं।
लेकिन अगर आपके तरफ से उस मोटिव को सपोर्ट
नहीं मिलेगा तो मुझे लगेगा कि आई एम डूइंग
समथिंग रॉन्ग। मुझे तो यही लगेगा कि मैं
कुछ गलत कर रहा हूं। राइट? बस दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वो मुझे आप फील
मत होने दो। बस यही रिक्वेस्ट है।
कोई नहीं पढ़ाता यार। मैं आपको मैं आपको
बोल के थक चुका हूं। हूं आप लोगों को फ्री
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में लाइव
ट्रेनिंग इस तरीके की कोई नहीं देता है।
कोई नहीं देगा जिसमें कोई किसी का स्वार्थ
ना हो। किसी का कोई कुछ ऐसा ना हो कि उसको
पैसे ना कमाने हो। कोई भी नहीं देता है।
तुम जाके पूछ लो यार किसी से जहां पूछना
है जिससे पूछना है पूछ लो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जाओ जिससे जहां
पता करना है कर लो। फिर भी तुम अगर नहीं आ
पा रहे हो। टाइम नहीं निकाल रहे हो।
तुम्हारे पास अगर बहाने हैं कि सर मेरा ये
एग्जाम है। सर मेरे पास टाइम मैं इस काम
में था। उस काम में था। सो इट्स वेरी सैड।
राइट?
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बिफोर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वी स्टार्ट अ
अगेन मैं आपको फिर से बता देता हूं। किसी
भी एसओसी के लाइव क्लास में जाइएगा। किसी
भी क्लास की वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। जब
भी आप ओपन करते हैं या जब भी आप देख रहे
होते हैं तो इसी वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन
में दो लिंक्स आपको मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप का लिंक मिलेगा जो कि एसओसी का
स्पेशल ग्रुप है। थर्ड ग्रुप है ये। यह भी
अब फिल होने वाला है। तो जल्दी ज्वाइन
कीजिए। एंड उसके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बाद WhatsApp
चैनल है जिसको आप जाके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
यहां पे आपको दूसरा लिंक ये मिलेगा। सॉरी
ये दूसरा लिंक। यह
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] WhatsApp चैनल
है। तो, [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां
पे भी आप इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। सारी
अपडेट्स वगैरह आपको यहीं पे सबसे पहले
मिलती है। एंड ग्रुप में टाइम टाइम टू
टाइम टू टाइम ग्रुप ओपन होगा आपका। एंड
टाइम टू टाइम जो है आपको ग्रुप का जो है अ
एक्सेस
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मिलेगा। तो आप वहां पे कम्युनिकेट कर सकते
हैं, बात कर सकते हैं। एंड जितने भी
रिसोर्सेज हैं, नोट्स हैं या जो भी चीजें
हैं वो इसी ग्रुप में आएंगी। याद रखिएगा
एसओसी के ग्रुप में ही आएंगी या फर्दर
सर्टिफिकेशन जो मैंने बोला था ट्रेनिंग के
बाद उसकी भी अपडेट उसकी भी डिटेल्स सब इसी
ग्रुप में आया करेंगी। तो ये ग्रुप
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ज्वाइन करना
मैंडेटरी है। ये बिल्कुल मैंडेटरी है। आप
इसको ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा। हो सकता है तीन
अभी थर्ड ग्रुप है। फोर्थ या फिफ्थ ग्रुप
के बाद मैं ग्रुप बनाना ही छोड़ दूं। बस
उतने क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा बच्चे हो
जाएंगे। 5000 बच्चे हो जाएंगे पांच ग्रुप
में। तो उतने बच्चों
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को टैकल कर पाना
बहुत मुश्किल हो जाएगा। तो आपको अगर आना
हो तो ग्रुप में प्लीज आ जाइएगा। इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
सॉरी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब हम
यहां पे आते हैं। ये मेरी Lindin प्रोफाइल
है। आप चाहे तो मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं।
मुझे आके यहां पे फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। इफ यू विश टू। यहां
पे ये प्रोफाइल के लिंक है। आप इस लिंक पे
भी आके हमें फॉलो कर सकते हैं। एंड यहीं
पे आपको जब डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च करेंगे आप
Lindin पे तो डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
का हमारा कंपनी का पेज मिल जाएगा। इस पेज
को आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां आपको कंपनी
से रिलेटेड अपडेट्स मिल जाएंगे। और यह
हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक्स का
Twitter यानी कि एक्स पेज है। आप इसको
जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। इट्स वेरी वेरीेंट
क्योंकि यहां पे कुछ-कुछ ऐसी चीजें आने
वाली है आने वाले टाइम में सीटीएफ एंड
एसओसी एंड लैब्स के रिगार्डिंग जो आपको
मजा आएगा आपको मतलब यहां पे आप अगर यहां
पे एक्टिव होते हैं तो तो Twitter पेज
Twitter का प्रोफाइल तो सबके पास होना भी
चाहिए। Twitter इज़ वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग
या X का। चलिए अब बिफोर वी स्टार्ट एक चीज
और मैं आप सबों से डिस्कस करना चाहता हूं।
एक जो जो चीज है मैं और मैं आपको बताना
चाहता हूं। हमारे लारा बिनेस नंबर है उस
पे हमें मैसेज आते रहते हैं। बहुत सारे
मैसेजेस आते हैं। हमारे पास मैसेज आए हैं
WhatsApp बिनेस पे कुछ लोगों के कि सर
प्रैक्टिकल
कब शुरू होगा एसओसी में? सर प्रैक्टिकल
कुछ शुरू कर दो। ऐसे कर दो, वैसे कर दो।
जबकि मैंने पहले भी इस क्लास के पहले भी
मैंने बताया हुआ है इसके बारे में कि
प्रैक्टिकल जैसी चीज पे अगर सिर्फ आप
डिपेंड रहते हैं तो एसओसी में आप करियर
नहीं बना सकते हैं। आप एसओसी में अच्छा
एक्सेल नहीं कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
प्रैक्टिकल तो होगी। प्रैक्टिकल इज अ
पार्ट ऑफ दिस ट्रेनिंग। बट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बिना थ्यरी और
बिना कांसेप्ट को समझे उस प्रैक्टिकल का
कोई यूज़ केस नहीं है। कोई नहीं कुछ नहीं
समझ में आएगा। और एसओसी में थ्यरी का बहुत
बड़ा रोल है। तो जब कांसेप्ट्स और थ्योरी
चल रहे हैं तो उस पे फोकस कीजिए। उसको
समझिए और उसी को इंप्लीमेंट करेंगे आप
प्रैक्टिकल में। याद रखिएगा दैट विल बी
इंप्लीमेंटेड। तो जब एक बार आपने पढ़
लिया, सीख लिया, समझ लिया, जब आप
प्रैक्टिकल के थ्रू उसको डेमोंस्ट्रेट
करेंगे सेम चीज को तो आपके दिमाग में वो
परमानेंट फिट हो जाएगा। और उसी को हम
स्किल बोलते हैं। स्किल उसी को कहा जाता
है।
मेमोराइज तो कोई भी कर लेता है बट स्किल
गेन करना इज वेरी डिफिकल्ट थिंग।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है?
तो बस जैसा मैं बताते चलूं प्लीज आप उसको
फॉलो करते चलिए। ये रिक्वेस्ट है आपसे।
दैट्स इट। मेरे साइड से यही है। आई होप कि
अच्छा आप लोग शेयर अच्छा आप लोग शेयर करते
हैं क्या वीडियोस को? मुझे एक बार बताइए।
आप लोग शेयर करते हैं कोई करता है क्या
शेयर वीडियोस को? और शेयर करते हैं तो
स्क्रीनशॉट रखते हैं शेयर करने का? वो
मैंने जो बताया था कि गिफ्ट वाउचर वाली
चीज जो बताई थी तो उसमें क्योंकि एज अ
प्रूफ ऑब्वियस सी बात है चाहिए होगी थोड़ी
सी। नहीं तो फिर ऐसे कोई भी कुछ भी बोल
देगा।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो आप में से कोई है जो शेयर करता है या
उसके स्क्रीनशॉट्स वगैरह रखता है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
क्योंकि [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आप लोग
शेयर देखो
अब आप सोच अगर आप शेयर नहीं करते वीडियोस
को तो प्लीज शेयर कीजिएगा मैं आपको इसका
एक वो बता देता हूं क्यों मैं ऐसा बोलता
हूं। हमने [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डिसाइड किया है कि हम एक टाइम के बाद जैसे
वन वीक या 10 दिन पे एक ड्रॉ करेंगे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ड्रॉ का मतलब
है कि हम एक ग्रुप में जितने भी ग्रुप्स
हैं सब में हम एक मैसेज डालेंगे एक फॉर्म
के थ्रू आपने जो भी शेयर जहां-जहां भी
शेयर करे हैं वीडियोस को तो स्क्रीनशॉट के
साथ उसमें आपको बताना पड़ेगा कि हां मैंने
ये चीज शेयर करी है और स्क्रीनशॉट उसी डेट
की होनी चाहिए। ये नहीं कि अभी तुरंत
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया कहीं शेयर कर दिया उस
टाइम पे नहीं जिस डेट को भी यह चीज अनाउंस
होगी उसके एक दिन पहले तक की शेयर जो भी
शेयरिंग आपने करी होगी वो काउंट होगा
जिसकी सबसे ज्यादा शेयर होगी वैसे तीन
लोगों को टॉप थ्री लोगों को या टॉप फाइव
लोग भी हो सकते हैं वो हम पे डिपेंड करता
है कितने लोगों को देना है हम जोatो के
गिफ्ट वाउचर्स प्रोवाइड करेंगे अब देखो अब
इसमें आप में से कई लोग यह सोच सकते हैं
कि सर ऐसा क्यों कर रहे हैं आप गिफ्ट
वाउचर्स क्यों दे रहे हैं एक तो हमें
ट्रेनिंग भी दे रहे हैं इस तरह की
क्वालिटी की ऊपर से हमें रिवॉर्ड भी दे
रहे इसका मत इसका रीज़न बस इतना है कि ये
वीडियो ये जो वीडियोस है प्लेलिस्ट है वो
उन लोगों तक भी पहुंचे जहां तक पहले नहीं
पहुंच सकती थी। राइट? जैसे बहुत लोग
नॉर्मली शेयर नहीं करते हैं। बट अगर जब हम
ऐसी कोई चीज लेकर आएंगे तो बहुत सारे लोग
शेयर करेंगे और जब शेयर आप लोग करोगे तो
ये वीडियोस उन तक पहुंचेगी जहां तक पहले
नहीं पहुंच पा रही थी। तो हमारा यह मोटिव
एक छोटे से प्लान का एक मोटिव यह है कि
वीडियो को मैक्सिमम जगह पे पहुंचा देना जो
भी एसओसी या साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
इंटरेस्टेड बंदे हैं। बस यही मोटिव है
नथिंग एल्स।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
टी
टीएचएम का भी हां ट्राईक का भी वाउचर हम
दे सकते हैं। यस अगर किसी को देखो जो भी
विनर्स होंगे हम उनको ऑप्शन दे देंगे कि
Zomato का गिफ्ट वाउचर चाहिए तुम्हें
ब्लिंकिट का चाहिए sविg instाam का चाहिए।
ट्राई हैक मी का तुम्हें वाउचर चाहिए वन
मंथ का जो होता है जो भी ऑप्शन सारे ऑप्शन
दे देंगे जो उसको चूज़ करना होगा वो चूज़
करेगा वी विल प्रोवाइड देम दैट पर्टिकुलर
वाउचर दैट्स इट ठीक है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब तो सही है अब तो बिल्कुल सही है ना
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो अब तो
सही है भाई
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलो दैट्स कूल चलो 186 पीपल हैव जॉइ
नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
और हां Lindin पे आप लोग प्लीज आप लोग
पोस्ट करते रहिएगा ये देखिए कितने लोग
पोस्ट करते हैं एंड आई एम एक्सट्रीमली
हैप्पी एक्सट्रीमली एक्सट्रीमली हैप्पी
मतलब ये देखो काफी लोग पोस्ट करते हैं
यहां पे ये देखो ये इन्होंने पोस्ट किया
है शेख निजायुद्दीन ने विदिशा दे इन्होंने
पोस्ट किया है आकाश वर्मा इन्होंने पोस्ट
किया है। अ देन यहां पे मोक्ष ने पोस्ट
किया है। राइट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अंशिका ने पोस्ट किया है। सूरज ने देयर आर
अ लॉट ऑफ़ पीपल पोस्टिंग अबाउट दिस एसोसिएट
ट्रेनिंग एंड आई एम रियली हैप्पी। आई एम
रियली हैप्पी एंड आई एम ओवरवेम्ड। काफी
अच्छा लगता है जब आप ऐसे करते हैं तो
पोस्ट कीजिए एंड पॉइंट्स लिखिए। जैसे मान
लो लेट्स सपोज कि इन्होंने
इन्होंने [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मान लो
कि ये करा है मान लो ये मैंने इन्होंने
पोस्ट किया है। ठीक है? तो इन्होंने एक
टॉपिक पोस्ट किया है यहां पे और यहां पे
नोट्स डाले हैं इन्होंने। अच्छी बात है।
ये भी आप कर सकते हैं। अगर आपको नोट्स
डालना है अपने नोट्स भी आप डाल सकते हैं।
अदरवाइज आप पॉइंट्स लिख सकते हैं। जैसे
बहुत लोग पॉइंट्स जैसे इन्होंने शेख
इन्होंने जब डाला है तो इन्होंने पॉइंट्स
लिखा हुआ है कि क्या है? कैसे-कैसे
पॉइंट्स हैं। वैसे भी आप कर सकते हैं।
इससे आपकी अपनी लर्निंग भी होगी अच्छी और
आपको मजा भी आएगा। ठीक है? और हमें भी पता
चलेगा और हमें टैग कर दीजिएगा डे यानी कि
डिफ्रॉनिक्स को टैग कर दीजिएगा। चलिए बहुत
सारी बातें हो गई। अब जो है आज की जर्नी
हमारी स्टार्ट करते हैं। डे कौन सा है डे?
डे फोर है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो लेट्स स्टार्ट विद डे फोर। द
इंटरेस्टिंग डे फोर। इंटरेस्टिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग डे फोर। चलिए
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके गाइस
बनते हैं एसओ सी एल वन वि डे फोर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आज हम स्टार्ट करते हैं एक बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक के साथ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हमारे एसओसी के जो कि काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
एंड इन चीजों के बिना एसओसी अधूरा है
एसओसी में आप कुछ कर नहीं पाएंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
मैं तभी बोलता हूं। ठीक है? तभी बोलता हूं
कि फोकस फोकस टॉपिक्स पे फोकस करो। और
मुझे लगता है बहुत लोग समझ गए हैं। आई नो
बहुत लोग समझ गए हैं। बहुत लोग हो सकता है
नहीं भी समझो। धीरे-धीरे समझ जाएंगे
क्योंकि ये कितना इंपॉर्टेंट है। अब अब
मुझे ये बताओ यार कि मैं आपको एक जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग ट्रेनिंग दे रहा हूं। तो मुझे
पता है ना कैसे डिलीवर करना है। तो उस पे
ट्रस्ट तो करो थोड़ा। भरोसा तो करो कि अगर
थ्यरी चल रही है तो किसी रीज़न से चल रही
है। प्रैक्टिकल आएगा तो किसी रीज़न से
आएगा। उसके एडवांस और होंगी तो किसी रीज़न
से होंगी। तो उस पे भरोसा करो थोड़ा यार
क्योंकि ये चीजें नहीं समझोगे ना तो
इंटरव्यू नहीं क्रैक कर पाओगे। मैं गारंटी
के साथ लिख के दो इंटरव्यू में तुम्हारे
सामने एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड खोल के नहीं दे
देंगे वो एसआईएम का कि भैया यहां पे ये
काम करो भैया यहां पे ये चीज करो ये
पॉसिबल नहीं है। इट्स नॉट पॉसिबल वो नहीं
होता है ऐसे जनरली जनरली कहां होता है।
नॉट नॉट पॉसिबल।
सो थोड़ा समझना है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] थोड़ा इस चीज को
ना समझना है। यू हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड दिस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओके? चलिए।
सो लेट्स स्टार्ट विद द टीटीपीस। द फर्स्ट
वन इज़ टीटीपीस। टैक्टिक्स, टेक्निक्स एंड
प्रोसीजर्स इन एसओसी।
सुनने में काफी नॉर्मल सा लग रहा है।
टीटीपीस बट बा इसके काम बहुत बड़े हैं।
एक-एक चीज को समझेंगे। एक-एक चीज़ को दिमाग
में घुसा लेंगे। अब सभी लोग इधर ध्यान
देंगे। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] किसी को
नहीं भूला मैं। अभी मैं चैट पे ध्यान नहीं
दे रहा। मैं किसी को भूला नहीं हूं।
अह जस्ट जस्ट आई एम नॉट फोकसिंग ऑन चैट।
आप भी फोकस मत करो चैट पे। आप इधर आ जाओ।
ठीक है भैया? इधर आ जाओ। किसी को मैं नहीं
भूला।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
दे डिस्क्राइब हाउ अटैकर्स थिंक एक्ट एंड
ऑपरेट ड्यूरिंग अ साइबर अटैक। टीटीपीस का
मतलब होता है टीटीपीस क्या हमें डिनोट
करता है? यह डिनोट करता है कि एक हैकर जो
है वो किस तरीके से थिंक करता है, एक्ट
करता है एंड ऑपरेट करता है एक साइबर अटैक
के टाइम पे। दैट्स इट। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड टीपी।
इफ एन आईओसी टेल्स यू व्हाट हैपेंड
टीटीपीस टेल्स यू हाउ एंड व्हाई इट
हैपेंड। अब आईओसीस क्या है? बता दीजिए
मुझे। अगर आपको मैंने एक टर्म बोला हुआ है
ये पहले भी। मैंने इसको बहुत डिटेल में
एक्सप्लेन नहीं करा है। आज करूंगा बट
बताइए आप में से अगर किसी को याद है आईओसी
का तो। इफ यू रिमेंबर अबाउट आईओसी लेट मी
नो। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बताइए
लेट मी नो गाइस लेट मी नो गाइस देखते हैं
ना कितने लोगों को याद आए यस बिल्कुल सही
बिल्कुल [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सही
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज आईओसी को हम बोलते हैं
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज अब आपके दिमाग
से ये निकल गया होगा कि इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज क्या होता है तो हम उस पे
आएंगे और उसको देखेंगे उसको समझेंगे भी।
उस पे भी हम आएंगे। आईओसी पे भी याद है हम
आएंगे। याद रखिएगा ये टर्म याद रखिएगा। तो
फिलहाल के लिए हम टीटीपीस पे हैं।
टैक्टिक्स, टेक्निक्स एंड प्रोसीजर। तो ये
जो तीनों चीजें हैं ये क्या डिस्क्राइब
करती हैं? हाउ अटैकर थिंक, एक्ट एंड
ऑपरेट। जब वो अटैकर अटैक करता है किसी भी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे तो वो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कैसे सोच रहा होता है, कैसे वो एक्ट कर
रहा होता है? एंड कैसे वो एग्जीक्यूशन कर
रहा होता है, ऑपरेट कर रहा होता है उस
अटैक के लिए। तो टीटीपी आपको बताता है
आईओसी तो बताता है कि क्या हुआ था? व्हाट
हैपेंड? क्या हुआ? एंड टीटीपी बोलता है
व्हाई एंड हाउ हैपेंड? मतलब होता है ना?
अरे भाई कोई अटैक हुआ? अरे यार क्या हुआ?
तो ये है आपका आईओसी। टीटीपी क्या हुआ?
अरे भाई कैसे हुआ यार? क्यों हुआ यार? यह
आपका टीटीपी है। समझ में आ गया? सो टीटीपी
इज़ लाइक दैट। कैसे हुआ? क्यों हुआ? आईओसी
क्या हुआ? ये चीज़ है। समझ में आ गया? ये
समझ में आ गई होगी आपको। क्या हुआ? पूछे
तो आईओसी है। और अगर क्यों?
कैसे हुआ? तो वो हमारा टीटीपी है। दैट्स
इट। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टैक्टिक्स,
टेक्निक्स एंड प्रोसीजर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब आते हैं
एसओसी एनालिस्ट जो होते हैं वो टीटीपी का
यूज़ क्यों करते हैं? दे यूज़ टीटीपीस टू
डिटेक्ट अटैक्स इवन व्हेन आईओसी चेंज।
यह डिटेक्ट करने के लिए करते हैं अटैक को।
इवन आईओसी अगर बदल जाए, चेंज हो जाए,
आईओसी बदल जाए मतलब व्हाट हैपेंड? मतलब यह
हो सकता है ना कि इसका आंसर कुछ भी हो
सकता है। व्हाट हैपेंड? तो मल्टीपल आंसर्स
हो सकते हैं कि क्या हुआ था? अरे वो एक
अननोन आईपी से रिक्वेस्ट आई थी। अच्छा
नहीं नहीं वो तो आईपी जो है ना वो इंटरनल
आईपी है। अच्छा नहीं ये तो एक ब्लैक
लिस्टेड आईपी थी। पता नहीं आई थिंक बाईपास
कर लिया। तो देयर कैन बी मल्टीपल व्स। तो
जो आपका एसओसी एनालिस्ट होता है वो टीटीपी
को यूज करके अटैक्स को डिटेक्ट करने की
कोशिश करता है। इवन आईओसीस अलग-अलग हो जाए
तो। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
दैट्स इट। अंडरस्टैंड अटैकर इंटेंट। अटैकर
के इंटेंट को समझने की कोशिश करता है कि
भैया क्यों आप ये क्यों करने आया है? यह
ऐसा क्यों कर रहा है? व्हाई इट इज़ ही इज़
डूइंग? हाउ ही इज डूइंग और शी इज डूइंग जो
भी अटैकर है हाउ दे आर डूइंग राइट यहां पर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जेंडर बायस नहीं बनना है मुझे तो दे मैं
बोल देता हूं ठीक है अटैकर भाई मेल भी हो
सकता है फीमेल भी हो सकता है एंड आप में
से कहीं कोई
वो ना हो जाए मेल फीमेल को लेके सो थोड़ा
दे दे इज़ वेरी गुड
मेरे भी नोन में है जो मेल फीमेल को लेके
काफी वो हो जाते हैं एक्साइटेड हो जाते
हैं थोड़ा तो थोड़ा सोचना सोचना पड़ेगा मुझे
अब तो अटैकर इज़ दे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अटैकर इज़ दे ठीक
है [हंसी]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बिल्ड बेटर डिटेक्शंस अलर्ट्स एंड
रिस्पांस प्लेबुक्स दैट्स इट सिंपल कि ये
टीटीपीस का यूज़ करके बेटर डिटेक्शन बनाते
हैं। डिटेक्शन करने की क्षमता उसको और भी
बेटर करते हैं। अलर्ट्स बेटर अलर्ट्स आ
जाए एंड एक बेटर रिस्पांस जो है उसका मिल
जाए। अलर्ट्स बेटर का मतलब है यहां पे
अलर्ट्स जो हैं उस वो एक रूल के थ्रू आते
हैं। एक सेट ऑफ रूल्स के थ्रू अलर्ट्स आते
हैं। तो एक अच्छा रूल प्रिपेयर करना अपने
लिए डिटेक्शंस प्रिपेयर करना और रिस्पांस
ये सब काम के लिए टीडीटीपीस का यूज़ में
लिया जाता है। अब यहां पे दो चीजें मैंने
आपको बताई है। कुछ एक बंदा पूछ रहा था सर
टास्क में मतलब कैसे करना होता है? क्या
करना होता है? टास्क भी आप देते हो क्या?
वैसे तो अभी तक मैंने इतना कुछ खास आपको
दिया नहीं है। बट मैं रेग वीडियोस के अंदर
में लाइव के अंदर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपको रेगुलर
बेसिस पे कुछ-कुछ कभी-कभी टास्क दे सकता
हूं। ऐसा नहीं कि मैंडेटरी बट कुछ-कुछ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
टास्क दे सकता हूं। राइट?
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उन टास्क्स
को आप पूरा करेंगे। ठीक है? वो टास्क
हालांकि मैं दूंगा बट मैं भी आपको
बताऊंगा। मैं भी आपको समझाऊंगा। बट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] स्टिल
ओके।
तो द थिंग इज यहां पर है साइबर किल चेन
एंड मित्र्रे अटैक बोल लो वैसे अटैक लिखा
नहीं होता है बट यू कैन से इट मैथ्रे अटैक
या मथ्रे अटैक ठीक है अब साइबर किल चेन एक
टर्म होता है और एक मथ्रे अटैक होता है ये
दोनों बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है इन एसओसी दीज़ आर
वेरी वेरी वेरीेंट वीवी वीवी एक होता है
ना वीवीआई जो स्कूल में लिखते थे अह
क्वेश्चंस के लिए एग्जाम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] के पहले वीवीआई
क्वेश्चन मतलब वेरी वेरी वेरीेंट क्वेश्चन
वीआई वेरीेंट क्वेश्चन आईएेंट क्वेश्चन तो
वीवीआई वाला
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब देखो साइबर किलचेन एंड मैथ्री ये क्या
है ये दोनों एक फ्रेमवर्क है एक फ्रेमवर्क
है साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क यू कैन से
ये फ्रेमवर्क बनाया साइबर किलचेन को बनाया
गया था एक सेट ऑफ फ्रेमवर्क एक सेट ऑफ
प्रोसेस बनाया गया जिससे कि अटैकर जो है
क्या-क्या स्टेप्स जो है ना वह एग्जीक्यूट
करते हैं टू लॉन्च अ साइबर अटैक इसको
कंपनीज़ को बताने के लिए ताकि कंपनीज़ उन
स्टेप्स को अच्छे से समझ पाए और उसके
अगेंस्ट जो है वो एक डिफेंड मैकेनिज्म जो
है वो लेकर आ पाए। एक डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म यू
कैन से लेकर आ पाए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] राइट? अब साइबर
किलचेन एंड मथ्रे जो है इसको हम डिटेल में
भी बाद में समझेंगे। बट अभी थोड़ा सा
डिस्कस कर लेते हैं। ये एक सेपरेट टॉपिक
है आपका। मथ्रे अटैक तो बिल्कुल है ही है
ही। क्योंकि मथ्रे इज़ वेरीेंट इन एसओसी
एंड बाद में हम साइबर किल चेन का भी उसी
में करेंगे। एंड एपीटी हां हां एपीटी भी
एपीटी भी हमारे ज़ोन में है। एपीटी इज़
आल्सो वेरीेंट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। अब यहां पे जो साइबर किल चेन का
स्टेज होता है यानी कि एक अटैकर किन
स्टेप्स से होके साइबर अटैक जो है ल्च
करता है। एंड कंपनीज़ को ये स्टेप्स पता
होने चाहिए ताकि इसी के अगेंस्ट वो एक
डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म तैयार कर सके। पहला होता
है रिकॉनसेंस। यह आप में से कई लोग को पता
होगा। इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग। इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग की जाती है टैकर के द्वारा। देन
होता [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] है
वेपनाइजेशन। तब वेपनाइजेशन। वो वेपंस को
तैयार करते हैं। वेपन्स का मतलब है जो
आपके पेलोड होते हैं। जो आपका पेलोड जो
अटैकर का बेसिकली पेलोड होता है जो कि एक
एक्सप्लइट को एग्जीक्यूशन करने का काम
करता है। एक एक्सप्लइट को एग्जीक्यूट करता
है एक सिस्टम पे। तो वो वेपनाइजेशन होती
है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां इनरेशन इज ऑलरेडी इनसाइड इन यू कैन से
कि
रेकोसेंस में उसको इंक्लूड कर लो आप
डिलीवरी उस पेड को डिलीवर करना वहां जो भी
आपका टारगेट जो भी टारगेट है उसका उस
एक्टर अटैकर का वहां डिलीवर करना उस पेलोड
को। ठीक है? तो उस पेलोड को डिलीवर करने
का काम इस डिलीवरी फेज में होता है। तब
आती है एक्सप्लॉयटेशन। अब उस पर्टिकुलर
पेलोड से एक्सप्लइट करना उस सिस्टम को। उस
सिस्टम के डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट पार्ट्स जो हैं
उनको एक्सप्लइट करना, डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
सर्विसेस को एक्सप्लइट करना। जिस चीज़ के
लिए वो बना हुआ है उसको एग्ज़क्यूट करना।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देन है
इंस्टॉलेशन, कमांड, कंट्रोल एंड एक्शन ऑन
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे आ
जाती है इंस्टॉलेशन की, कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
की एंड एक्शन ऑन ऑब्जेक्टिव। जब
एक्सप्लइट्स हो जाते हैं, सारी चीज़
एक्सप्लइट हो गई। तो अब आपकी जो ये
पर्टिकुलर पेलोड होती है, उसके थ्रू एक
बैकडोर इंस्टॉल कर दिया जाता है सिस्टम
पे। बैकडोर का मतलब है कि अगर बाय चांस
उनका एक्सेस चला जाता है किसी भी तरीके से
किसी भी रीजन से तो वो
इंस्टॉलेशन जो है बैकडोर की कर देते हैं
ताकि बाद में फ्यूचर में वो अगेन
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सके उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
को दैट्स इट देन कमांड एंड कंट्रोल जो
जहां से जिसको हम सीएनसी सर्वर्सर्स
सीएनसी बोलते हैं। कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
अटैकर का सेटअप हो जाता है। जहां से वो
सारी चीजें एक साथ लॉन्च करेगा। सारी
चीजें कंट्रोल करेगा। ए टू जेड चीजें
कमांड्स ल्च करेगा। अलग-अलग तरह के
कमांड्स देगा जो उस तरीके से अपना पेलोड
काम करेंगे एंड देन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो भी उसके
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स होंगे वो ऑब्जेक्टिव अपना
फुलफिल करेगा। व्हाटएवर हिज ऑब्जेक्टिव
देयर ऑब्जेक्टिव आर राइट या C2 कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल इज़ C2 वही है C2 सर्वर या सीएनसी
जो भी है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक
है? अब ये आपको ये जो हो गया ये हो गया
साइबर किल चेन का प्रोसेस। अब इसी तरीके
से माइथ अटैक जो होती है उसका भी एक टेिक
होता है। अब इसमें जो है यह थोड़ा सा
डिफरेंट है क्योंकि यह जो स्पेसिफिकली है
एसओसी जैसे एनवायरमेंट में मथ्रे अटैक या
मथ्रे फ्रेमवर्क को ही फॉलो किया जाता है।
ये भी एक सेट ऑफ फ्रेमवर्क ही है जिसको
फॉलो हम करते हैं। दैट्स इट। अगर आप
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अगर मैं आपको
वैसे दिखाऊं [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अगर मैं यहां पे आपको माय थ्रे अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क सर्च करूं आपके लिए
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो मैं यहां पे
ओपन कर लेता हूं। तो यहां पे आपको देखिएगा
मिलेगा
व्हेन सिक्योरिटी टीम्स रेस्पोंड्स टू अ
ब्रच दे फेस अ फैमिलियर प्रॉब्लम दे मस्ट
रिकंस्ट्रक्ट अ थ्रेट एक्टर्स पाथ
इंक्लूडिंग विदाउट अ पाथ विदाउट रिलाइंग
ऑन कंसिस्टेंट इंडिकेटर्स मतलब हमेशा
इंडिकेटर्स पे डिपेंड हो के सब कुछ नहीं
होता है। तो जब कोई अटैक होता है ना तो जो
पर्टिकुलर सिक्योरिटी टीम होती है उनको
रिकंस्ट्रक्ट करना पड़ता है वो पूरा
सिनेरियो जैसे आपने देखा होगा जब क्राइम
होती है जब कोई भी ऐसा क्राइम होता है
क्राइम सीन को रिकंस्ट्रक्ट किया जाता है
सीबीआई वगैरह जब भी इन्वेस्टिगेशन करती है
तो आपने सुना होगा कि क्राइम सीन को री
रिकंस्ट्रक्ट किया जा रहा है। ठीक है ना?
दोबारा से ताकि एक आईडिया लगाया जा सके कि
आखिर यह क्राइम या यह जो अटैक है वह किस
तरीके से किस
प्रोसेस से हुआ है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है? मैलवेयर
फैमिली चेंज इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर शिफ्ट्स एंड
टूल्स वैरी फ्रॉम वन इंट्रोजन टू द
नेक्स्ट। हर इंट्रोजन जो है दूसरे
इंट्रोजन से अलग होती है। हर अटैक एक
दूसरे अटैक से बिल्कुल अलग होता है। येट द
कोर बिहेवियर ऑफेन लुक द सेम। बट जो कोर
फंक्शनैलिटी होता है वो हमेशा सेम होता
है। जो कोर अटैक का पैटर्न होता है वो
हमेशा सेम होता है। ठीक है?
द माइक्रो अटैक फ्रेमवर्क एड्रेसेस दिस
चैलेंज बाय डॉक्यूमेंटिंग हाउ एडवर्सरीज
ऑपरेट इन प्रैक्टिस। इट डिफाइन द
टैक्टिक्स दैट रिप्रेजेंट एन अटैकर्स
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स एंड टेक्निक्स। माय
फ्रेमवर्क्स अटैकर का ऑब्जेक्टिव और
टेक्निक्स को रिीडफाइन करता है। बस डिफाइन
करता है। दैट्स इट। और कुछ भी नहीं। दे
अप्लाई टू अचीव दोज़ ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। जो वो
अचीव करते हैं ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। जिस चीज को
जिस पर्टिकुलर अ टेक्निक को अप्लाई करके
वो जो अपना ऑब्जेक्टिव अचीव करते हैं उसी
को ये डिस्क्राइब करता है मत्री
फ्रेमवर्क। अच्छा इसको आप ऐसे कंपैरिजन कर
लो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। ओएस टॉप 10 आपने
सुना है? बताइए आपने ओएस टॉप 10 सुना है?
बताइए मुझे। हैव यू हर्ड अबाउट ओएस टॉप
10?
हम [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[हंसी]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां अब ओएस टॉप 10 भी ना एक तरह का
फ्रेमवर्क है बट वो पता है किसके लिए है
स्पेशली पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स के लिए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स के लिए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स जो है ओएस फ्रेमवर्क को फॉलो
करते हैं मोस्टली राइट यह फ्रेमवर्क वेब
पेन टेस्टिंग से ज़्यादा कनेक्टेड मतलब एक
फ्रेमवर्क है। यानी कि मोस्टली जब
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते हैं अटैकर्स तो
ओएस को जरूर अ जो है फॉलो करते हैं। उसी
तरीके से जब हम एसओसी की बात कर रहे हैं
तो हम यहां पे समझ लीजिए मथ्रे फ्रेमवर्क
की बात कर रहे हैं। यानी कि इस फ्रेमवर्क
को फॉलो करते हुए एंड अटैकर्स के
पाथ को रिकंस्ट्रक्ट किया जाता है कि आखिर
उसने फ्रेमवर्क के अकॉर्डिंग कैसे-कैसे
कैसे-कैसे किया है। सब कुछ अटैक सब कुछ
प्लान किया है। एवरीथिंग
दैट्स इट।
ईच एंट्री [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इज
बेस्ड ऑन रियल इन्वेस्टिगेशंस कंडक्टेड
बाय रिस्चर्स एंड इंसिडेंट रिस्पोंडर्स
व्हिच ग्राउंड्स द फ्रेमवर्क इन व्हाट
टर्म्स टू इन व्हाट टीम्स एनकाउंटर इनाइड
एक्चुअल एनवायरमेंट्स। सिंपल सा बात है।
इस फ्रेमवर्क में जितने भी एंट्रीज हैं वो
सब किस पे बेस्ड हैं? रियल इन्वेस्टिगेशंस
किनके द्वारा किया गया है? रिस्चर्स एंड
इंसिडेंट रिसोंडर्स के द्वारा किया गया
है। व्हिच ग्राउंड्स द फ्रेमवर्क इन व्हाट
टीम्स एनकाउंटर इनसाइड एक्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट्स जो एक्चुअल एनवायरमेंट में
जिस तरीके से प्रॉब्लम्स एनकाउंटर किया
जाता है एसओसी टीम के द्वारा उसी को इसने
पर्टिकुलर इस पर्टिकुलर फ्रेमवर्क ने
कंडक्ट किया अपने अंदर। इसलिए ये जो है ये
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। फॉर सिक्योरिटी टीम्स
दिस टर्न्स मत फ्रेमवर्क इंटू बोथ अ
रेफरेंस एंड अ प्लेबुक। मतलब एक रेफरेंस
भी है और एक प्लेबुक की तरह भी इसको
सिक्योरिटी टीम्स लेती है। द फ्रेमवर्क
एक्सप्लेंस हाउ इट्स इट्स इट्स मैट्रिससेस
आर ऑर्गेनाइज्ड व्हिच प्लेटफॉर्म्स एंड
एनवायरमेंट्स दे कवर एंड हाउ टैक्टिक्स
एंड टेक्निक्स कनेक्ट फ्रॉम वन फेज ऑफ़ एन
अटैक टू द नेक्स्ट। यही टैक्टिक्स और
टेक्निक जिसकी मैं बात कर रहा था
जिस जिसकी मैं यहां पे बात कर रहा था
टीटीपीस की टैक्टिक्स एंड टेक्निक्स की तो
इसी टैक्टिक्स एंड टेक्निक्स की बात हो
रही है। बाद में तो प्रोसीजर है ही बट
यहां टैक्टिक्स और टेक्निक्स को ये कनेक्ट
करने का काम करता है कि किस तरह का
टैक्टिक और किस तरह का टेक्निक जो है यूज़
किया जा रहा है अटैकर के द्वारा। दैट्स
इट। ये बहुत बड़ी चीज है। बहुत बड़ी चीज
है। अब इस मथ्रे फ्रेमवर्क को तो हम बाद
में बहुत डिटेल में पढ़ेंगे। बहुत डिटेल
में हम समझेंगे क्योंकि हमारा ये पार्ट
है। अगर आपको नहीं पता तो मैं बता देता
हूं। इट्स द पार्ट ऑफ़ एसओसी ट्रेनिंग एंड
इसको डिटेल में पढ़ना भी हमारा पार्ट है
क्योंकि ये काफी इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है।
राइट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
राइट तो एक शॉर्ट में माइक्रो फ्रेमवर्क
के अंदर क्या होता है? पहले रिकॉनसेंस देन
रिसोर्स की डेवलपमेंट होती है जो भी
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट इनिशियल एक्सेस पहले
होता है देन एग्जीक्यूशन होती है उस
पर्टिकुलर पेलोड की देन पर्सिस्टेंस
क्रिएट किया जाता है जिससे बार-बार अटैक
जो है वो लॉन्च किया जा सके बार-बार वो
अटैक को कभी हटाया ना जा सके उस पर्टिकुलर
पेलोड को प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन नॉर्मल यूजर
से एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर डिफेंस इवेशन
मतलब कोई किसी भी तरह का डिफेंस है तो
उसको इवेट करना उससे बचना जैसे कोई
एंटीवायरस है ईडीआर है एक्सडीआर है
क्रेडेंशियल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एक्सेस किसी भी तरह का कोई क्रेडेंशियल है
उसको एक्सेस लेना। डिस्कवरी कि अब इनरेशन
जिसको आप बोल रहे हैं डिस्कवर करना।
अलग-अलग और जो डिवाइसेस हैं और कोई ऐसी
नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस या और समथिंग ऑन द अ
नेटवर्क उसको लैटरल मूवमेंट नेटवर्क में
एक डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस पे स्विच करना।
एक कंप्यूटर से दूसरे कंप्यूटर में कूद
जाना, एक कंप्यूटर से दूसरे कंप्यूटर को
अह जो है वो
इंपैक्ट डालना उस पे या इफ़ेक्ट करना यू
कैन से। तो वो लैटरल मूवमेंट के अंदर ही
आता है। ठीक है? मतलब इनफेक्ट अगर कर दे
एक कंप्यूटर से दूसरे कंप्यूटर को इनफेक्ट
कर दे वो चीज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कलेक्शन देन
कलेक्शन करना अ लॉग्स या जो भी डेटावटा
व्हाटएवर कलेक्शन जो भी उसको जो भी उसको
चाहिए भाई वो सब कलेक्ट करना कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सी एंड सी या C2 एंड देन
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन निकालना व्हाटएवर निकालना
जो और फिर लास्ट में इंपैक्ट तो उसका जो
इंपैक्ट है वो इंपैक्ट है। दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बिल्कुल सही। तो
हम इस पे आएंगे हम पाइवोटिंग पे, लैटरल
मूवमेंट पे, मत अटैक पे, साइबर किल चेन पे
इन सब पे हम बहुत डिटेल में पढ़ेंगे।
क्योंकि ये एक अलग ही सेपरेट टॉपिक्स हैं।
इनको अगर हम Myra अटैक पे बात करने लगे तो
उस पे तो दो-तीन क्लासेस चल सकती हैं। My
एंड ये लेटर मूवमेंट और इन सब पे जो है
बहुत लंबा क्लास चल सकता है। तो हम उस पे
भी आएंगे। उसके लिए आप बेफिक्र रहिए। आई
विल 100% टेल यू अबाउट ऑल दिस। ठीक है?
फिलहाल जो इंपॉर्टेंट है पहले उस पे आते
हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
व्हाई टीटीपीसेंट
इन अ एसओसी? भैया
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है ये टीटीपी भैया जो है हमारे
ये क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है? व्हाई इट इज़ेंट?
इसका भी हमें जानकारी होना चाहिए। व्हाई
दिस इज़ेंट? सो सबसे पहले इमेजिन दिस रियल
वर्ल्ड एग्जांपल। आईओसी क्या होते हैं? अ
मास्क पर्सन वाज़ सीन। आईओसी क्या बोलेगा?
एक मास्क पर्सन को देखा गया था। टीटीपी
क्या बोलेगा? द अटैकर ब्रोक द लॉक। ठीक
है? मतलब एक मास्क पर्सन अटैकर को माना जा
रहा है। यहां पे अटैकर इज़ बीइंग कंसीडर्ड
हियर। टीटीपी में क्या है? द अटैकर ब्रोक
द लॉक। अटैकर ने लॉक तोड़ा। एंटर्ड थ्रू द
बैक डोर। बैक डोर से घुसा। डिसेबल्ड
सीसीटीवी एंडस्केप्ड वाया द फायर एग्जिट।
मतलब ये पूरा का पूरा एक डिटेल जो है ना
वो डिटेल में यहां पे आपकी एक्सप्लेनेशन
देगा आपकी टीटीपी। दैट्स इट।
गॉट इट
गॉट इट ये चीज है क्या हुआ है अ सर
न्यूक्लियर स्कैन से अ मीडियम लेवल की
वनेबिलिटी मिली तो डायरेक्टली रिपोर्ट कर
करें क्या इन माय केस इट वाज़ प्रोटो कर
सकते हो अगर आप चेन अप करके देख लो चेन
करके अभी वो बग की क्लास नहीं है तो मैं
ज्यादा इस पे डिस्कस नहीं करूंगा जिस पे
हम जिस क्लास में हम उसी के बारे में
मोस्टली बात करेंगे। अगर आपको
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लगता है कि चैन हो सकती है और सीवियरिटी
बढ़ा सकते हो आप तो बढ़ा के करो नहीं तो
फिर कर सकते हो। नो इशूज़।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
हां ग्रुप में ही सब कुछ होगा। जो भी
बीच-बीच में इवेंट्स या जो भी इससे
रिलेटेड एसओसी से रिलेटेड चीजें होंगी वो
WhatsApp ग्रुप में आपको इनफॉर्म किया
जाएगा। तो ग्रुप जरूर ज्वाइन कीजिएगा।
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट।
ठीक है?
तो आईओसी बस एक पर्टिकुलर चीज इंडिकेट
करता है कि अरे एक मास्ट पर्सन को देखा
गया था। टीटीपी क्या करता है? पूरी उस
पर्टिकुलर इंडिकेटर्स की डिटेल प्रोवाइड
करता है। एव्री डिटेल
मतलब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अटैकर ने
लॉक तोड़ा। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बैक डोर से घुसा। सीटी डिसेबल किया और
स्केप भाग गया। ये है टीटीपी की वैल्यू।
अब यहां देखो एसोसिएट टीम्स केयर मोर
अबाउट बिहेवियर देन जस्ट इंडिकेटर्स।
एसोसिएट टीम जो है बिहेवियर को ज्यादा
यहां पे वैल्यू देती हैं। देन देन द जस्ट
दैन जस्ट इंडिकेटर्स। इंडिकेटर्स से
ज्यादा यहां पे बिहेवियर पे ये ध्यान देते
हैं एसोसिएट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टीम
कि मतलब इंडिकेटर्स पे तो है। ठीक है? बट
बिहेवियर इज़ वेरीेंट जो भी बिहेवियर ऑफ
पर्टिकुलर थिंग्स उस पर्टिकुलर मान लो कोई
एक इवेंट हो रहा है कोई एक इंसिडेंट हो
रहा है तो बिहेवियर पे बहुत फोकस करना है।
ठीक है? अब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हमने पहले टैक्टिक्स
टीटीपीस में सबसे पहला हमारा टैक्टिक्स
है। फिर टेक्निक्स है एंड फिर प्रोसीजर्स
है। तो हम अपने पहली चीज़ पे आ जाते हैं
टैक्टिक्स पे। फर्स्ट वी आर कमिंग ऑन
टैक्टिक्स। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
टैक्टिक्स डिस्क्राइब व्हाई द अटैकर इज
डूइंग समथिंग। टैक्टिक्स का मतलब है कि
व्हाई अटैकर क्यों ऐसा कर रहा है?
टैक्टिक्स यही बताता है। ईच टैक्टिक
रिप्रेजेंट्स अ फेज ऑफ़ अटैक अटैक लाइफ
लाइफ साइकिल या अटैक साइकिल। तो टैक्टिक्स
बताता है भाई क्यों कर रहा है अटैकर? अरे
भैया ऐसा क्यों कर रहे हो? मत करो। ये सब
करने से क्या होगा? [हंसी] कॉमन अटैकर गोल
क्या होता है? अटैकर का गोल क्या होता है?
कॉमन इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन करना।
क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुराना, लैटरल मूवमेंट
करना, डाटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेट करना एंड
पर्सिस्टेंस को मेंटेन करना। यह कॉमन जो
है [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये अटैकर
का गोल होता है। तो टैक्टिक्स का है कि
क्यों अटैकर क्यों कर रहा है? अब
टैक्टिक्स के मैं कुछ एग्जांपल आपको बता
देता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? अब मान लो एक टैक्टिक है और उसका
मतलब मैं समझा देता हूं। इससे आपको क्लियर
हो जाएगा। एक टैक्टिक है इनिशियल एक्सिस।
ये टैक्टिक में आया इनिशियल एक्सिस। तो
इसका मैंने क्या बोला था? क्यों? व्हाई?
हाउ अटैकर फर्स्ट गेट्स इन? हाउ अटैकर
फर्स्ट गेट्स इन। इनिशियल एक्सेस का मतलब
है एग्जीक्यूशन रनिंग मलिशियस कोड।
एग्जीक्यूशन का मतलब है मलेशियस कोड को रन
करना। ये टैक्टिक्स है। मतलब एक इनिशियल
एक्सेस का एग्जीक्यूशन का पर्सिस्टेंस एक
टैक्टिक्स है। तो इसका मतलब क्या है?
सिस्टम के अंदर में रहना। ये इसकी मीनिंग
है। ठीक है? ये जो मैं आपको राइट में बता
रहा हूं, ये मीनिंग है और ये टैक्टिक है।
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन बिकमिंग एन एडमिन या
मोर प्रिविलेज यूजर या एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
यूजर डिफेंस इवेशन मतलब एंटीवायरस या
इडीआर एक्सडीआर इन सबको बीट करना
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इन सब से बचना
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्रेडेंशियल
एक्सेस मींस पासवर्ड्स यूजरनेम ये सबको
चुराना ये भी एक टैक्टिक है क्रेडेंशियल
एक्सेस इसका मतलब है पासवर्ड को चुराना बस
लैटरल मूवमेंट मूविंग टू अदर सिस्टम्स अदर
सिस्टम्स जो डिवाइसेस जो है नेटवर्क में
उस पे मूव ऑन करना यह लैटरल मूवमेंट
कहलाता है एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन डाटा को चुराना
जो भी डाटा है उसको चुना। तो ये टैक्टिक्स
थे कुछ और उसके कुछ एग्जांपल थे। तो आई
थिंक आपका टैक्टिक क्लियर हो गया। मुझे
बताते चलिए। नहीं बताइएगा तो मुझे समझ
नहीं आएगा। इफ इट इज क्लियर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बताइए मुझे। सभी
का क्लियर है। एवरीथिंग प्लीज मैं एक बार
चैट देखता हूं। बता दीजिए जल्दी से।
ओके
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है। आई [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] थिंक
काफी लोग ऑलमोस्ट सबको समझ में आ चुका है।
ओके मिस्टर नथिंग आपको बंटी मिली है। क्या
बात है? बहुत अच्छी बात है यार। मिस्टर
नथिंग गॉट बंटी एंड उन्होंने सुपर चैट भी
कर दिया है। ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
थैंक [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यू वेरी
मच।
मिस्टर नथिंग एंड कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू ऑन
योर बंटी। ऑन योर फर्स्ट वैलिड बग। मतलब
बंटी नहीं लगी इनको। फर्स्ट वैलिड बग इनका
एक्सेप्ट हुआ है एंड इसलिए इन्होंने सुपर
चैट किया है। सो थैंक यू वेरी मच एंड आई
होप कि जो है आपकी बाउंटी भी जल्दी ही लग
जाए। राइट? [खांसने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
व्हाट इज़ ईडीआर? अब देखो ईडीआर क्या होता
है? आप में से कोई पूछ रहा है। अब ये अब
मुझे एक बात बताओ। राहुल राज इज़ आस्किंग
व्हाट इज़ ईडीआर? अब मैं आपसे यह बोलूं कि
दैट्स द मेन रीज़न व्हाई यू शुड अटेंड लाइव
और यू शुड वॉच एव्री सेकंड ऑफ़ रिकॉर्डिंग।
क्योंकि रिकॉर्डिंग में आप एव्री सेकंड
देख ही नहीं सकते। देखता ही नहीं है कोई।
लाइव में तो सब सुन लेते हो। अब ईडीआर के
बारे में नहीं बताया था। राहुल राज बताइए
आप आप तो इसका मतलब आप रेगुलर नहीं है।
आपने रेगुलर या तो रेगुलर है नहीं या तो
लाइव में नहीं आते या तो आपने रिकॉर्डिंग
भी अगर देखी है तो सही से नहीं देखी है।
तो इट्स योर फॉल्ट ना। राइट? मैंने इडीआर
के बारे में ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है। पिछले
के क्लासेस इसलिए बोला पिछले क्लासेस के
वीडियोस को भी अच्छे से देखिएगा। राइट?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] थोड़ा अच्छे
से देखिएगा।
रिपीट कर दें सर सारा कांसेप्ट ये तो
पॉसिबल ही नहीं है कि सारा कांसेप्ट मैं
अभी फिर से वापस से रिपीट करूं अगर आप लेट
जॉइ कर रहे हैं तो ये आपकी गलती है इट्स
योर फॉल्ट कि इफ यू आर जॉइनिंग लेट तो अभी
इतनी क्लासेस में इतनी चीजें हो गई वापस
से रिपीट नहीं कर सकते आप वीडियो की
रिकॉर्डिंग देख लीजिएगा ठीक है आप
रिकॉर्डिंग देख लीजिएगा आपका रिपीट हो
जाएगा जितनी बार देखना चाहे आप देख
लीजिएगा रिकॉर्डिंग हां एक चीज मैं फिर से
बता देता हूं गाइज़ इस ट्रेनिंग के कंप्लीट
होने के बाद हो सकता है यह वीडियोस हैं जो
वीडियोज़ आपको अभी दिख रहे हैं लाइव के यह
मेंबर ओनली हो जाएं। जहां पे पे करके
देखना पड़ेगा। आगे के जो भी लर्नर्स या
व्यूअर्स होंगे। ऐसा पॉसिबल है। हो सकता
है। मैं ये नहीं बोल रहा होगा ही होगा।
मैं यह भी नहीं बोल रहा कि नहीं भी होगा।
हो सकता है। तो इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू यू टू
प्लीज अटेंड लाइव। और इस चीज की वैल्यू को
समझिए और अभी जब तक वीडियोस हैं तब तक
लाइव में आके रिकॉर्डिंग को रिपीट करके
प्रैक्टिस करके सब कंप्लीट कर लीजिए। बस
दैट्स इट। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
दैट्स इट ताकि थोड़ी वैल्यू समझ में आए
सबको। अभी तो रहेगा अभी रहेगा। टेंशन मत
लेना। चलिए टैक्टिक्स का एग्जांपल समझ में
आ गया होगा सबको। अब आते हैं टेक्निक्स
पे। टेक्निक्स का मतलब है द मेथड। जो मेथड
होता है वो मेथड। ठीक है? ये टैक्टिक्स का
मतलब है यहां पे द गोल। टैक्टिक्स आपका
क्या है? ये गोल है आपका। और टेक्निक क्या
है? यह मेथड है। जो मेथड हम यूज़ करने जा
रहे हैं। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
टेक्निक डिस्क्राइब्स हाउ द अटैकर अचीव्स
अ टैक्टिक।
टैक्टिक आपका गोल था बट उस गोल को अटैकर
कैसे अचीव कर रहा है यही आपकी टेक्निक
कहलाता है। सिंपल
सिंपल सिंपल
बहुत सिंपल है। अटैकर उस गोल को कैसे अचीव
कर रहा है? हाउ ही इज़ अचीविंग हाउ दे आर
अचीविंग। यही टेक्निक है। थिंक ऑफ़ टेक्निक
एज स्पेसिफिक अटैक मेथड्स। तो एक अटैक
मेथड के थ्रू अचीव करेगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात
है। एक अटैक मेथड होगी उससे अचीव करेगा।
तो टैक्टिक अगर आपका है क्रेडेंशियल
एक्सेस मान लो टैक्टिक है आपका क्योंकि
हमने पहले टैक्टिक में क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस
देखा था। ठीक है? टैक्टिक्स में हमने
देखा। अब मान लो टैक्टिक्स में
क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस है तो टेक्निक क्या
होगा कि उस क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस के लिए उस
पासवर्ड को क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस का मतलब
क्या है? पासवर्ड चुराना या पासवर्ड गेन
कर ले लेना। तो उसके लिए क्या-क्या
टेक्निक्स यूज़ हो सकते हैं? कि लॉगिंग
क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग जो एल्स एस डंपिंग
होती है। एल्स एंस एल्स एस मेमोरी डंप या
व्हाटएवर
[खांसने की आवाज़]
ब्राउज़र, [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पासवर्ड थप्ट फिशिंग फॉर क्रेडेंशियल्स ये
सब चीजें होती है। ठीक है? तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये सारी जो
टेक्निक्स हैं वो यूज़ में ली जाती हैं फॉर
दिस पर्टिकुलर काइंड ऑफ टैिक्स। तो जो
टैक्टिक को फुलफिल करने के लिए यूज़ में
लिया जाए वो टेक्निक्स हैं। और जिस
पर्टिकुलर टेक्निक का यूज़ करके गोल को
अचीव किया जाए वो गोल ही आपका बेसिकली
टैक्टिक होता है। सिंपल। समझ में आ गया?
बहुत ईजीली आपको समझ में आ गया?
एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड वेरी ईजी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बताइए मुझे जल्दी से बताइए मजा मजा तो आ
रहा होगा बताइए
ऑलाइट
ओके
काफी कम लोग रिप्लाई कर रहे हैं।
चलिए ठीक है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पे है ईच टैक्टिक हैज़ मल्टीपल
टेक्निक्स। क्योंकि टैक्टिक जो होगा ना एक
हो सकता है बट उसके टेक्निक्स बहुत सारे
हो सकते हैं। जैसे यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
होगा। सो इट कैन बी मल्टीपल टेक्निक्स।
टेक्निक आपको समझ में आई थिंक आ गई होगी।
अब आते हैं प्रोसीजर्स पे। प्रोसीजर्स का
मतलब है जिस टेक्निक को जिस टेक्निक से
किया गया हो तो उसमें जो स्टेप्स यूज किए
गए हैं उन टेक्निक्स को अप्लाई करने के
लिए वो प्रोसीजर्स हैं। प्रोसीजर्स आर
अटैकर्स एग्जैक्ट इंप्लीमेंटेशन इन रियल
वर्ल्ड। अटैकर एग्जैक्ट जो इंप्लीमेंट
करता है एग्जैक्ट जो इंप्लीमेंट
इंप्लीमेंटेशन करता है अटैक का रियल
वर्ल्ड में उसी को हम प्रोसीजर बोलते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? इसमें क्या आते हैं? टूल्स,
कमांड्स, [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
स्क्रिप्ट्स, टाइमिंग्स, ईटीसी, व्हाटएवर।
तो जो भी टूल्स यूज़ हो रहे हैं, कमांड्स
यूज़ हो रहे हैं, स्क्रिप्ट्स यूज़ हो रहे
हैं, वो सब प्रोसीजर का पार्ट है।
एग्जांपल देखिए अब क्या है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] टेक्निक है
क्रेडेंशियल जंपिंग। ये आपका टेक्निक मतलब
कि मतलब ये टैक टैक्टिक है। ऑब्वियस सी
बात है। ये टैक्टिक है। बट इसके टेक्निक्स
अलग-अलग यूज़ होंगे। जैसे कि ये सारे
टेक्निक्स यूज़ हुए थे यहां पे की लॉगिंग,
क्रिज़ लॉबी। तो यहां पे डायरेक्टली मैंने
टेक्निक लिख दिया है कि क्रेडेंशियल्स
डंपिंग का हमें निकालना है प्रोसीजर। तो
प्रोसीजर क्या होगा? एक कमांड होगी इस
तरीके का कुछ प्रॉडम exc यहां पे एक इस
तरीके से एक्सेप्ट यूएलए हफन एमए एल्स
exec एल्स डॉट डीएमपी तो इस तरीके से जैसे
एल्स एल्स मेमोरी डंप करने का कमांड होगा
एक तो ये पूरा ये जो कमांड है ये प्रोसीजर
है बस अब एसओसी टीम्स जो है ना वो टीटीपीस
जो है टीटीपीस
उसको मैप करती हैं किसके किसके थ्रू?
My्रे के थ्रू। मथ्रे फ्रेमवर्क के थ्रू।
जो भी एसओसी टीम्स हैं, मोस्टली एसोसिएट
टीम्स जो है टीटीपीस को मैप करती है Myra
पे। m्रे मतलब एक फ्रेमवर्क जहां पे सब
चीजें हैं कि कैसे-कैसे एक अटैकर जो है
क्या-क्या प्रोसेससेस किस तरीके की चीजें
यूज़ कर सकता है एक नेटवर्क के अंदर
इनफिल्ट्रेट करने के लिए। तो, उसको यह मैप
करती है और उसी के अकॉर्डिंग काम करती है।
ऐसा क्यों होता है? क्योंकि mra जो है एक
ग्लोबल नॉलेज बेस है। जहां पे ग्लोबली
एक्सेप्टेड एक फ्रेमवर्क है। एसओसीस,
एसआईएम्स, ईडीआर्स, एक्सडीआर इन सब में
यूज़ होता है। इन सबका बिल्डिंग ब्लॉक है
वो। एंड टैक्टिक्स एंड टेक्निक्स के
अराउंड बिल्ड अप है। टै टैिक्स एंड
टेक्निक्स के अराउंड समझे? बस हो गया।
वही हाउ कैसे
हुआ यह? हाउ ऐसे उस पे यह बिल्ड है। एव्री
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट मस्ट नो m्रे अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क या m्रे के बारे में सबको पता
होना चाहिए। अब आप लोगों के लिए छोटा सा
यही टास्क है। मैं बताऊंगा सब कुछ बताऊंगा
कि आप लोग m्रे के बारे में थोड़ा सा पढ़
के आएंगे। खुद से थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करेंगे।
थोड़ी सी पढ़ेंगे mra के बारे में। देयर
आर लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स ऑनलाइन इंटरनेट पे आप
उसके बारे में थोड़ा पढ़ेंगे। बाकी मैं
इजी बहुत प्यार से आपको तो समझा ही दूंगा।
यू विल अंडरस्टैंड। राइट समझ में आ जाएगा।
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
प्रोसीजर्स हो गए हमारे। अब हम आ जाते हैं
आईओसीस पे। इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज
पे। नाउ वी आर ऑन आईओसीस। इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज। अब देखिए इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज क्या होते हैं? मैंने बताया
था स्टार्टिंग में ही कि इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है। आईओसी होता है। ठीक
है?
इसी को लेके हम अब बढ़ने वाले हैं। ये भी
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। टीटीपीस तो हम समझ
गए। अब आईओसी पे आते हैं। दे आर ऑब्जरवेबल
एविडेंसेस दैट सजेस्ट अ सिस्टम मे बी
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड और अंडर अटैक। ये एक ऐसे
एविडेंस होते हैं जिनको ऑब्जर्व किया जा
रहा है। अब जैसे एसओ की टीम है वो ऑब्जर्व
कर रही है एक सिस्टम को एंड उसको लग रहा
है कि ये सिस्टम शायद कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो
चुका है। ये सिस्टम शायद
अटैकर के कंट्रोल में है। इस सिस्टम का
कुछ ना कुछ तो सिस्टम में गड़बड़ी है। ये
जो पर्टिकुलर ऑब्जरवेशन वाली चीज हो रही
है। ऑब्जरवेशन की जो एविडेंस हमारे साथ है
जो भी होंगी वह आईओसी जो है
के द्वारा होती है। मतलब वो इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कहलाते हैं। बेसिकली उसको हम
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज कहलाते हैं।
कहलाते हैं। जिसके थ्रू भी हो रही है वो
इंडिकेटर्स होते हैं। एंड कॉम्प्रोमाइज के
मतलब एक सिस्टम कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो रहा है या
हुआ है उसको जो इंडिकेट करते हैं जो भी
जितने भी इंडिकेशंस हैं वो सब इंडिकेटर्स
कहलाते हैं। एंड उसी को इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कहा जाता है। तो इफ टीटीपीस
डिस्क्राइब अटैकर बिहेवियर आईओसीस आर द
फुटप्रिंट्स अटैकर्स लीव बिहाइंड। तो अगर
टीटीपी अटैकर के बिहेवियर को डिफाइन करता
है। जैसे कि पहले हमने देखा था ना क्या
हुआ था एग्जैक्टली क्या हुआ था कि एक
एक बंदे को मास्क आदमी को देखा गया था।
यही था ना तो अब वो बंदा आया। उसने कैमरा
ऑफ किया। वो अंदर घुस गया। ये वो वो सब
हमने देखा था। तो अगर टीडीपी अटैकर के
पूरे बिहेवियर को बताता है तो आईओसीस क्या
करते हैं? आर द फुटप्रिंट्स अटैकर्स स्लीप
बिहाइंड। तो अटैकर ने जो फुटप्रिंट छोड़ा
है पीछे जो डिजिटल फुटप्रिंट जो डिजिटल
प्रिंट्स छोड़ रहा है वो छोड़ रहा है या
फुटप्रिंट छोड़ रहा है वही है आईओसी
इंडिकेटर्स। उसके मतलब वो काफी हेल्प होती
है उसके थ्रू। एसओसी टीम को यह पता लगाने
में कि एग्जजेक्टली वह अटैक कहां से
ओरिजनेट हुआ है। किसने अटैक का कोशिश किया
है? किसने किया है ये सब पता करने में।
एसओसी एनालिस्ट हंट डिटेक्ट कोरिलेट एंड
रिसॉनड यूजिंग आईओसी एव्री सिंगल डे। अब
एसओसी एनालिस्ट जो होते हैं आईओसी के
बेसिस पे ही हंट करते हैं ऐसे ऐसे अटैक्स
पे। अटैक्स को ऐसे-ऐसे अटैकर्स को। उनको
डिटेक्ट करते हैं अटैक्स को। उनको रिलेट
करते हैं अदर रूल्स एंड जो भी चीजें होती
हैं उनके थ्रू एंड फिर वह रिसोंड करते
हैं। ये पूरा का पूरा प्रोसेस है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखो आईओसी का
सिंपल मतलब मैं समझा देता हूं। समथिंग बैड
हैपेंड हियर एंड वी कैन प्रूव इट विद
डेटा। बस आईओसी का मतलब यही है। कुछ तो
बुरा हुआ है। हम इसको प्रूव कर सकते हैं
डेटा के साथ। ये आईओसी का मतलब है। अब ये
जो डेटा है वो कहां से आएंगे? ये बोल रहा
है कि कुछ बुरा हुआ है। हम उसको डेटा से
प्रूफ कर सकते हैं। अब ये डेटा कहां से
आया है? तो डेटा लॉक से आएंगे। डेटा
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक से आएंगे। डेटा एंड पॉइंट
एक्टिविटी जैसे आपके लैपटॉप, डेस्कटॉप इन
सब से आएंगे। ईमेल हेडर्स से आएंगे। फाइल
सिस्टम से आएंगे। जो आपके फाइल सिस्टम
बेसिकली कहलाते हैं। उस फाइल सिस्टम से
ईमेल हेडर्स ईमेल वगैरह है उससे आएंगे।
लॉक्स से नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक से इन सब से डेट
आएंगे। अब इन अ रियल एसओसी एनवायरमेंट
आईओसी हेल्प्स यू ट्रिगर अलर्ट्स इन
एसआईएम कंफर्म मलेशियस एक्टिविटी कोरिलेट
अटैक्स अक्रॉस सिस्टम्स रिसोंड क्विकली
एंड राइट इंसिडेंट रिपोर्ट्स
तो रियल एसोसिएट एनवायरमेंट में आपके
आईओसी इन चीजों में हेल्प करता है। एसआईएम
में ट्रिगर करेगा अलर्ट को। अलर्ट को
ट्रिगर करता है। मलिशस एक्टिविटी अगर कोई
हो रही है तो उसको कंफर्म करता है। कोई भी
अटैक कुछ उस तरीके का कोई अटैक और भी हो
रही है सिस्टम्स पे उन सबको एक रिलेट करता
है। कोरिलेट जिसको बोल रिलेट करता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बहुत क्विकली रिसोंड करता है। जैसे कि अगर
मान लो कोई किसी तरह का
एक इंडिकेटर ऐसा आया तो वो उसको ब्लॉक
करना, आइसोलेट करना, कंटेन करना उस
पर्टिकुलर अटैक को। यह इसके बेसिस पर
डिफाइन या डिसीजन लिया जा सकता है। राइट
इंसिडेंट रिपोर्ट्स एंड इंसिडेंट
रिपोर्ट्स करने में भी हेल्प करता है।
मतलब आपके ब्लॉक आइसोलेट कंटेन में भी
हेल्प करता है। इंसिडेंट रिपोर्ट्स को भी
राइट डाउन करने में ये हेल्प करता है। ये
है आईओसी का पूरा बेनिफिट। अब आईओसी के भी
टाइप्स होते हैं। आईओसी के भी टाइप्स होते
हैं। अब इनमें जो है हम मेन जो टाइप्स के
हैं वो सब टाइप्स देखने वाले हैं। सबसे
पहला आता है हमारा नेटवर्क बेस्ड आईओसी।
जो नेटवर्क बेस्ड आईओसी होते हैं वो होते
हैं। ये क्या होते हैं? दी शो व्हाट
हैपेंड इनसाइड द सिस्टम। मतलब इनसाइड द
सिस्टम इसको हम नहीं बोलेंगे। इनसाइड द
नेटवर्क बोलेंगे। आई थिंक आई थिंक इसको
इनसाइड द इंसाइड द नेटवर्क बोल सकते हैं।
यह सिस्टम आई थिंक मैंने गलत लिख दिया है।
मैं इसको चेंज करना चाहूंगा क्योंकि फिर
ये YouTube पे रहता है। इनसाइड द नेटवर्क
यू कैन से
दिस शो व्हाट हैपेंड इनसाइड द नेटवर्क।
ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] दिस शो व्हाट
हैपेंड इनसाइड द नेटवर्क। नेटवर्क के अंदर
में क्या हुआ था? ये बताता है आपका
नेटवर्क बेस्ड आईओसीस। अब इसमें एग्जांपल
कैसे हैं? एग्जांपल कौन-कौन से हैं भैया?
देखिए
मलेशियस IPपी एड्रेस यह एग्जांपल है।
सस्पिशियस डोमेन सी टू सर्वर कम्युनिकेशन।
कोई कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर है तो
अनयूजुअल पोर्ट्स और प्रोटोकॉल्स। कोई
अनयूजुअल पोर्ट्स या प्रोटोकॉल्स आपको दिख
रहे हैं। कोई एक सीएनसी कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
सर्वर की कम्युनिकेशन एक एक फॉरेन आईपी के
थ्रू दिख रही है आपको कि एक आईपी है जिससे
कि कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है जो ट्रस्टेड
नहीं है। कोई सस्पिशियस डोमेन ऐसा डोमेन
जो आप नहीं जानते हैं। आपके कम आपके कंपनी
आपकी एसओसी टीम को नहीं पता है कि यह कौन
सा डोमेन है? कैसा डोमेन है। एंड मशियस
IPपी एड्रेस अगर कोई मलेशियस IPपी एड्रेस
आपको दिख जाए तो यह एग्जांपल्स हैं।
अब एसओसी टीम्स क्या
वेयर एसओसी सीज देम? एसओसी उन्हें कहां
देखती है? जैसे ये जो चीजें हैं ये जो
आपके नेटवर्क बेस्ड आईओसीस के इंडिकेटर्स
हैं। बेसिकली ये इंडिकेटर्स हैं। आईओसीस
आर इंडिकेटर्स जो इंडिकेट करते हैं किसी
भी पर्टिकुलर एक पैटर्न को एक पर्टिकुलर
चीज को अटैक पैटर्न को कि अरे भैया यहां
पे सस्िशियस डोमेन है। इंडिकेट करो। एसओसी
टीम को क्या करते हैं? अरे भैया यहां पे
सस्िशियस डोमेन है। इंडिकेट कर दो टीम को।
अरे यार यहां पे सी टू सी सर्वर
कम्युनिकेशन लग रही है मुझे इंडिकेट कर दो
तो एसओसी की टीम इनको कहां देखती है इन
इंडिकेशंस को फायरवल लॉक्स में देखेगी
प्रॉक्सी लॉक्स में देखेगी डीएनएस लॉक्स
में देखेगी आईडीएस या आईपीएस अलर्ट्स में
देखेगी यहां पे एसओसी टीम्स देखती है एज
एसओसी टीम आप इन जगहों को देखोगे इन जगहों
को सर्च करोगे इन जगहों पे इनको देखोगे ये
होती है ये होती है कमाल ऐसे करते हैं
एसओसी वाले तो एसओसी में देखो यू विल नॉट
बिलीव गाइस एसओसी में
अ
क्या बोल रहे हो सर? सम अटैकर इरेज देयर
फुटप्रिंट्स। हां जी इरेज कर देते हैं।
बहुत सारे होते हैं। देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स।
यस। डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक से इरेज्ड
फुटप्रिंट्स भी पता चल जाती है। बहुत मतलब
आई विल नॉट से हमेशा बट हां मैक्सिमम टाइम
पता चल जाती है। करेक्ट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर अब सर अब सारा टॉपिक एक दूसरे से
कनेक्ट हो रहा है। सब समझ में आ रहा है।
मजा आ रहा है। क्या बात है? नाम क्या है?
पप्पी माइंडसेट। क्या? अरे यार तुम लोग
नाम ऐसा क्यों रखते हो कि नाम बोल भी ना
पाए इंसान। पप्पी माइंडसेट कौन सा नाम
होता है यार? यूजरनेम जब तुम लोग रखते हो
YouTube पे बनाने जाते हो तो क्या सोच के
यूजरनेम रखते हो? ये सब मतलब कि मैं लाइव
में बोल भी नहीं पा रहा हूं। मतलब मेरे को
पहले सोच देखना पड़ रहा है कि क्या है? ये
क्या लिखा है? पप्पी यूपी पप्पी माइंडसेट
ऐसे नाम तो कम से कम रियल या कुछ ऐसा रखो
मस्त ऑथेंटिक वाला
है ना [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हां
ये वीकली थ्यरी टेस्ट होगी आप लोगों की
टेस्ट भी होगी थ्यरी टेस्ट भी होगी हमारा
खुद का ही पोर्टल डेवलप हो रहा है जहां पे
हम टेस्ट आपके लेंगे आपको उसके बदले
रिवॉर्ड्स अ जो है वो वो आपको प्रोवाइड
करेंगे एंड देयर विल बी मल्टीपल थिंग्स।
पॉइंट्स को आप बाद में रिडीम कर सकते हैं
हमारे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कोर्सेज के अंदर डिस्काउंट्स लेने के लिए
या गिफ्ट ट्राई हैक के वाउचर्स वगैरह लेने
के लिए। ऐसे चीजों को हम जल्दी लेकर
आएंगे। बहुत जल्द आपके सामने बहुत बड़ी
चीज आएगी तो पता चल जाएगा आपको।
ठीक है?
ओके।
चलिए। ये आपका हो गया नेटवर्क बेस्ड एसओ
नेटवर्क बेस्ड आईओसीस। अब आते हैं होस्ट
या एंड पॉइंट बेस्ड आईओसीस। होस्ट या एंड
पॉइंट बेस्ड आईओसीस। ये क्या होते हैं?
दीज़ शो व्हाट हैपेंड इनसाइड द सिस्टम।
मतलब ये सिस्टम के अंदर क्या हुआ? वो
नेटवर्क के अंदर था। ये सिस्टम के अंदर
क्या हुआ है? उसके बारे में बताता है। जो
भी ऐसे आईओसी या इंडिकेटर्स होते हैं। तो
इंडिकेटर्स क्या? इंडिकेटर्स क्या डिनोट
करते हैं? क्या इंडिकेट करते हैं?
सस्िशियस प्रोसेससेस, अनएक्सेक्टेड
सर्विसेस, रजिस्ट्री चेंजेस, न्यू शेड्यूल
टास्क। मतलब कोई सस्िशियस प्रोसेस हुआ है,
कोई अनएक्सेक्टेड सर्विज चलने लगी हैं।
रजिस्ट्री में किसी तरह का कोई चेंज आ गया
है। कोई ऐसा टास्क शेड्यूल हुई है जो पहले
थी नहीं जो किसी ने करा ही नहीं है। वो कर
लिया है। राइट? तो एसओसी इसको कैसे देखती
है? कहां से? मतलब वेयर कहां देखती है?
इनको एडीआर xdr के अंदर उनको मिल जाएगा।
Windows इवेंट लॉग्स के अंदर मिल जाएगा।
सिसमोन जो होती है ये एक Windows sis
इंटरनल का पार्ट है। Sis एक यूटिलिटी है
सिस्टम मॉनिटर उसके अंदर में देख सकती है।
एंड Linux ऑडिट लॉग्स Linux का अगर सिस्टम
है तो Linux के ऑडिट लॉग्स में ये देख
सकती है जो एसओसी की टीम है। तो यहां पे
नेटवर्क बेस्ड iOCस को यहां फायर वॉल
प्रोक्सी डीएनएस आईपीएस आईडीएस में देखते
हैं। एंड पॉइंट्स आईओसीस को इडीआर एसडीआर
हो गई। इवेंट लॉक्स हो गई SMON हो गया और
Linux ऑडिट लॉग हो गया। ये सब पे देखते
हैं। अब एक बंदा पूछ रहा था कि सर कौन से
टॉपिक को हम एक्सप्लोर करें वो समझ नहीं आ
रहा। तो देखो यहां सिंपल सा फंडा है।
ईडीआर एक्सडीआर अब आपको नहीं समझ में आ
रहा है। मान लो आपको थोड़ा बहुत आईडिया है
कि इडीआर एक्सडीआर एक एंटीवायरस की तरह
होता है अटैक्स को रोकने के लिए या जो भी
है थ्रेट्स को बट अब इसकी डिटेल नहीं पता
ना इसको लेके एक्सप्लोर करना शुरू कर दो।
अब sisson के बारे में नहीं पता। Google
करो सिसपीटी करो सिसोन के बारे में पता
लगाने लगो। लinक्स ऑडिट लॉक्स एक्चुअली
क्या होते हैं? Linx ऑडिट लॉक का मतलब
क्या होता है? अगर ऐसा जानना है सिंपली
जिसमें लॉग्स का कलेक्शन एंड ऑडिटिंग होता
है वो ऑडिट लॉग तो उसके बारे में थोड़ा तो
ये एक्सप्लोरेशन कहलाता है। जब आप
एक्सप्लोर खुद से करने लगेंगे तो आपसे
बेस्ट जो नॉलेज है वो किसी और की हो भी
नहीं सकती है। दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उसके बाद है
फाइल बेस्ड आईओसीस। दीज़ रिलेट टू मशियस
फाइल्स। इनका [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रिलेशन है मलेशियस फाइल्स से। दैट्स इट।
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एग्जांपल
क्या है? फाइल हैश। कोई ऐसी जो फाइल हैश
मलेशियस हैश हो गया या हैश बोलो जो फाइल
हैश है उसको हम चेक करते हैं। फाइल नेम
पैटर्न्स जो है वो इंडिकेट करता है एंड
फाइल साइज एनोमेलिस के अला डिफरेंट काइंड
ऑफ़ फाइल साइज अगर मतलब पूछा जाए अजीब भी
फाइल साइज दिख रही है। अब मान लो कोई एक
पीडीएफ है और लेट्स सपोज पीडीएफ एक्सटेंशन
पीडीएफ है उसकी साइज एकदम एक या 2 KB की
है तो ये प्रैक्टिकली पॉसिबल नहीं है कि
पीडीएफ के अंदर एक 2 KB का पीडीएफ हो जाए
कुछ गड़बड़ है या तो ऐसा है कि एक नॉर्मल सी
इमेज है और उसकी साइज 50 MB की ही हो उसकी
साइज चलो 50 MB तो फिर भी चलेगा मान लो
500 Mb की इमेज हो 100 MB की इमेज हो तो
थोड़ा डाउट तो क्रिएट होगा। तो ये
एग्जांपल्स हो गए फाइल बेस्ड आईओसीस के।
एसओसीस उन्हें कहां देखते हैं? एंटीवायरस
के अंदर, ईडीआर के अंदर, ईमेल सिक्योरिटी
गेटवेज या जो भी है उनके अंदर एंड सेंड
बॉक्सेस के अंदर जो सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट
यूज़ करते हैं। अब सैंड बॉक्स का मतलब होता
है एक ऐसा एनवायरमेंट वर्चुअल टाइप जैसे
वर्चुअल बॉक्स आपका होता है या वर्चुअल
वीएमवेयर। तो ये सैंड बॉक्स उससे एक लेवल
अपर चीज है कि एक कंटेंड एनवायरमेंट होता
है जहां पे आप जो भी काम करो सिर्फ उसी
पर्टिकुलर एनवायरमेंट को अफेक्ट करेगा या
इनफेक्ट इनफेक्ट करेगा। आपके Windows या
अदर मशीनंस या अदर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
इनफेक्ट नहीं करेगा। सो ये सेंड बॉक्सेस
होते हैं। तो इन सबके बारे में रिसर्च आप
कर सकते हो। दिस कैन बी रिसर्च्ड। ये
टॉपिक्स हैं आपका। अब यहां पे फाइल हैश तो
हैश के बारे में नहीं पता कि भ है क्या
होती है? हाउ इट इज़ डिफरेंट फ्रॉम
इंक्रिप्शन एंड पासवर्ड की हैशिंग होती
है। हैशिंग के टेक्निक्स अलग-अलग जो होते
हैं MD5, MD4, एसए 256, एसएचए टू 512 या
जो भी हैशेस के टाइप्स होते हैं वो आपने
थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लोर कर लिया। ये सब चीजें
होती है एक्सप्लोर करने की। सेल्फ
एक्सप्लोरेशन की टॉपिक्स होती है जिनको कि
आपको करना होता है। दैट्स इट। जब आप ये
चीजें एक्सप्लोर कर लेंगे तो आपको सारी
चीजें और ज्यादा क्लियर होने लगेंगी।
हालांकि जबजब जैसे-जैसे जरूरत पड़ेगी आपको
इस पूरी ट्रेनिंग में अगर जिन चीजों की भी
जरूरत पड़ेगी मैं खुद भी बताऊंगा आपको।
खुद से आप एक्सप्लोर कर लेना। बट मैं खुद
भी आपको पूरी डिटेल में एक्सप्लेन करके भी
बताऊंगा। जब जिसकी जहां जरूरत पड़ेगी वहां
पे।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब आते हैं ईमेल बेस्ड आईओसी। आई थिंक ये
लास्ट होगा ईमेल बेस्ड। यस ईमेल बेस्ड
आईओसीस। अब ये ईमेल बेस्ड आईओसी क्या है?
ये रिलेट करते हैं मलेशियस ईमेल्स से।
ठीक है?
क्या है? सर आई हैव अ रिक्वेस्ट टू यू। जब
मैं डीएचई क्लास कर रहा था तो मैंने पूछा
था सर से सर एक्सप्लेन
डीप। सो समझ नहीं आ रहा है।
नहीं आ पा रहा है। तो क्या हुआ फिर बताइए?
यू आर सो काइंड। थैंक यू। थैंक यू ब्रदर।
ओके। सर मैंने समय एग्जाम सर समय एग्जाम
चल रहा है इसलिए फोकस नहीं कर पा रहा। कोई
बात नहीं। एग्जाम चल रहा है तो थोड़ा टाइम
निकालिए।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
प्लीज
टाइम निकालिए।
देखिए मैं ऐसे क्वेश्चंस को बिल्कुल भी
नहीं लूंगा जो एसओसी से अभी फिलहाल की
क्लास से बिल्कुल रिलेटेड नहीं है। ठीक
है? तो मैं उसको जानबूझ के इग्नोर कर देता
हूं। तो आप समझ जाइएगा। अगर मैं आपको
इग्नोर कर रहा हूं आपके क्वेश्चन को तो आप
समझ जाइए कि वो एसओसी से अभी इस क्लास से
रिलेटेबल नहीं है। हो सकता है आगे फ्यूचर
में आएंगी वो चीजें। बट अभी नहीं क्योंकि
अभी वो करेंगे तो फिर क्या होगा? बिगिनर्स
को कुछ समझ में नहीं आएगा और बिगिनर्स को
लगेगा कि क्या हो क्या रहा है। वो टाइम
वेस्ट की बात है। ठीक है? तो इसके लिए
प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू नॉट स्पैम।
स्पैम प्लीज मत कीजिए। वो चीजें हो सकती
है आप जो पूछ रहे हैं वो आने वाले कुछ
क्लासेस आने वाले क्लासेस में हो। उसके
बारे में डिस्कशन उसके बारे में मैं बताऊं
भी आपको। बट अभी वो जरूरी नहीं है इसलिए
मैं उस पे डिस्कस नहीं कर रहा। राइट? सो
दैट वी कैन सेव सम टाइम। तो ये है ईमेल
बेस्ड आईओसी। अब ईमेल बेस्ड आईओसी मतलब
ईमेल। मलेशियस ईमेल्स से ये कनेक्ट करते
हैं। कैसे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एग्जांपल क्या है? मलेशियस सेंडर ईमेल।
कोई सेंड कर रहा है ईमेल। मलेशियस बंदा है
वो हो गया। फिशिंग सब्जेक्ट लाइंस।
सब्जेक्ट लाइंस कुछ अजीब अटपटा चीज है।
फिशिंग टाइप लग रही है। मलेशियस यूआरएल्स
कुछ मलशियस यूआरएल्स आपको भेजे जा रहे हैं
ईमेल में। हेडर एनमलीज हेडर्स जो है ईमेल
हेडर्स उसमें कुछ गड़बड़ी आपको लग रही है।
एसओसी उनको कहां देखते हैं? ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स में। ईमेल सिक्योरिटी
टूल्स आते हैं बहुत सारे। जैसे ये जैसे ये
माइ कास्ट प्रूफ पॉइंट ये सब ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स ही होते हैं। Microsoft
डिफेंडर एंटीवासेस जो हैं आजकल वो भी ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी आजकल मतलब थोड़ा प्रोवाइड करने
लगे हैं अलग-अलग चीजें। एंड रिपोर्ट्स जो
होती हैं उनके अंदर में। तो ये यहां पे
एसओसी जो है ईमेल बेस्ड आईओसीस को देखते
हैं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? मैंने पहले ही बोला है अगर आप
स्पैम करेंगे तो आपके आपका सीधा सा एक ही
वो है कि इस टाइम आउट पे डालना। दैट्स इट।
टाइम आउट।
तो कोई फायदा नहीं है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? ईमेल बेस्ड आईओसी हो गए। अब आते
हैं हम हमारे एक और इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक पे।
आईओसी कॉन्फिडेंस लेवल। अभी याद रखिएगा
ट्रेनिंग के अभी ट्रेनिंग जब अभी-अभी
ट्रेनिंग हमारा अभी जब लास्ट यह टॉपिक्स
हो जाएंगे तो हम एक लैब पे भी आएंगे उसको
भी हम करेंगे। ठीक है? तो याद रखिएगा वो
चीज़ आईओसी कॉन्फिडेंट लेवल्स ऑल आईओसीस आर
नॉट इक्वल एट ऑल। देखो आईओसी जो है वो सब
आईओसीस इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज इक्वल
नहीं होते। मित्र्रे का बताऊंगा यार।
मित्र का बताऊंगा। मित्र का मैंने बोला ना
वो एक अलग से सेपरेट। आप लोग सुनते नहीं
हो। आई थिंक वही तो बात है। फोकस ही नहीं
है। बहुत लोगों का तो फोकस ही नहीं होता
है कि मित्र एक सेपरेट टॉपिक है। बहुत
बड़ी टॉपिक है। तो वी विल गो थ्रू दैट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कॉन्फिडेंस लेवल। जितने भी इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होते हैं वो सारे इक्वल नहीं
होते हैं। ऐसा नहीं कि सब इक्वल होते हैं।
उनमें क्या-क्या सीवियरिटी कैसे होती है?
लो, मीडियम, हाई, वेरी हाई। लो में एक
एग्जांपल ले लो। सिंगल सस्िशियस आईपी।
मीडियम में नोन फिशिंग डोमेन हाई में
मैलवेयर हैश प्लस एग्जीक्यूशन वेरी हाई
में मल्टीपल कोर रिलेटेड आईओसीस तो ये
एग्जांपल्स हैं मतलब मल्टीपल कोर रिलेटेड
इंडिकेटर्स हैं मतलब कि ये बहुत बड़ा अटैक
हो सकता है हाई में मैलवेयर का कोई हैश
एंड एग्जीक्यूशन मतलब मालवेयर जो है थोड़ा
सा इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में है और
एग्जीक्यूशन किया जा रहा है इट्स वेरी
डेंजरस [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
फिशिंग डोमेन एक पता है आपको और वो डोमेन
आपको भेजा गया है एंड एक ऐसी आईपी जो
सस्िशियस लग रही है। उसप कोई ऐसे कुछ
सर्विस भी नहीं है और आपको कुछ अलग जगह पे
लेके जा रही है तो वह एक लो कैटेगरी में
आती है। एसओसी एनालिस्ट नेवर रिलाई ऑन अ
सिंगल आईओसी। एसओसी एनालिस्ट जब अगर आप बन
जाते हैं या आप होते हैं तो आप सिर्फ एक
आईओसीस पे डिपेंड नहीं रहेंगे। इंडिकेटर्स
पे डिपेंड नहीं रहेंगे। आपको मल्टीपल एंड
सेवरल इंडिकेटर्स को ध्यान में रखना
पड़ेगा एंड उनके अकॉर्डिंग डिसीजन बनाना
पड़ेगा।
ठीक है?
गॉट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इट।
टुडे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आई एम
नॉट जॉइनिंग क्लास बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ दैट ऑफ़ द
पर्सन। सॉरी। ओके। इट्स ओके रोशन। कोई बात
नहीं।
देखो फिर से समझाइए। ये आप देखिए आप देखो
अगर आपको नहीं समझ में आ रहा है ना आप एक
बार रिकॉर्डिंग दोबारा देखिएगा। मैं
गारंटी देता हूं आपको समझ में आ जाएगी। बट
स्टिल जस्ट लेट मी लेट मी
एक्सप्लेन। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आईओसी
कॉन्फिडेंस लेवल्स होते हैं। मतलब हर
आईओसी एक नहीं होता है। तो आईओसी का
अलग-अलग कॉन्फिडेंस होते हैं। लो
कॉन्फिडेंस, मीडियम, हाई, वेरी हाई। ये
ऐसे ही होते हैं जैसे बग्स की सीिवियरिटी
होती है ना लो सीवियरिटी की बग है, मीडियम
सीवियरिटी की बग है, हाई सीवियरिटी की बग
है, क्रिटिकल सीवियरिटी की बग है। वैसे ही
है। लो है मतलब कि लो वाली कॉन्फिडेंस है
उस पे। उस पर्टिकुलर इंडिकेटर पे लो
कॉन्फिडेंस है। उसने कुछ इंडिकेट किया है।
अच्छा ये यार सिंगल सस्िशियस आईपी लग रहा
है। ठीक है थोड़ा बहुत ज्यादा प्रॉब्लमेटिक
नहीं है। तो ये लो है। उससे थोड़ा ज्यादा
जो सीवियर होगा वो मीडियम फिर उससे ज्यादा
हाई एंड देन सबसे ज्यादा हाई।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
दैट्स इट।
अब यहां समझते हैं आईओसी वर्सेस टीटीपी।
बहुत सारे लोग कंफ्यूज हो जाते हैं कि
आईओसी एंड टीटीपीस के बीच एक्चुअल डिफरेंस
क्या है? तो इसको समझना बहुत जरूरी है।
डिफरेंस क्या है? आईओसी में मान लो हम
क्या करते हैं? एविडेंस। आईओसी में हमारी
एविडेंस होती है। इंडिकेटर्स में हमें
इंडिकेशन क्या मिलती है? एविडेंस की। तो
टीडीटीपीस जो है वो बिहेवियर को बताता है।
आई आईओसी एविडेंस के बारे में बताता है।
अलर्ट कर मतलब इंडिकेट करता है। टीडीटीपीस
उसके बिहेवियर के बारे में बताता है। जो
भी चीजें [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हो रही
हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
व्हाट हैपेंड? आईओसी बताता है क्या हुआ
था? क्या हुआ? एंड टीडीपी हाउ हैपेंड?
कैसे हुआ? आईओसी शॉर्ट लिव्ड होते हैं एंड
टीटीपी आपके लॉन्ग लिव्ड होते हैं। मतलब
आईओसी शॉर्ट अलर्ट तो जो ट्रिगर मतलब अलॉट
जो होता है ना जो बेसिकली इंडिकेट
इंडिकेशन होती है छोटी शॉर्ट टर्म के लिए
इंडिकेशन होती है। बट
जो टेक्निक टैक्टिक्स एंड प्रोसीजर है वो
लॉन्ग टर्म यानी कि पूरा प्रोसेस एक फॉलो
करना पड़ता है। पूरे प्रोसेस के थ्रू जाना
पड़ता है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] समवन इज़
आस्किंग आईओसी पर्सन होता है क्या? नहीं
यार आईओसी इज़ नॉट पर्सन। आईओसी इज अ
इंडिकेटर।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आईओसी एक इंडिकेटर है। जैसे मान लो आप कोई
टूल यूज़ कर रहे हो। उस टूल ने आपको कुछ
इंडिकेट करा अपने डैशबोर्ड पे। वो आईओसी
है। कि अरे भैया ये इंडिकेशन एक लो
इंडिकेशन दिया। तो जैसे मान लो ये एक
इंडिकेशन दिया।
ये सस्िशियस प्रोसेससेस ये इंडिकेशन दिया।
तो यह इंडिकेशन है वो सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर
ही जो भी आप टूल सिक्योरिटी टूल यूज कर
रहे हो वो जो इंडिकेट कर रहा है वह आईओसी
है। दैट्स इट। वो कोई पर्सन नहीं है। वो
इंसान नहीं है। ठीक है? इजी टू चेंज होते
हैं। आईओसी को आराम से चेंज किया जा सकता
है। इंडिकेटर्स को चेंज किया जा सकता है।
टीटीपीस को चेंज करना बहुत मुश्किल है।
हार्ड टू चेंज। अलर्ट्स के लिए आईओसी का
यूज़ किया जाता है। एंड डिटेक्शन लॉजिक के
लिए टीटीपीस को यूज़ किया जाता है। मतलब
डिटेक्ट करने के लिए डिटेक्ट कैसे किया
जाए? कैसे क्या लॉजिक बनाया जाए? और
अलर्ट्स के लिए जो अलर्ट्स होते हैं उसके
लिए आईओसीस का यूज किया जाता है। दैट्स इट
सिंपल।
दैट्स इट सिंपल। ठीक है? आई होप आप समझ गए
होंगे। जो प्रोफेशनल्स एसओसी होते हैं वो
दोनों को यूज़ करते हैं। आईओसी और टीटीपीस
दोनों को। सबका
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
क्लियर है? मुझे बताइए एक बार पहले। तब तक
आई हैव आई विल हैव द वाटर। पहले बता
दीजिए। सबका क्लियर है तो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आईओसी इज़ लाइक अ पजल पीस एंड टीटीपी इज़
लाइक सॉल्विंग इट। यस बिल्कुल सही निशा।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट निशा। अह पजल है आईओसी
और उसको सॉल्व करना टीटीपी है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अच्छा
एग्जांपल दिया है। बहुत बढ़िया। समझ गए?
इसका मतलब आप समझ गए हो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर प्लीज इसे कंटिन्यू रखिएगा क्योंकि
मेरा इंटरव्यू है फरवरी 2020 अह से
हैं में। मैं फोर्थ सेमेस्टर में हूं।
बीसीए कर रहा हूं। ओके। बहुत अच्छी बात
है। आई होप [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यू
गेट रेडी फॉर दैट।
कैन आई गेट इंटर्नशिप इन योर कंपनी? अह
इंटर्नशिप अगर हम अनाउंस करेंगे तो आपको
पता चल जाएगा। फिलहाल तो ऐसा कुछ नहीं है
बट अनाउंस करेंगे तो पता चल जाएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आप बस सोशल
हैंडल्स पे हमारे एक्टिव रहिएगा एंड फॉलो
करके रखिएगा। दैट्स इट।
लव लव फ्रॉम एआई बिरूनी। थैंक यू ब्रदर।
थैंक यू। [खांसने की आवाज़]
सर [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वजू सेटअप
करना है प्रोजेक्ट के लिए। कोई बात नहीं।
वजू को भी हम कवर कर लेंगे। टेंशन नहीं
लेना। उसको भी हम लाएंगे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब देखो यहां पे
क्या फ्लो है? रियल एसओसी का फ्लो क्या
होता है? आईओसी अलर्ट इन्वेस्टिगेशन। ये
फ्लो है। कैसे फ्लो है? आईओसी डिटेक्टेड
एक इंडिकेटर डिटेक्शन होती है। इंडिकेटर
आता है जिसमें या इंडिकेटर आईपी हैश
प्रोसेस कुछ भी इंडिकेट कर सकता है।
एसआईएम जनरेट्स अलर्ट। जैसे ही इंडिकेटर
इंडिकेट करता है। जैसे ही इंड आईओसी
डिटेक्टेड आईओसी डिटेक्ट होती है यानी
इंडिकेटर डिटेक्ट होती है। एसआईएम एक
अलर्ट जनरेट कर देता है। एसओसी लेवल वन जो
है उस अलर्ट को यानी कि उस आईओसी को
इंडिकेटर को वैलिडेट करता है। एसओसी मैप्स
टू टीटीp। अब एसओसी टीटीपी के एसओसी जो है
वो टीटीp पे जाता है। यानी टैक्टिक्स
टेक्निक और प्रोसीजर पे जाता है। जो भी
टैक्टिक है जो भी टेक्निक यूज़ होना है और
जो प्रोसेस यूज़ होना है उस पे चला जाता
है। देन वो डिसीजन बनाता है कि ये ट्रू
पॉजिटिव है या फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है। अगर
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है तो उसका भी उसको
डॉक्यूमेंट करना है। उसको लॉग करना है।
उसको डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करके बताना है कि कैसे
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है, क्या है। दैट्स इट। फिर
आगे डिसाइड करना है कि उसको क्लोज करना है
या आगे फॉरवर्ड करना है। अगर फिर भी आपको
डाउट है तो। एंड ट्रू पॉजिटिव यानी कि
इसमें गड़बड़ी है। इसमें ये एकदम रियल इशू
है। तो अब इसको क्या करना है? वहीं पे
क्लोज कर देना है। छोटी मीडियम सीवियरिटी
की है। उतना कुछ खास ऐसा नहीं करेगा। या
फिर इसको एस्केलेट करना है अपने सीनियर
को। L2 L3 को हाई सीवियरिटी के लिए। एंड
फिर वही बात है लास्ट में एस्केलेशन एंड
क्लोज़र। कि अगर एस्केलेट करना है तो
एस्केलेट कर दीजिए अपने सीनियर्स को या तो
उसको क्लोज़ कर दीजिए। दैट्स इट। खत्म हो
गई। तो ये जो पूरी चीज है ये एक फ्लो है
हमारे आपके एसओसी के लिए। जैसे आप अगर
एसओसी हैं एनालिस्ट हैं तो आप इस फ्लो को
फॉलो करते हैं। दैट्स इट। ये फ्लो फॉल
होगा। चलिए
अब आते हैं हमारे [खांसने की आवाज़]
लास्ट टॉपिक पे। अलर्ट ट्राय। मतलब आज के
सेशन का लास्ट टॉपिक। इसके बाद हम लैब पे
थोड़ा आएंगे। लैब को भी थोड़ा हम देखेंगे
क्योंकि वो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है। लैब वाला
भी पार्ट इंपॉर्टेंट है। तो हम अलर्ट
ट्राय पे आते हैं। अब अलर्ट ट्राय क्या
है? देखो अलर्ट ट्रैक इज द स्ट्रक्चरर्ड
प्रोसेस ऑफ अलर्ट ट्रैक क्या है? एक
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड प्रोसेस है। क्विकली
एनालाइजिंग सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट्स टू डिसाइड
वेदर दे आर रियल थ्रेट्स, फॉल्स अलार्म्स
और नीड एस्केलेशंस। अलर्ट ट्रैक का मतलब
होता है अलर्ट को ट्रैग करना। देखो ट्रायग
का मतलब आप लोगों को पता होगा या आप लोगों
ने पढ़ा होगा कहीं देखा होगा बग बाउंटज
में आप लोगों को पता होगा कि अलर्ट ट्रायग
नहीं ट्रायग का एक कांसेप्ट है बग बाउंट
जब भी आप जहां से भी करते हैं तो एक
ट्रायग का कांसेप्ट है राइट यू नो द
ट्रायग कांसेप्ट
ट्रैगर होते हैं उनके कंपनीज़ में एंड ये
ट्र वो ट्राई करते हैं आपकी जब आप रिपोर्ट
करते हो ना कोई वनेबिलिटी या कोई बग
रिपोर्ट करते हो तो वो ट्रैग हो ट्राई
होगा कि नहीं होगा वो ट्रैगर करता है। अगर
वो वैलिड होगा तो ट्रैग हो जाएगी। यानी कि
वैलिड है आपका वनेबिलिटी रिपोर्टेड। आगे
उसके प्रोसेससेस होंगे। नहीं वैलिड है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो एक्सेप्ट ही
नहीं होगा। ट्रैग नहीं होगा। सिंपल बग
क्राउड है। हैकर वन पे जाओगे तो वहां पे
जो भी रिपोर्ट्स या कोई भी बग बाउंट
प्लेटफार्म को रिपोर्ट करोगे तो वहां पे
जो सामने वाली टीम होती है सिक्योरिटी टीम
या तो उस कंपनी की हो सकती है या हैकर वन
बक्राउड के खुद के हो सकते हैं। मैनेज्ड
अगर होगा तो। सिंपल। तो जब ऐसा होगा तो उस
केस में क्या होता है जो अलर्ट अ जो
बेसिकली वो ट्राइगर टीम है वो करती है
ट्राई कि अगर ट्राई कर दिया तो मतलब आपकी
वनेबिलिटी एक्सेप्ट कर ली गई है जो आपने
रिपोर्ट किया था नहीं की है तो नहीं की गई
है दैट्स इट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है
समझ में आ गया गॉट इट
चलिए अब अलर्ट ट्रैक एक स्ट्रक्चर प्रोसेस
किस चीज का है क्विकली एनालाइज सिक्योरिटी
अलर्ट्स अलर्ट ट्रैक के थ्रू आप
सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट्स को तुरंत एनालाइज कर
लेते हैं। किस चीज के लिए? डिसाइड करने के
लिए कि वो रियल में सही में थ्रेट है या
झूठ-मूठ का एक फॉल्स अलार्म है या इसको
आगे एस्केलेट करना है। मेरे बस की बात
नहीं है। एल वन की बस की बात नहीं है। ये
बहुत हाई सीवियरिटी की है। इसको एस्केलेट
करके सीनियर को भेज दो। दैट्स इट। ये है
अलर्ट ट्रैक का मतलब। इन सिंपल वर्ड्स
अलर्ट ट्रैक इज़ इक्वल टू सेपरेटिंग रियल
अटैक्स फ्रॉम नॉइज़ फास्ट एंड फ्रॉम नॉइज़
फास्ट एंड एक्यूरेटली। एल ट्राई का मतलब
है कि रियल अटैक्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को को नॉइज़ से
अलग करना मतलब फॉल्स अलार्म से अलग करना
बहुत ही जल्दी और एक्यूरेटली मतलब फालतू
की चीजों के फॉल्स जो पॉजिटिव है उससे अलग
कर देना रियल अटैक्स को ये अलर्ट ट्रैक का
मतलब है ट्रैग हो गया मतलब कि वो
पर्टिकुलर जो अलर्ट आई थी वो जो पर्टिकुलर
आईओसी एक्टिवेट हुआ था पर्टिकुलर अलर्ट आई
थी वो सही है अगर ट्रैग हो गया तो मतलब उस
पे अब काम करना है उस पे आगे के
प्रोसेससेस करने हैं जो टीटीपीस वाला काम
है टैक्टिक्स टेक्निक्स एंड प्रोसीजर वो
करना है। तो ये होता है अलर्ट। ट्रैक होने
का मतलब अलर्ट को ट्राई करना।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एसओसी
एनवायरमेंट्स जनरेट थाउजेंड्स ऑफ अलर्ट्स
डेली। जो एसओसी के एनवायरमेंट होते हैं
हजारों अलर्ट डेली जनरेट करते हैं। ओनली अ
स्मॉल परसेंटेज आर रियल इंसिडेंट्स।
जिसमें से कुछ छोटे ही जो होते हैं ना
परसेंटेज कम पर बहुत थोड़े परसेंटेज जो
होते हैं वो रियल होते हैं। रियल इंसिडेंट
होते हैं। ट्रू पॉजिटिव होते हैं। योर जॉब
एज अ एसोसिस एनालिस्ट इज़ टू फ़िल्टर,
प्रायोरिटाइज एंड एक्ट। और एज अ
एसोसिएशनलिस्ट आपका यह भी काम होता है कि
वो इतने हजारों सारे अलर्ट्स में से जो
रियल अलर्ट्स हैं जो ट्रू पॉजिटिव है उनको
फिल्टर करना उनको प्रायोरिटाइज करना और उन
पे फिर एक्शन लेना बस ये चीज
दैट्स [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इट। अब एक
चीज को यहां पे हम समझेंगे। सबसे पहले तो
अलर्ट के लिए एक इवेंट का होना बहुत जरूरी
है। जब भी कोई अलर्ट होती है ना ट्राई तो
अलर्ट ट्राई कब होगी? जब कोई अलर्ट होगा
और अलर्ट भी कब होगी? जब कोई एक इवेंट
होगा यानी कि कोई इवेंट कुछ तो होना
चाहिए। लाइक यूजर लॉगिन यह एक इवेंट है।
प्रोसेस कोई ल्च हो रहा है वो इवेंट है।
कोई फाइल डाउनलोड करी है वो इवेंट है। कोई
मेल सेंड कर रहा है वो इवेंट है। ये सारे
इवेंट्स हैं। तो जब तक कोई इवेंट नहीं
होगा तब तक कोई अलर्ट कैसे आएगा? और तब तक
जब तक अलर्ट नहीं होगा हम उसको ट्राई कैसे
करेंगे? ट्राई का मतलब हम उसको कैसे
बोलेंगे कि हां ये बिल्कुल सही अलर्ट है।
ये प्रोसेस है। राइट? तो दिस इज़ अ
सर एसओसी में फ्रीलांस कैसे कर सकते हैं?
वो तो कंपनी के साथ जुड़ के कर सकते हैं
एसओसी में फ्रीलांस। कंपनी अगर आपको
फ्रीलांस के लिए रेडी हो जा रही है तो यस
यू कैन डू। तो पहले इवेंट होना चाहिए।
जैसे कोई यूजर लॉग इन कर रहा है तो एक
इवेंट हो गया। कोई प्रोसेस ल्च हो रही है,
कोई फाइल डाउनलोड हो रही है या कोई सॉफ्ट
जो एक exc फाइल है मान लो Windows में वो
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है या किसी भी तरह का
प्रोग्राम एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है। वो एक
इवेंट है। देन द सिस्टम लाइक योर ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम अ फायर वाल और अ क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर
मस्ट लॉक द इवेंट। जब कोई इवेंट ल्च होगा
तो आपका जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है या फायरवल
है या जो भी क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर आप यूज कर
रहे हैं जो भी मशीन यूज कर रहे हैं उनका
काम होता है कि जो भी इवेंट्स हो रहे हैं
उसको लॉग करके रखना उसकी लॉग बना के रखना
उसकी सारा डेटा रिकॉर्ड करके रखना उसकी
सारी कत्था चीट जो होता है ना वो रिकॉर्ड
करके रखना ये उनका काम होता है आफ्टर दैट
ऑल सिस्टम लॉग्स मस्ट बी शिप्ड टू अ
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस लाइक एसआईएम और ईडीआर
अब जब लॉग कलेक्ट हो गया यह पूरा मैं
प्रोसेस बता रहा हूं जब लॉग कलेक्ट हो गया
सिस्टम्स के थ्रू, फायरवल के थ्रू या
क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर के थ्रू। तो अब क्या
नेक्स्ट स्टेप होता है कि यह जो लॉक्स हैं
इनको एसआईएम या ईडीआर सॉलशंस जो
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस होते हैं उनको भेजा
जाता है। उनके उनके उनको उनसे पास कराया
जाता है। द एसओसी टीम कैन रिसीव मिलियंस
ऑफ लॉग्स पर डे फ्रॉम थाउजेंड्स ऑफ
डिफरेंट सिस्टम्स वेयर मोस्ट ऑफ द इवेंट्स
आर एक्सपेक्टेड बट सम रिक्वायर अटेंशन। अब
एसओसी टीम जो है मिलियंस ऑफ लॉग्स रिसीव
करती है पर डे फ्रॉम ऑल द सिस्टम्स इन द
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। अब एक नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में बहुत सिस्टम्स हो
सकते हैं। उनसे लाखों लॉग्स क्रिएट हो रहे
हैं। उन सबको रिसीव करता है हमारा एसओसी
जाबाज सिपाही। बहुत जांबाज है।
उन सबको रिटाइव करता है। उन सबको स्टोर
करता है। एंड इसमें से बहुत सारे लॉक्स तो
जाने पहचाने लगेंगे। अरे हां ये तो सही
है। ठीक है। इनफेटिव लगेंगे। बट कुछ जो
होते हैं वो आपके अटेंशन को अपनी तरफ
खींचते हैं और बोलते हैं कि भैया मैं आया
हूं अटैक करने तुम्हारे नेटवर्क के अंदर।
मैं ही हूं डेंजरस वाला। अलर्ट अ
नोटिफिकेशन जनरेटेड बाय अ जो अलर्ट होता
है अ नोटिफिकेशन जनरेटेड बाय अ सिक्योरिटी
सॉल्यूशन व्हेन अ स्पेसिफिक इवेंट और
सीक्वेंस ऑफ़ इवेंट्स अकर्स इज़ व्हाट सेव्स
एसओसी एनालिस्ट फ्रॉम मैनुअल लॉग रिव्यु
बाय हाईलाइटिंग ओनली सस्पिशियस एनो एनो
एनोमेलस इवेंट्स। एनोमेलस इवेंट्स का मतलब
होता है कि ऐसे इवेंट्स जो
नॉर्मल नहीं है जो जो नॉर्मल नहीं है
उसमें कुछ खामियां है एनोमली है कुछ
खामियां हैं कुछ दिक्कतें हैं ऐसी अलर्ट्स
तो क्या करते हैं आपके अलर्ट क्या है वो
आपका एक नोटिफिकेशन है जनरेट किए जाते हैं
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन सॉफ्टवेयर के द्वारा
जब कोई एक स्पेसिफिक इवेंट होता है या
सीक्वेंस ऑफ इवेंट होता है तब अलर्ट को
जारी किया जाता है जैसे कोई कोई एक इवेंट
हुआ मान लो एक इवेंट हुआ यूजर लॉग इन अब
यूजर लॉगिन पे जैसे ही कोई यूजर लॉग इन
करता है तो आ रहा है रॉन्ग पासवर्ड यानी
कि उसने गलत पासवर्ड डाला है तो ये तुरंत
एक अलर्ट को ट्रिगर कर देगा और ये आपकी
सिक्योरिटी सॉफ्टवेयर जो है वो ट्रिगर कर
देती है अलर्ट को एंड इस तरीके से जो
एसओसी एनालिस्ट होते हैं उनका बहुत टाइम
बचता है मैनुअली इसको चेक मैनुअल चेक करना
पॉसिबल है क्या इतना इतने अलर्ट्स आ रहे
हैं वो आ रहे हैं तो ये सॉफ्टवेयर ही वो
अलर्ट्स को एग्जीक्यूट करते अरे यूजर लॉग
इन हुआ है बट उसमें मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स
अटेम्प्ट हो रहे हैं। गलत पासवर्ड्स
बार-बार उनको बताए जा रहे हैं। यानी कि
मल्टीपल अटेम्प्ट्स हो रहे हैं। इस तरह से
होता है।
आई होप यू गॉट इट।
राइट?
अब ये है आपकी ट्रायग एनालिस्ट। यह आपके
भैया ट्रैक एनालिस्ट हैं। इनका कुछ इस
तरीके से काम होता है। इस तरीके से यह
ऑपरेट करते हैं। मतलब एक तो पहले अलर्ट एक
अलर्ट होती है। एसआईएम, एक्सडीआर, ईडीआर,
आईडीएस, आईपीएस, ईमेल, सिक्योरिटी ये सब
से एक अलर्ट आती है। राइट? दिस कम्स इन सब
से एक अलर्ट आता है।
ठीक है? आई एम फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश एंड
करेंटली फॉलोइंग द डीएचई कोर्स। इट इज़
सचिन मेंशंड डीएई नोट्स आर अवेलेबल फॉर
₹40 बट आई एम नॉट रिसीविंग द ओटीपी व्हाइल
ट्राइंग टू परचेस। अह आप अगर बांग्लादेश
से हैं तो प्लीज आप ईमेल का यूज कीजिए।
प्लीज यूज़ योर ईमेल नॉट योर फोन नंबर।
ओके? ईमेल पे आप यूज़ कीजिए। ईमेल पे ओटीपी
आपकी आ जाएगी। राइट? अब यह जो ट्रैक
एनालिस्ट होते हैं, जो ट्रैक करते हैं
अलग-अलग पर्टिकुलर अह अलर्ट्स को, उनका
क्या किस तरीके का वर्किंग होता अब
अलर्ट्स आया मान लो यहां से अलर्ट्स केम
सम हाउ ठीक राइट अब अलर्ट जब आएगा तो
बेसिकली यहां पे देखो यहां पे अलर्ट्स
आएंगे अब अलर्ट्स में मतलब ये अलर्ट्स
किसको जा रहे हैं ट्राई एनालिस्ट को जा
रहे हैं अलर्ट्स इनको इसको चला गया राइट
अब यहां पे ये प्लेबक्स को प्लेबुक्स को
सर्च करेगा प्लेब्स का मतलब है एक
फ्रेमवर्क को सर्च करेगा मान लो जैसे
mitre हो गया या सोर का यूज़ किया जा रहा
है यहां पे तो अलग-अलग फ्रेमवर्क कोई भी
फ्रेम फ्लेम या कोई सा भी प्लेबुक हो सकता
है। मैंने बताया था Myra को भी प्लेबुक
बोलते हैं। तो ये एक प्लेबुक मान लो सोर
प्लेबुक है। तो यहां पे ये अ जो पर्टिकुलर
अलर्ट्स हैं जब इसके पास आएंगे तो ये इसको
इस पे मैप करेगा। इन पर्टिकुलर एक एक रूल
के ऊपर एक ये रूल्स हैं। ये सेट ऑफ रूल्स
हैं। उन पे मैप करेगा। एंड फिर जो है क्या
करेगा? फिर भैया हमारा ये एक फीडबैक लूप
चलाएगा। वीक और मिसिंग फीडबैक लूप। फिर
यहां पे ये फीडबैक लूप यहां से आएगा।
एस्केलेट अलर्ट्स एंड रिमूव फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स विद क्लियर डॉक्यूमेंटेशन फॉर अ
स्मूथ हैंडशॉप। अगर मान लो किसी तरह का
कोई अ एक एस्केलेशन की जरूरत पड़ती है तो
ये एस्केलेट करेगा अलर्ट को सिंपल सा। एंड
जितने भी फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स उसको हटाएगा।
रियल वाले जो चीजें हैं उसको अह फोकस में
रखेगा। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स को हटा देगा। बट
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन जरूर करेगा। ये जो एनालिस्ट
है डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करना है कि भैया क्यों
हटा रहे कैसे हटा रहे हैं। ठीक है? और वीक
और मिसिंग कॉन्टेक्स्ट है अगर तो लॉग्स
चेक करेगा। जैसे कि कोई भी लॉग्स है और
लॉग्स जो हैं उसको जैसे क्लाउड के लॉग्स
हैं, एंड पॉइंट के लॉग्स हैं उनको भी चेक
करेगा। ये सारी चीजें करते हैं। उसके बाद
एक रूल के थ्रू यहां पे करेगा। अगर वीक और
मिसिंग फीडबैक लूप यहां से चलती है। इस
तरीके से फीडबैक लूप ये वीक और मिसिंग
वाली लूप चलती रहेगी आपकी। मान लो अगर वीक
है तो फिर वही सेम चीज़ यहां से लॉग
उठाएगा। दूसरी जगह से लॉग उठाएगा। फिर
देखेगा, चेक करेगा, एस्केलेट करेगा अपनी
अपने सीनियर को भेजेगा एस्केलेट करने की
जरूरत पड़ी तो फिर अगर नहीं तो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स को हटाएगा रियल जो है जो ट्रू
पॉजिटिव है उस पे काम करेगा इस तरीके से
वैसे फिर वीक और मिसिंग फीडबैक लूप इसी
तरह इस तरीके से भी काम करता है कि फिर से
अगर कोई अलर्ट आया है मान लो वीक है कुछ
खास मजेदार नहीं है तो वापस से फिर अलर्ट
को देखेगा कि भैया वापस से कहीं से कोई
अलर्ट आई है यहां से आई हो या दूसरे लॉग
से यहां से आई हो तो ये वापस से सेम
प्रोसेस को फॉलो करेगा कोई मतलब इसका
सिंपल सिनेरियो में समझा देता हूं। कोई एक
ट्रैक एनालिस्ट है या एसओसी एनालिस्ट है
मान लो वो अपना बैठा हुआ है बेचारा। अब
उसको सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन से एक अलर्ट आती
है। ठीक है? अब वो इस अलर्ट को एग्जामिन
करेगा। देखेगा कि ये वीक है। हाई
सीवियरिटी की है। लो सीवियरिटी की है। ये
देख लेगा। लो सीवियरिटी की होगी तो फिर से
वापस से दूसरे अलर्ट्स पे जाएगा। हाई
सीवियरिटी की होगी तो फिर ये उसमें से
देखेगा कि ये एक्चुअली सही है कि नहीं है।
उसमें से वही वो करेगा फिल्टर आउट। कैसे?
ट्रू पॉजिटिव्स को अलग करेगा। फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स को अलग करेगा। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स
क्यों फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स है? इसका
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करेगा। अपनी टीम को सेंड
करेगा सीनियर को। ट्रू पॉजिटिव है तो अगर
हाईली क्रिटिकल है तो उसको एस्कलेट कर
देगा। आगे अपने सीनियर्स को। नहीं है उतना
क्रिटिकल तो खुद ही जो है उस पे आगे के
प्रोसेससेस करके उसको क्लोज करेगा।
रेमिडीएट करेगा। रेमेडी करेगा उसका मतलब
उसको सही करेगा काउंटर मेजर करेगा दैट्स
इट
समझ में आ गया अलर्ट ट्रैग साइकिल नहीं है
ये दिस इज़ नॉट साइकिल
ठीक है अब व्हाई अलर्ट ट्रैग इज क्रिटिकल
क्रिटिकल क्यों है ये अलर्ट ट्रैग
क्रिटिकल क्यों है क्योंकि अगर आप प्रॉपर
ट्रैग नहीं करेंगे विदाउट प्रॉपर ट्रैग
अगर आप प्रॉपर ट्रैग नहीं करेंगे तो एसओसी
टीम्स ड्राउन इन अलर्ट तो एसओसी टीम्स के
पास इतने अलर्ट्स हो जाएंगे लाखों के कि
वो पागल हो जाएंगे। अगर यह प्रॉपर टाई
ट्रैग नहीं हुआ तो रियल अटैक्स गेट्स
मिस्ड। अगर प्रॉपर ट्रैग नहीं हुआ तो रियल
अटैक्स को मिस कर सकते हैं। एसोसिएट टीम
रियल अटैक्स के बारे में पता ही नहीं
चलेगा। रिस्पांस डिले हो जाएगा। अगर अलर्ट
सही से नहीं हुआ और बिजनेस पे इसका
इंपैक्ट पड़ेगा। बिजनेस की बैंड बज जाएगी।
अगर सही से अलर्ट नहीं करा गया तो अलर्ट
ट्रैग नहीं किया गया तो बाय द टीम विथ गुड
ट्रैग फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स आर रिड्यूस्ड अगर
अच्छे से ट्रायड हो रहा है अगर ट्राई किया
जा रहा है तो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स को रिड्यूस
किया जाता है रियल थ्रेट्स जो होते हैं
उसको जल्दी पकड़ा जाता है एंड एसओसी जो है
वो एफिशिएंट एंड ट्रस्टेड हो जाते हैं टीम
यह चीज़ है। अब एक बात याद रखिएगा एसओसी
टीम का प्रमोशन ट्रैग क्वालिटी के ऊपर
होता है। नंबर ऑफ अलर्ट्स कितने आपने डील
किए हैं, क्लोज किए हैं या एक्सक्लेट किए
हैं उससे नहीं होता है। ट्रैग की जो
क्वालिटी होगी उस पे आपकी प्रमोशन टिकी
है। तो याद रखिएगा कि जब भी आप किसी एसओसी
जॉब के लिए जाइएगा या एसओसी में जॉब
कीजिएगा एज एसओसी तो आपकी ट्राय की
क्वालिटी को मेंटेन कीजिएगा कि अगर मान लो
आप कोई चीज ट्रैक कर रहे हो तो जो चीज आप
बता रहे हो ट्रैक करने में वही चीज निकल
कर आए सामने से या उसके बहुत क्लोज हो।
तो फिर आपकी प्रमोशन पक्की है। राइट?
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां ट्रैक
डिसाइड्स वेदर एन अलर्ट बिकम्स एन
इंसिडेंट। अब यह ट्रैग ही डिसाइड करता है
कि एक नॉर्मल सा अलर्ट जो है वो इंसिडेंट
बन बन रहा है। इंसिडेंट है या नहीं।
इंसिडेंट का मतलब है एक्चुअली कुछ चीज हो
गया। एक्चुअली वो चीज हो गई। अलर्ट का
मतलब है जस्ट एक नोटिफिकेशन। इंसिडेंट का
मतलब है वो चीज इन इन अ
एग्जीक्यूशन है। इन एग्जीक्यूशन है। वो
चीज एक्चुअली हो गई है। तो ट्रायग ही
डिसाइड करता है कि ये अलर्ट ही रह जाएगा।
नॉर्मल हो के हट जाएगा या ये इंसिडेंट है।
यानी कि काम शुरू हो चुका है अटैकर का।
यानी कि अटैक इज़ स्टार्टेड। दिस इज़
द पावर ऑफ़ अलर्ट ट्रैक। अलर्ट ट्राई की
इसीलिए बहुतेंस होती है एंड इसलिए बहुत
जरूरी भी है कि जो भी अलर्ट्स है उसको
ट्राई किया जाए। आई थिंक आप समझ गए होंगे।
अब यहां पे अलर्ट्स के कुछ प्रॉपर्टीज है
जिसको हम देखेंगे। अलर्ट के प्रॉपर्टीज
उसको हम देखेंगे। व्हाट आर द अलर्ट
प्रॉपर्टीज? तो अलर्ट के बहुत सारे
प्रॉपर्टीज होते हैं। अब यहां जो
प्रॉपर्टीज मैंने आपको यहां पे दिखाया है।
ये एक कुछ छोटे से एग्जांपल्स हैं ये
प्रॉपर्टीज। ऐसे बहुत सारे और प्रॉपर्टीज
होते हैं। बट यहां पे कुछ छोटे से मेनमेन
प्रॉपर्टीज हैं। हम उनको देखते हैं अलर्ट
का। तो पहला एक अलर्ट टाइम होता है। तो
व्हेन द अलर्ट वाज़ जनरेटेड ये बताता है कि
अलर्ट कब जनरेट हुई थी? अलर्ट टाइम। अलर्ट
का प्रॉपर्टी मतलब जो अलर्ट आ रही है ना
इंडिकेटर्स का उसमें क्या-क्या चीजें होती
है? तो अलर्ट कब जनरेट हुआ था? तो अलर्ट
टाइम जो होता है वह प्रॉपर्टी के थ्रू पता
चलता है। अलर्ट नेम समरी ऑफ़ व्हाट
ट्रिगरर्ड। अलर्ट नेम से पता चलता है
किसका कि क्या ट्रिगर हुआ था। यह पता चलता
है। अलर्ट नेम से यह पता चलता है कि क्या
ट्रिगर हुआ था। व्हाट वाज़ एग्जैक्टली
ट्रिगरर्ड अनयूजुअल लॉग इन लॉग इन लोकेशन।
मान लो ये ट्रिगर हुआ था। अनयूजुअल लॉग इन
लोकेशन।
अलर्ट सीवियरिटी अर्जेंसी असाइन बाय
डिटेक्शन। लो मीडियम हाई क्रिटिकल। मतलब
डिटेक्शन की तरफ से क्या अर्जेंसी को
असाइन की गई थी इस पर्टिकुलर अलर्ट को? कि
भैया ये लो अलर्ट है, मीडियम अलर्ट था,
हाई अलर्ट था या क्रिटिकल अलर्ट था?
बस सर एसओसी में क्लाउड का कुछ पार्ट
इंक्लूड होता है। बिल्कुल क्लाउड भी
क्लाउड में भी होते हैं भाई। हां, क्लाउड
में भी लॉग्स होते हैं। क्लाउड इज़ आल्सो
पार्ट ऑफ़ क्लाउड एस बी आल्सो पार्ट ऑफ़
एसओसी। हम उसको भी देखेंगे। अलर्ट
सीिवियरिटी अर्जेंसी असाइन बाय द
डिटेक्शन। मतलब वही जो डिटेक्शन के द्वारा
अर्जेंसी एक असाइन की जाती है। अलर्ट
स्टेटस करंट लाइफ साइकिल स्टेट न्यू है,
इन प्रोग्रेस है या क्लोज है। मतलब कोई
अलर्ट पे काम हो रहा है तो कोई नया अलर्ट
है उसको असाइन किया जाता है। सॉफ्टवेयर के
अंदर ये सब असाइनमेंट होती है। ये सब
चीजें सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर होती है। याद
रखिएगा या कोई ह्यूमन इंसान नहीं कर रहा
होता है कहीं खड़ा हो के। टीम जो होती है
वो सॉफ्टवेयर पे काम कर रही होती है। उसी
सॉफ्टवेयर पे ये सारे काम होते हैं जो
मैंने अभी आपको जितने भी अभी चीजें बताई
हैं सब।
तो अलर्ट स्टेटस में यह पता चलता है कि
न्यू है, प्रोग्रेस में है या क्लोज्ड है।
अलर्ट वर्डिक्ट यानी कि सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट एल1 क्लासिफिकेशन आउटकम मतलब वो
बताता है इस अलर्ट के बारे में कि
एक्सैक्टली ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव अलर्ट है या
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है। मतलब सही है या गलत है।
अलर्ट असाइनी एनालिस्ट हैंडलिंग द अलर्ट।
जो हैंडल कर रहा है असाइन एनालिस्ट नेम
मतलब कि उस अलर्ट के ऊपर जिसका भी नाम
असाइन हुआ है और जिस जो भी एनालिस्ट उस
अलर्ट को पर्टिकुलरली हैंडल कर रहा है वो
अलर्ट असाइन कहलाता है। अलर्ट असाइन की
कैटेगरी में आता है। अलर्ट डिस्क्रिप्शन
एक्सप्लेनेशन ऑफ व्हाट द अलर्ट मींस। इस
अलर्ट डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या होता है? उस
अलर्ट का एग्जैक्ट मतलब क्या है? उसका
पूरा डिटेल एक्सप्लेनेशन डिटेल
डिस्क्रिप्शन ऑफ सस्कर एक्टिविटी। जो भी
एक्टिविटी हो रही है उसका डिटेल जानकारी
अलॉट फील्ड्स कॉनसेप्चुअल वैल्यूज़ दैट लेड
टू द अलर्ट अफेक्टेड होस्ट नेम्स एंटर्ड
कमांड लाइन ईटीसी मतलब कि ये फील्ड्स होते
हैं ऐसे जहां पे जो भी वैल्यू होती है
कॉनसेक्चुअल वैल्यू जो कि अलर्ट जो दैट
लीड्स टू द अलर्ट मतलब अलर्ट के आने में
जिनका वैल्यू जिनका रोल होता है वो अलर्ट
फील्ड्स में आते हैं। जैसे अफ़ेक्टेड होस्ट
नेम्स। कौन-कौन से होस्ट नेम्स को अफ़ेक्ट
किया गया है? एंटर्ड कमांड लाइन। जो भी
कमांड एंटर की गई है उस पर्टिकुलर होस्ट
को या होस्ट को इनफेक्ट करने के लिए वो सब
अलर्ट फील्ड्स में आते हैं। दैट्स इट।
सिंपल एज एज यूज़। आई होप आप समझ गए होंगे।
ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब आते हैं यहां पे अलर्ट के
प्रायोरिटाइजेशन पे। अब देखो, यह भी एक
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है। अलर्ट की
प्रायोरिटाइजेशन करना। द प्रोसेस ऑफ
डिसाइडिंग वि अलर्ट टू टेक इज कॉल्ड अलर्ट
प्राइिंग। अब अलर्ट्स जब भी आ रहे हैं ना,
तो अब कौन सा अलर्ट को कंसीडर किया जाएगा?
किसको पहले कंसीडर किया जाएगा? ये भी काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है गाइस। इसको हम अलर्ट की
प्रायोरिटाइजेशन करते हैं। अब बिना
प्रायोरिटीशन के प्रायोरिटाइजेशन के तो
कुछ होता नहीं है। प्रायोरिटी इज़
एवरीथिंग। आप जिसको प्रायोरिटी दोगे वो
खुश रहेगा आपसे। आप जिसको प्रायोरिटी नहीं
दोगे वो कुछ नहीं रहेगा। एज सिंपल एज दैट।
राइट? तो प्रायोरिटाइजेशन आपको करना होता
है अलर्ट के केस में। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे कैसे
करते हैं? एव्री एसओसी टीम डिसाइड्स ऑन
इट्स ओन प्रायोरिटाइजेशन रूल्स एंड
यूजुअली ऑटोमेट्स देम बाय सेटिंग द
एप्रोप्रियट अलर्ट सॉर्टिंग लॉजिक इन
एसआईएम और आईडिया। मतलब यहां पे है हर
एसोसिएट टीम का अपना एक प्रायोरिटाइजेशन
रूल होता है। वो अपना रूल बना लेते हैं कि
भ हम इस तरीके से प्रायोरिटाइज करेंगे। हम
इस तरीके से चीजें करेंगे। एंड उसी को वह
ऑटोमेट कर देते हैं। एक अलर्ट सॉर्टिंग
लॉजिक लगा देते हैं। एसआईएम जो सॉफ्टवेयर
होती है, इडिया सॉफ्टवेयर होती है और
उसमें वो सेट कर देते हैं। अब उसी के
अकॉर्डिंग जो है वो अलर्ट को प्रायरिटाइज
करते हैं। जैसे पहला फ़्टर द अलर्ट्स।
फ़िल्टर करते हैं, शॉर्ट करते हैं। देन
शॉर्ट बाय टाइम करते हैं। शॉर्ट एक
सीवियरिटी एंड शॉर्ट बाय टाइम। तो, फ़िल्टर
कैसे करते हैं? मेक श्योर यू डोंट टेक द
अलर्ट दैट अदर एनालिस्ट हैव ऑलरेडी
रिव्यूड। अब इसको फ़्टर भी करना है कि भाई
ऐसा अलर्ट हम ना उस पे काम करने लगे जो
ऑलरेडी किसी और एनालिस्ट के द्वारा हैंडल
किया जा रहा है। कोई मतलब नहीं बनता ना
कोई और हैंडल कर रहा है। फिर आप भी उसी पे
चढ़े पड़े हो। आप भी उसी पे लगे पड़े हो।
क्या फायदा हुआ? और दैट इज़ ऑलरेडी बीइंग
इन्वेस्टिगेटेड बाय वन ऑफ़ योर टीममेट्स।
तो उसको छोड़ देना भाई। उसको छोड़ देना है।
जो अलर्ट ऑलरेडी कोई हैंडल कर रहा है उसको
छोड़ दो। सिंपल तो अलर्ट उसको फ़्टर कर
देंगे। सॉर्ट बाय सीवियरिटी। अब सॉर्टिंग
होती है सीिवियरिटी के। स्टार्ट विद
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स देन हाई, मीडियम एंड
फाइनली लो। तो सबसे पहले जो अलर्ट पे काम
होता है वो होता है क्रिटिकल अलर्ट पे। जो
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स हैं सबसे पहले उस पे काम
होता है। फिर हाई फिर मीडियम एंड फिर लो
वाले। तो ये तो नॉर्मल सी ये तो मतलब अह
नॉर्मल मतलब वो है अह काइंड ऑफ़ कि दिस इज़
अ यूजुअल राइट ये यूज़ुअल है कि हां इस
तरीके से काम होता है। दिस इज़ बिकॉज़
डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर्स डिज़ रूल्स सो दैट
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स आर मच मोर लाइकली टू बी
रियल मेजर थ्रेट्स एंड कॉज मच मोर इंपैक्ट
देन मीडियम और लोअ वंस।
सिंपल। दिस इज बिकॉज़ डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर्स
डिजाइन रूल्स। सो दैट द क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स
आर मच मोर लाइकली टू बी रियल। क्योंकि
डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर्स को ऐसा लगता है कि जो
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स हैं वो ज्यादा रियल
होंगे एंड कॉज मोर इंपैक्ट देन मीडियम और
लोअ्स। तो ये तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है। ये
नॉर्मल सी समझने वाली बात है। इट इज़ एन
अंडरस्टैंडेबल थिंग। राइट? बहुत नॉर्मल सी
चीज़ है कि अगर कोई क्रिटिकल अलर्ट है तो
वो ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल होगी। जो मीडियम और
लो वाले होंगे वो कम इंपैक्टफुल होंगे। तो
डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर्स इसी तरीके से इसी के
बेस पे रूल बनाते हैं। तो सीवियरिटी में
इसीलिए क्रिटिकल को सबसे पहले रखा जाता
है। ये तो नॉर्मल चीज है। ठीक है? बस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] 10 मिनट 15 मिनट
और 15 मिनट और रुक जाओ। जस्ट 15 मिनट्स।
देन आती है शॉर्टिंग बाय टाइम। स्टार्ट्स
विद द ओल्डेस्ट अलर्ट्स
एंड्स विद द निवेस्ट वन। द आईडिया इज दैट
इफ बोथ अलर्ट्स आर अबाउट टू अबाउट टू
ब्रचेज।
इफ बोथ अलर्ट्स आर अबाउट टू ब्रचेज द हैकर
फ्रॉम द ओल्ड ब्रिज इज लाइकली ऑलरेडी
डंपिंग योर डाटा व्हाइल द न्यू कमर हैड
जस्ट स्टार्टेड डिस्कवरिंग ये बहुत बड़ा
माइंडसेट है एक माइंडसेट का गेम है कि अगर
कोई अटैक हुआ है राइट एंड उसमें अगर कोई
एक ओल्ड अलर्ट है उस अटैक का एक कोई नया
अलर्ट है तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है ओल्ड अटैक
पे अटैकर जो होगा वो बहुत डेवलपमेंट कर
चुका होगा आगे वो और भी चीजें कर चुका
ऊंगा। हो सकता है आपके क्रेडेंशियल्स डंप
कर रहा है, डाटा डंप कर रहा है तो उसको
रोकना पहले ज्यादा जरूरी है। देन द न्यू
अलर्ट।
तो पहले ओल्ड वाले अलर्ट पे फोकस देन न्यू
वाले पे।
दैट्स इट। ये होती है आपकी अलर्ट
प्रायोरिटेशन करना। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पे अलर्ट्स का पूरा मैं आपको गेम
समझा देता हूं। किस तरीके से होता है। तो
सबसे पहले लॉग्स द फर्स्ट फॉरस्ट थिंग
डिस्कवरी होती है।
देन प्रीलिमिनरी इन्वेस्टिगेशन होता है।
देन ट्रायग होती है। देन एक्सटेंडेड
इन्वेस्टिगेशन होता है। देन उसको कंटेन या
रिसोंड या मिटिगेट या उसको रॉल्व किया
जाता है। ये पूरा प्रोसेस होता है। अब
इसमें डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट प्रोसेससेस हैं। अब
जैसे डिस्कवरी कहां से होती है? पहले तो
लॉग्स जो होते हैं वो निकाले जाते हैं या
एंड पॉइंट डेटा जो एंड पॉइंट्स यानी आपके
मशीन का डेटा होता है जो भी मशीन से डेटा
या इवेंट लॉ्स या लॉग्स को निकाला जाता है
पहले राइट ये एक्सटर्नल थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
के थ्रू भी होता है। अब इसको कोरिलेट किया
जाता है एसआईएम के थ्रू। फिर बिहेवियरल
एनालिटिक्स किया जाता है। मतलब बिहेवियरल
एनालिटिक्स बिहेवियर के बेसिस पे। फिर
एनोमली एनालिटिक्स का किया जाता है। यानी
कि किसी तरह का कोई गड़बड़ी का देखा जाता
है। किसी तरह की कोई एनिमली तो नहीं।
एनोमली का मतलब होता है कि किसी तरह की
कोई गड़बड़ी टाइप कुछ जो चीज नहीं होनी
चाहिए वो तो नहीं है। एंड देन डिसेप्शन
टेक्नोलॉजीस का यूज़ किया जा सकता है।
किया जाता है। डिसेप्शन टेक्नोलॉजीस का
यूज़ करके देखा जाता है कि हां भैया कोई
किसी तरह का कोई डिसेप्शन यहां पे तो नहीं
है। देन क्या किया जाता है? लिंकिंग,
स्कोरिंग, मर्जिंग एंड प्रीिलिमिनरी
स्कोपिंग। मतलब उसके बाद इन सबको लिंक
किया जाता है। उनका स्कोरिंग किया जाता है
कि भैया क्या स्कोर का है? कौन सा सबसे
कौन सा ज्यादा मतलब अह स्कोर कर रहा है
यानी कि क्रिटिकल हो सकता है। देन उनको
मर्ज किया जाता है एंड देन एक स्कोप बनाया
जाता है प्रीलिमिनरी स्कोप कि मतलब भैया
ये ये चीजें हैं ये ये पर्टिकुलर स्कोप के
अंदर में ये ये चीजें मर्ज करके ये ये
चीजें जो है वो अलर्ट्स जो हैं उनको हमने
इन्वेस्टिगेट किया है। उनको हमने
इन्वेस्टिगेट करके अब हम उनको
ट्रैक करने के लिए रेडी हैं। फिर हम रैंक
करेंगे। अब ट्रैक ट्रैक के पहले हम जो
ट्रैगिंग कर रहे हैं उसमें हमने बेसिकली
क्या किया? रैंक किया। अब हमने ट्रैग
किया। हमने एक्सेप्ट किया कि हां भैया ये
ये सारी चीजें गड़बड़ी हैं। ये ये सारी
चीजें प्रॉब्लमैटिक हैं। ये अलर्ट सही
हैं। इन इससे खतरा है। तो अब रैंकिंग
करेंगे। कौन सबसे ज्यादा क्रिटिकल लेवल पे
है? उससे नीचे उससे नीचे उससे नीचे ऐसे
करके। फिर जब रैंकिंग कर देंगे ट्राई कर
देंगे तो आप फुल स्कोपिंग विजुअलाइजेशन
इनरचमेंट। अब उस पे पूरा डीप
इन्वेस्टिगेशन चलेगी। पूरी फुल स्कोप
देखेंगे क्या है कैसे कौन सा अलर्ट कौन सा
अटैक है किस तरह का अटैक है सबसे ज्यादा
क्रिटिकल कौन है उसको लाओ पहले उसको पकड़ो
उस पे डीप इन्वेस्टिगेशन करो भैया कैसे
हुआ क्यों हुआ किस क्या प्रोसेस रहा है
mur्रे से कंपेयर करेंगे हम जो फ्रेमवर्क
बना है m्रे का उससे हम कंपेयर देखेंगे कि
किस तरीके से ये प्रोसेस हो रहा है किस
तरीके की चीजें चल रही हैं। राइट? ये सारी
चीज़ एंड देन लास्ट में आता है क्वारेंटाइन
या रेमडिएट या अपडेट या शेयर। लास्ट में
या तो उसको क्वारेंटाइन किया जाएगा या तो
उसको रिॉल्व किया जाएगा या तो उसको सॉल्व
मतलब व्हाटएवर जो भी उसको अपडेट किया
जाएगा, पैच किया जाएगा या जो भी होगा वो
फिर लास्ट में किया जाएगा। ये पूरा का
पूरा एक प्रोसेस होता है। ये पूरा का पूरा
प्रोसेस होता है। यह प्रोसेस जो है ये
प्रोसेस बहुत इजी प्रोसेस है। आपको बस ऊपर
वाला ध्यान रखना है। यह नीचे वाले अगर
आपको नहीं भी समझ में आ रहे हैं, छोड़
दीजिए। कोई जरूरत आपको नहीं है। बस इसको
समझ जाइए। पहले डिस्कवर करेंगे अलर्ट्स
को। मतलब जो भी है। फिर एक इनिशियल
इन्वेस्टिगेशन होगी। फिर ट्राई होगा। पता
चलेगा कि कौन सही है, कौन गलत है, क्या
है। देन उसमें से ट्राई करेंगे तो रैंकिंग
भी करेंगे कि क्रिटिकल कौन है, मीडियम हाई
कौन है। फिर उस पे और डीप इन्वेस्टिगेशन
चलेगी कि भैया एग्जैक्ट कैसे हुआ, क्या
हुआ? टीटीपीस को फॉलो होंगी एंड फिर उस पे
रेमेडी होगी। दैट्स इट। फिर उसका सॉलशन
होगा। समझ में आ गया?
नीचे वाले के कंफ्यूजन हो रहे हैं तो ऊपर
वाले से मैंने आपको समझा दिया इजी वे में
ताकि आपको समझ मेन हमारा मोटिव है समझ में
आना। मोटिव यह नहीं है कि हम सामने
स्क्रीन पे कितना कुछ देख रहे हैं। मोटिव
है हमें कितना समझ में आ रहा है। हमारे
दिमाग में कितना चीज फिट बैठ जा रहा है वो
हमारा मेन है कांसेप्ट पे फोकस करना। ये
टॉपिक्स और ये जो लिखी हुई चीजें ये तो
बहुत सारी आएंगी। ऐसी तो बहुत सारी चीजें
तो आपको मिल जाएंगी इंटरनेट पे। बट दिमाग
में एक कांसेप्ट घुस जाए वो मैटर करता है।
ठीक है? आई होप समझ में आ गया होगा।
ठीक है। अब आते हैं यहां पे अलर्ट
ट्रैगिंग जो होती है किस तरीके से होती
है? हालांकि अलर्ट ट्रैगिंग
करने का एक हम लाइव एक हम इसको
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के थ्रू देखेंगे लैब के
थ्रू तो ज्यादा समझ में आएगा। एग्जैक्ट
ट्रैगिंग का मतलब क्या होता है? ठीक है?
फिर हम ज्यादा समझ पाएंगे। ठीक है?
इनिशियल एक्शन होता है पहले।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देन
इन्वेस्टिगेशन होती है। देन फाइनल एक्शन
होता है। अलर्ट ट्रैगिंग में। इनिशियल
स्टेप्स क्या होता है? आर डिज़ टू इंश्योर
दैट यू टेक ओनरशिप ऑफ द असाइन अलर्ट।
ये इनिशियल एक्शन है कि आप उसका ओनरशिप
लेते हैं एंड अवॉयड इंटरफेयरिंग वि द
अलर्ट्स बीइंग हैंडल्ड बाय अदर एनालिस्ट।
जैसा कि हमने पहले ही देखा था। मतलब आपके
पास मतलब जो अलर्ट आपको मिला है आपका आप
आपके पास अलर्ट एक दिख रहा है आपको तो आप
उसका ओनरशिप ले लीजिए कि मैं इस अलर्ट को
मैनेज करूंगा और दूसरे के अलर्ट्स में
इंटरफेयर आप मत कीजिए। तो आप खुद को भी
असाइन कर सकते हैं। बस अब जैसे पहला अलर्ट
होगा आपने खुद को असाइन किया न्यू। अब मैं
आपको इसको विजुअलाइज करा देता हूं किस
तरीके से होता है ये। तो इसके लिए हम एक
लैब पे चलेंगे। हम हम
गो टू द लैब एंड इस पे चलते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके मैं
इसको रिसेट कर देता हूं ताकि
आपको समझ में ईजी समझने में इजी आए थोड़ा
इजी हो जाए थोड़ा सा। ठीक है? अब देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे अब
मैं यहां पे कौन सी चीजें यहां पे कुछ इस
तरीके से दिखती है ये अलर्ट डैशबोर्ड जो
है कुछ इस तरीके से ये पता है ये अलर्ट
डैशबोर्ड्स जो है ये जैसे जीरा सॉफ्टवेयर
आती है टिकटिंग टाइप का सॉफ्टवेयर है ये
टिकटिंग सॉफ्टवेयर्स की जो होते हैं ना उस
तरीके से कुछ आपको यहां पे कई बार दिख
जाएगा उसमें भी ऐसा होता है कई बार तो अब
यहां पे मैं अलर्ट प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाता हूं
एसओसी का डैशबोर्ड है इसे ओपन कर लेते हैं
हम ये अलर्ट ट्रैक देखो ये एक डैशबोर्ड है
एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड बोर्ड है एसओसी का। कुछ
इस तरीके से होती है ये। जैसे अब क्या
होती है? यहां पे आप अलर्ट को सर्च कर
सकते हैं। यहां से आप अलर्ट सर्च कर सकते
हैं। अब अलग-अलग डेट्स को अलर्ट्स आए हैं।
देखो इस अलर्ट को समझो। एक 21 मार्च को एक
अलर्ट आया है। सारे 21 मार्च को टाइमिंग
अलग-अलग है। एक 1153 पे, 1240 पे, 1302
पे, 13:30 पे, 1358 पे। ये सब एक डेट के
अलर्ट्स हैं। अब अलर्ट का नाम क्या है? ये
अलर्ट का नाम दिया हुआ है। एक अलर्ट है
डबल एक्सटेंशन फाइल क्रिएशन। यह एक अलर्ट
है। आईओसी पोटेंशियल डाटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
डाउनलोड फ्रॉम गीब रिपोज़िटरी अनयूजुअल
वीपीए लॉग इन लोकेशनेशंस ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
फ्रॉम एक्सटर्नल। ठीक है? ये अलर्ट्स के
अलग-अलग नाम है। ठीक है? ओके? अब आते हैं
यहां पे इसकी सीिवियरिटी। अच्छी बात है।
जिन लोगों ने लैब कंप्लीट कर लिया है
अच्छी बात है। बहुत अच्छी बात है। आप लैब
कंप्लीट अगर कर चुके हैं। बट यहां पर आपको
थोड़ा ध्यान देना है। हो सकता है मैं कुछ
चीजें आपको लैब कंप्लीट करना तो बहुत आसान
होता है। इट्स वेरी ईजी टू कंप्लीट ट्राई
हैक लैब्स। देख लो इधर कर लो डाल दो कहीं
ना कहीं से मिल ही जाता है। बट उसको समझना
बहुत मुश्किल है। उसको समझना बहुत ज्यादा
जरूरी है। ठीक है? तो वो समझिए आप।
सीवियरिटी
हाई क्रिटिकल लो मीडियम ये सब। राइट? ये
जो सीवियरिटी है ये सीवियरिटी डिफाइन करती
है। अब स्टेटस दिखा रहा है अवेटिंग एक्शन
अवेटिंग एक्शन अवेटिंग एक्शन ये क्लोज्ड
है। ये क्लोज्ड है। तो अवेटिंग एक्शन का
मतलब है कि आप इस पे कुछ एक्शन लेंगे।
वर्डिक्ट क्या है? इसमें अभी नन नन नन
इसमें वर्डिक्ट एक पहले से मिला है। फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है। ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव है। ये फॉल्स
है। ये ट्रू है। राइट? दिस असाइनी मतलब
किसको असाइन हुआ है? नन नन नन एक ये असाइन
हुआ है। एक टी रॉस करके हैं कोई। और ये है
जे एडमम्स। उनका साइन और फिर ये यहां पे
एकशंस होते हैं। ये एक्शन है। अब जब इनको
आप एक्सपेंड करोगे तो इसमें आपको बाकी
डिटेल मिलेगी। जब आप एक-एक जो लॉ जो
अलर्ट्स हैं उनको जब एक्सपेंड करोगे तो
आपको इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन मिलेगा, होस्ट
मिलेगा, प्रोसेस का नाम मिलेगा, प्रोसेस
का यूजर मिलेगा, टारगेट फाइल मिलेगी, फाइल
का एम ओटीW जो होता है वो आपको मिलेगा एंड
यहां पे फाइल की एमडी फाइल मिलेगी। ये
सारी चीजें मिलेगी। अब हम इसको भी
देखेंगे, समझेंगे। पहले हम आते हैं लैब के
ऊपर। ठीक है? अब यहां पे आई थिंक इसके ऊपर
में तो कोई लैब नहीं थी ना। इसमें तो नहीं
थी।
हां। [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] अब यहां पे
लैब में जब आते हैं तो यहां पे आ रहा है
कि व्हाट इज द नंबर ऑफ अलर्ट्स यू सी इन
एसओसी डैशबोर्ड? नंबर ऑफ अलर्ट्स कितने
हैं भैया? तो इसमें कितने अलर्ट्स हैं?
नंबर ऑफ अलर्ट्स। बताइए जरा एक बार देख
के। ये तो बहुत ईजी क्वेश्चन है। बताइए
कितने अलर्ट्स हैं?
कितने अलर्ट्स हैं इसमें? नंबर ऑफ
अलर्ट्स। जल्दी बताइए। जल्दी-जल्दी अब
रिप्लाई करना है आपको। फटाफट। हाउ मेनी
नंबर ऑफ अलर्ट्स?
फाइव है।
बिल्कुल। चलिए तो वो तो दिख रहा है फाइव
है। तो हमने फाइव किया एंड इट्स डन। व्हाट
इज द नेम ऑफ़ मोस्ट रीसेंट अलर्ट यू सी?
सबसे रीसेंट अलर्ट जो है उसका नाम क्या
है? तो रीसेंट अलर्ट कौन सा है? 1358
वाला। 1358 वाला। तो, यह है डबल एक्सटेंशन
फाइल क्रिएशन। यह अलर्ट का नाम है। तो,
हमने यहां पर डाल दिया डबल एक्सटेंशन फाइल
क्रिएशन। चेक करते हैं।
बिल्कुल सही है। बिल्कुल सही है। राइट।
सो, यह हो गया अपना। अब लेकिन, यह तो
नॉर्मल सी चीज थी। यह कौन सा है भाई? इसको
चेक कर देते हैं। [संगीत]
अब आते हैं अलर्ट प्रॉपर्टीज पे। थोड़ा सा
अब आगे बढ़ते हैं। अब अलर्ट प्रॉपर्टीज पे
आते हैं यहां पे। अब यहां पे ऑप्शन आ रहा
है व्हाट वाज़ द वर्डिक्ट ऑफ द अनयूजुअल
वीपीए लॉगिन लोकेशन अलर्ट? तो अनयूजुअल
वीपीए लॉगिन लोकेशन अलर्ट। यह है। इसका
वर्डिक्ट क्या है? तो वर्डिक्ट यहां पे
दिया हुआ है। देखो यहां पे ये वर्डिक दिया
हुआ है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। तो सिंपल हमारा ये
इसका फ्लैग जो है वो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव हो
जाएगा। बस दैट्स इट। व्हाट यूजर वाज़
मेंशंड इन द अनयूजुअल वीपीए लॉग इन लोकेशन
अलर्ट। कौन सा यूजर मेंशंड है? अनयूजुअल
वीपीए लॉग इन लोकेशन में कौन सा यूजर
मेंशंड है? बताइए जरा।
कौन सा यूजर मेंशंड है? बताइए जरा।
अनयल वीपीए लॉग इन लोकेशन में
टी रॉस
टी रोस
गलत बिल्कुल गलत आंसर है टी रोस नहीं है
भाई टी रॉस नहीं है टी रोस इज़ नॉट यूजर टी
रॉस तो असाइन ही है एसओसी एनालिस्ट है वो
इसको जब आप एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो आप देखेंगे
यहां पे सोर्स यूजर यह देखो सोर्स यूजर
आपको यहां पे दे रखा है तो इट्स एम
क्लार्क यह क्लार्केंट नहीं एम क्लार्क तो
एम क्लार्क है आपका जो इसका
मेंशंड यूजर है जो भी मेंशंड यूजर है इस
अलर्ट में वो एम क्लार्क है तो अब देखो एम
क्लार्क बिल्कुल सही है। चलिए ये तो हो
गया। अब आते हैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अलर्ट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] प्रायोरिटाइजेशन
पे। अलर्ट प्रायोरिटाइजेशन में आएंगे तो
यहां पे आ रहा है शुड यू फर्स्ट
प्रायोरिटाइज मीडियम ओवर लो सीवियरिटी
अलर्ट्स तो हां यार बिल्कुल यह और नहीं
देना है तो ये हां ऑब्वियस सी बात है मैं
मीडियम को प्रायोरिटाइज करूंगा ये पूछने
वाली बात है शुड यू फर्स्ट टेक द न्यूएस्ट
अलर्ट एंड द एंड देन ओल्डर वन नहीं ऐसा
नहीं है ओल्डर को पहले लेना है दम न्यू
वालों को कर लेना है तो यहां पे नहीं नो
ओल्डर को पहले लेना है ना भाई अब यहां पे
क्या है असाइन योरसेल्फ टू द फर्स्ट
प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट एंड चेंज इट्स स्टेटस टू
इन प्रोग्रेस द नेम ऑफ योर सिलेक्टेड अलॉट
विल बी द आंसर टू द क्वेश्चन। तो ये देखना
ध्यान देना कि यह बोल रहा है फर्स्ट
प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट को असाइन करो खुद को और
प्रोग्रेस कर दो स्टेटस को। तो इसमें
फर्स्ट प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट कौन सा हो सकता
है? आपके लिए सबसे ज्यादा प्रायोरिटी का
अलर्ट इसमें कौन होगा? पहला फर्स्ट
प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट कौन सा होगा बताइए?
यस। बिल्कुल सही। द फर्स्ट प्रायोरिटी
अलर्ट विल बी व्हिच वन?
यस। पोटेंशियल डाटा एक्सप्लेटेशन। क्यों?
क्योंकि ये क्रिटिकल है। क्रिटिकल को हमें
सबसे पहले देखना है। तो क्रिटिकल है। तो
अब हमें इसको क्या करना है? एडिट करना है।
हमें इसको स्टेटस को इन प्रोग्रेस करना
है। जैसा कि लैब में दिया गया है।
वर्डिक्ट अभी कुछ नहीं। असाइनी असाइनी में
जाके हमें खुद को असाइन करना है L1 को एंड
यहां पे प्रोग्रेस इन प्रोग्रेस करना है
एंड सेव करना है। जैसे ही आप सेव करेंगे
यहां पे पोटेंशियल डेटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन
इसको कॉपी करना है। यही हमारा नाम है जो
इसने देखा है ना कि जो आप सेलेक्ट करोगे
अलर्ट वही है। तो पोटेंशियल डेटा
एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन चेक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सिंपल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हो गया। यही
था आपका आंसर। तो ये हो गया अलर्ट
प्रायोरिटेशन भी हो गई। अब अलर्ट ट्रैक पे
आते हैं। अलर्ट ट्रैक पे आएंगे तो यहां पे
क्या लिखा हुआ है? वि फ्लैग डिड यू रिसीव
आफ्टर यू करेक्टली ट्रैक द फर्स्ट
प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट। फर्स्ट प्रायोरिटी
अलर्ट को अब देखो कैसे आप अब यहां पे
देखिए इफ यू डोंट रिसीव अ फ्लैग आफ्टर यू
ट्रैक इट मींस दैट द वैल्यूज़ यू सेट आर
रॉन्ग। ठीक है? यू कैन रिसेट द एसोसिएट
डैशबोर्ड बाय क्लिकिंग दिए। ये तो हम कहते
हैं कि जो फर्स्ट हमारा प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट
है उसको ट्राई करना है। तो हमारा फर्स्ट
प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट यही है पोटेंशियल डेटा
एक्सिल्ट्रेशन। यही तो है हमारा। राइट? तो
इसको हमें ट्राई करना है भैया। तो क्या
करना है हमें? अच्छा
ये ट्रैक कैसे होगा? हां अब इसको हमें
ट्राई करना है। फर्स्ट ये वाला जो चीज है
इसको ट्राई करना है। तो ट्रैक करने का
हमें ऑप्शन यहां पे कहीं नहीं है। याद
रखिएगा यहां पे कोई ऑप्शन नहीं दे रखा है।
बट हमारे पास क्या है कि इसमें ऑप्शंस चूज़
करने के लिए है। तो ये इन प्रोग्रेस है।
ठीक है? वर्डिक्ट क्या है? ट्रू पॉजिटिव
करते हैं। सीवियरिटी क्रिटिकल है आप यहां
पे वो हैं। और यहां पे कमेंट हम कर देते
हैं। कर देते हैं। इट्स अ कुछ भी डाल देते
हैं। इट्स इट्स अ
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट। ऐसा हमने कुछ भी लिख
दिया। इट्स अ क्रिटिकल अलर्ट। राइट? अब
हमने ये सब चीज कर दिया। अब यहां पे मान
लो इसको डिस्क इसको जब यहां पे
हो गया। सब कुछ कर दिया हमने। इन
प्रोग्रेस है। हमने अब इसको यहां पे सेव
कर दिया। अब हमने यहां पे सेव किया। अब
हमारे पास ये क्या आ रहा है? ट्रू पॉजिटिव
आ रहा है। L1 आ रहा है। ये सारी चीजें आ
रही है। अब हम इसके
सॉरी अब हम इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन पे जब आप
जाएंगे यहां पे तो डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको
सारी चीजें दिख रही है कि दिस रूल
डिटेक्ट्स फाइव और मोर गीगाबाइट्स ऑफ़ डेटा
सेंट फ्रॉम अ सिंगल डिवाइस टू अ सिंगल
डेस्टिनेशन विद इन अ डे। व्हिच मे इंडिकेट
डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन टू अनट्रस्टेड
लोकेशन। अब ये अनट्रस्टेड लोकेशन पे डेटा
भेज रहा था। तो हमने यहां पे क्या किया?
सबसे पहले कि इन प्रोग्रेस में ट्रू
पॉजिटिव क्रिटिकल एल1 ये सब सेलेक्ट करके
रख दिया। ठीक है? ये इन प्रोग्रेस में
हमने कर दिया। बट जब हम किसी चीज को ट्रैक
करते हैं जब हमने सब कुछ सब कुछ सही कर
दिया। तो अब हमारा काम है उस चीज को बंद
कर देना। तो पहले हम इन प्रोग्रेस पे सारा
चीज कर देंगे कि हां भैया इन प्रोग्रेस
में क्या है? हमने ट्रू पॉजिटिव कर दिया।
हमने सीवियरिटी क्रिटिकल ही रखा है। एंड
हमने खुद को असाइन करा था पहले वाले चीज
में इट्स अ क्रिटिकल एलर्ट कर दिया। अब हम
इसको क्लोज कर देंगे क्योंकि हमारा काम
यहां पे हो चुका है। इट्स नाउ क्लोज्ड।
इट्स नाउ डन। इट्स नाउ फिनिश्ड। तो हम
क्लोज करके यहां पे सेव कर देंगे। अब जैसे
ही यहां पे क्लोज करके यहां पे सेव करेंगे
इट शुड बी गिविंग अस समथिंग। लेट्स सी
कुछ नहीं हुआ।
ओके। व्हाई इट इज़ नॉट पहले तो हमारा यही
था ना
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है।
ओके तो इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन को ही लिख देते
हैं। देखो
अ डिस्क्रिप्शन में यहां पे मैं यहां पे
डिस्क्रिप्शन को एडिट कर देता हूं फिलहाल
के लिए। एंड इसको तो हमने क्लोज़ कर दिया
है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। इसको री रीस्टार्ट
कर देते हैं। वापस से रिस्टार्ट कर देते
हैं। ओके? इट्स डन। अब एक बार फिर से आते
हैं पोटेंशियल डाटा एक्सपेक्टेशन में। तो
यहां पे खुद को असाइन कर लेते हैं। स्टेटस
को यहां पे अ इन प्रोग्रेस कर देते हैं।
एंड क्रिटिकल है। वर्डिक्ट में ट्रू
पॉजिटिव कर देते हैं। फिलहाल इसको सेव कर
देते हैं। ये ये हो गया सेम ट्रू पॉजिटिव
इन प्रोग्रेस। अब वापस से जब जाएंगे तो
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है। स्टेटस में हम यहां पे
डिस्क्रिप्शन में यहां पे अ
फाइव और मोर गीगाबाइट्स ऑफ़ डेटा सेंट
फ्रॉम अ सिंगल डिवाइस टू अ सिंगल
डेस्टिनेशन विद इन अ डे। ठीक है? अब यहां
पे जो हमारा पोटेंशियल डेटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन है यहां पे तो यहां पे
व्हिच मे इंडिकेट डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन टू
अनयूजुअल ट्रस्टेड लोकेशन। तो अब यहां पे
कमेंट्स में हमें बताना पड़ेगा। बेसिकली
हमें क्या बताना पड़ेगा? डिस्क्रिप्शन देख
के। हमें क्या बताना पड़ेगा? डिस्क्रिप्शन
देख के। देखो किस तरीके से? अब यहां पे आ
रहा है दिस रूल डिटेक्ट्स फाइव और मोर
गीगाबाइट्स ऑफ़ डेटा सेंट फ्रॉम अ सिंगल
डिवाइस टू अ सिंगल डेस्टिनेशन विद इन अ
डे। व्हिच मे इंडिकेट डेटा एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन टू अनट्रस्टेड लोकेशन। अब जब
इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आओगे, जब इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में ठीक है? जब यहां पे
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आओगे तो यहां पे आपको
पता चलेगा कि सोर्स आईपी जो जहां से आई थी
बेसिकली सोर्स नेटवर्क आपको यहां पे पता
चल पता चल गया। अब डेटा सेंट यहां पे आ
रही है। डेटा वो आ रही है। तो अब ये जो
चीजें आ रही हैं ये हमें यहां पे
डिस्क्रिप्शन में मेंशन जैसे कि यहां पे
चीजें दी है ना कि यहां पे देखो योर
डिसीजन हैज़ हियर डिटरमाइंड वेदर यू फाउंड
और मिस द पोटेंशियल साइबर अटैक। सम एक्शंस
लाइक एस्केलेशन और कमेंटिंग विल बी
एक्सप्लेंड इन द फॉलोइंग रूम्स। ठीक है?
सो डोंट वरी इफ दे साउंड कॉम्प्लेक्स राइट
नाउ। फर्स्ट डिसाइड इफ द अलर्ट यू
इन्वेस्टिगेट इट इज़ मैलिसियस। ट्रू
पॉजिटिव देन प्रिपेयर योर डिटेल कमेंट
एक्सप्लेनिंग योर एन एनालिसिस स्टेप्स एंड
वर्डिक्ट रीज़निंग रिटर्न टू द डैशबोर्ड
एंड मूव इट टू द क्लोज स्टेटस सिंपल सा
वर्ड अभी क्या है? इफ यू डिड नॉट सी अ
फ्लैग राइट आफ्टर राइट मींस दैट द वैल्यूज़
यू सेट अलोंग यू कैन रिसेट द एंड
रिस्टार्ट ऑन द अब यहां पे हमें एक वर्डिक
लिखनी है। ठीक है? तो हमें यहां पे एक
वर्डिक लिख देते हैं। यहां पे हमने यहां
पे एक वर्डिक पोटेंशियल डेटा
एक्सिल्ट्रेशन। तो हमने एक वर्डिक क्या
लिखना है कि क्रिटिकल है। अब यहां पे हमें
क्लोज़ कर देना है। वर्डिक्ट क्या यहां पे
लिख देते हैं कि अलर्ट
क्रिटिकल
अ डिस्क्रिप्शन के अकॉर्डिंग वर्डिक
लिखेंगे। हमारा जो डिस्क्रिप्शन है इसके
अकॉर्डिंग इसके अकॉर्डिंग ही हम वर्डिक
लिखेंगे। ठीक है?
ये क्लोज कर दिया क्या मैंने? नहीं नहीं
क्लोज नहीं हुआ है।
ठीक है? अब यहां पे वर्डिक क्या लिखेंगे?
देखो अभी देखो।
5 और मोर GB 5 और मोर GB डाटा
वाज बीइंग डाटा वाज़ बीइंग सेंट फ्रॉम अ
सिंगल डिवाइस टू अ सिंगल डेस्टिनेशन विद
इन अ डे।
तो यहां पे हम लिख देते हैं विद इन अ डे
डे एंड डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन टू अनट्रस्टेड
लोकेशन वाज़ हैपनिंग। ठीक है? सिंपल सा चीज
यहां पर कर दिया हैपनिंग।
अब यहां पर हमें सोर्स एड्रेस ये मेंशन
करना है। इसको मैं सोर्स एड्रेस को मेंशन
कर देता हूं। यहां पे ये सोर्स एड्रेस है।
अ इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं। इसको मैं यहां
पे पेस्ट कर देता हूं। एंड इसको मैं सोर्स
आईपी कॉपी। सोर्स आईपी जो है
एंड सोर्स यह दोनों कॉपी कर लेते हैं। एंड
यहां पे लिख देते हैं।
ठीक है? मीटिंग रूम सेंड डाटा 5.8 GB
रिसीव्ड डाटा 5.2GB है। ठीक है? दिस रूल
डिटेक्ट फाइव मोर सिंगल डे व्हिच व्हिच मे
इंडिकेट डेटा एक्स ऑन ट्रस्टेड लोकेशन
क्रिटिकल है यहां पे। अब यहां पे फिर से
वो चीज डालते हैं।
यहां मैं डाल देता हूं।
एंड यहां पे मैं इसको डाल देता हूं। एंड
इसको डालते हैं। यहां पे फाइव और मोर GB
ऑफ़ डेटा वाज़ बीइंग सेंट फ्रॉम सेंट अ
फ्रॉम अ सिंगल डिवाइस टू अ सिंगल
डेस्टिनेशन अ
I आईपी।
यह आईपी डाल देते हैं। सिंगल डेस्टिनेशन
आईपी दिस विद इन अ डे। ठीक है? विद इन अ
डे सिंगल डेस्टिनेशन
द सिंगल डिवाइस टू अ सिंगल डेस्टिनेशन
ज़ूम डॉट ईएस विथ अ
IP 19 विद इन अ डे एंड डेटा एक्सप्लशन इन
टू अनट्रस्टेड लोकेशन वाज़ हैपनिंग। ठीक
है?
एज एज एसओसी
एल1 आई इन्वेस्टिगेटेड
एंड फाउंड
एंड
फाउंड इट ट्रू पॉजिटिव
ट्रू पॉजिटिव
एंड स्टॉप्ड द। अब यहां पे क्या हो रहा है
गाइस? एग्जैक्टली क्या हो रहा है कि ये
पोटेंशियल डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन हो रही है।
तो ठीक है? पोटेंशियल डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
को रोकना है हमें। तो हमने क्या किया है?
एक पर्टिकुलर डेटा साइज हमने क्या किया?
एक आईपी को वो पर्टिकुलर एक आईपी को जा
रही है। एंड फाउंड इट ट्रू पॉजिटिव एंड
स्टॉप्ड
द डेटा
द कम्युनिकेशन
एंड ब्लॉक्ड द आईपी एंड ब्लॉक्ड द आईपी।
बस दैट्स इट। ये चीज हम कर दिया। अब हम
यहां पे हमने एक चीज़ सेटअप कर दी है। हमने
एक चीज़ मेंशन किया यहां पे ब्लॉक आईपी ऐसे
करके। अब इसमें हम ऐसे करके अब इसको हम
क्लोज़ अगर करते हैं यहां पे क्रिटिकल एल
ट्रू कॉल और यहां पे सेव करते हैं। लेट्स
सी देयर इज़ समथिंग हैपेनिंग
ट्रू पॉजिटिव। कुछ हो क्यों नहीं रहा है?
ये आ क्यों नहीं रहा है? अलर्ट तो आ जाता
है वैसे तो।
व्हाट इट फॉल्स पॉजिटिव? कैसे? अच्छा।
अच्छा अच्छा एक सेकंड एक सेकंड एक सेकंड
एक सेकंड रुको रुको इट्स अ क्रिटिकल ठीक
है अ
कमेंट में तो कुछ भी हो जाएगा लेकिन यहां
पे वर्डिक्ट में फॉल्स पॉजिटिव हम लिख
सकते हैं क्या लेट्स सी इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन
को एक बार पढ़ लेते हैं एक बार अच्छे से
दिस रूल डिटेक्ट फाइव और मोर गीगाबाइट्स
ऑफ़ डेटा सेंट फ्रॉम अ सिंगल डिवाइस टू
अच्छा अच्छा अच्छा अच्छा अच्छा
सिंगल डेस्टिनेशन विद इन अ डे व्हिच मे
इंडिकेट डेटा एक्सप्रेशन टू अनट्रस्टेड
लोकेशन तो डेस्टिनेशन है zूम डॉट इव एस
सोर्स आईपी है ये सोर्स नेटवर्क है हमारा
मीटिंग रूम एंड अच्छा ये ज़ूम यूएस पे ओके
ओके ओके सो गाइज़ देखो यहां पे एक चीज है
यहां पे कैच है जो चीज हम कैच नहीं कर पा
रहे थे यहां पे बेसिकली दिस इज़ नॉट अ ट्रू
पॉजिटिव थिंग ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव नहीं है ये
बेसिकली क्या है zूम डॉट यूएस पे जा रही
है यानी कि एक मीटिंग चल रही है देयर इज़ अ
मीटिंग तो मीटिंग में वो डाटा फ्लोरिस हो
रही है मीटिंग में वो डाटा जा रही
ठीक है? अब वो मीटिंग में डेटा जब जा रही
है तो वो तो डेटा की साइज कुछ भी हो सकती
है ना। लाइक मीटिंग चल रही है, लाइव
मीटिंग चल रही है तो इट कैन यूटिलाइज़ मोर
डेटा अ लॉट ऑफ़ डेटा। राइट? तो अब यहां पे
पर्टिकुलरली ये जो डोमेन है ये तो हम
मीटिंग कर ही रहे हैं यार। तो बट ये
मीटिंग जब हो रही है तो ये तो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है ना। सिंपल सा चीज़ है। तो यहां
पे हमारे पास मान लो प्रोग्रेस करके यहां
पे वर्डिक्ट में हम फॉल्स पॉजिटिव लिख
देते हैं। क्रिटिकल एंड असाइन को सेल्फ कर
देते हैं। अ इट वाज़ अ फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव अ लॉट। ऐसा लिख दिया हमने कुछ भी
लिख दिया। एंड दैट्स इट। अब यहां पे हम
करेंगे सेव करेंगे। एंड यहां पे इसको
क्लोज कर देंगे। पहले प्रोग्रेस किया। अब
यहां पे क्लोज करके एंड इसको सेव कर
देंगे। जैसे ही क्लोज करके सेव करेंगे
हमारे पास जो है अ
कॉपी करके यहां पर एंड यहां पर फ्लैग दे
देंगे क्योंकि यहां पर यह बेसिकली एक
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव था क्योंकि हम ज़ूम को ध्यान
में दे नहीं रहे थे। ज़ूम को हम ध्यान में
नहीं ले रहे थे। इट वाज़ कि ये ज़ूम वीडियो
कॉल चल रही है। ज़ूम मीटिंग चल रही है। सो
हम उसको ट्रू पॉजिटिव बना रहे थे क्योंकि
हम इसको बस डिस्क्रिप्शन पे ध्यान दे रहे
थे। तो जब भी कोई अलर्ट आती है तो एव्री
पैरामीटर इज़ेंट। इससे ये पता आपको चल रहा
होगा कि एव्री पैरामीटर छोटे-छोटे
पैरामीटर पे आपको ध्यान देना है। दैट्स
इट। छोटे-छोटे पैरामीटर पे ध्यान देंगे तो
हमें फ्लैग या हमें जो भी हमारा सॉल्यूशन
है वो मिल जाएगा। अब अगर मैं अगर मैं अभी
यहां पे ज़ूम पे ध्यान नहीं देता तो अभी
समझ में ये चीज नहीं आती कि जब डेटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन हो रही है तो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव क्यों यहां पे हमें हमसे ये मांग
रहा है। तो क्योंकि डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
हो रही है जो भी हो रही है डेटा जा रही है
भाई एक ज़ूम यूएस एक मीटिंग के लिए जा रही
है। तो मीटिंग में तो डेटा होता है
एक्सप्लेरेट करता ही करता है। राइट? सो इट
वाज़ लाइक दैट। तो हमें यहां पे फ्लैग मिल
गई। चलो इसका तो हमें हो गया। अब यहां पे
आते हैं व्हिच फ्लैग डिड यू रिसीव आफ्टर
यू करेक्टली ट्रैक द सेकंड अ प्रायोरिटी
अलर्ट। सेकंड प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट हमारा कौन
सा है? क्रिटिकल के बाद हमारा हाई वाला
है। अब इसको हम करेक्टली ट्रैक करते हैं।
डबल एक्सटेंशन फाइल क्रिएशन। डबल
एक्सटेंशन। अब इसको एक्सटेंड करते हैं।
डबल एक्सटेंशन में क्या है? दिस रूल
डिटेक्ट्स अ क्रिएशन ऑफ़ डबल एक्सटेंशन
फाइल लाइक pdf.exe.f
डॉट लिंक। ऑफेन यूज़्ड बाय हैकर्स इन
फिशिंग अटैक्स ट्रिक यूज़र्स इंटू ओपनिंग अ
मलिशियस एग्जीक्यूटेबल। ठीक है? ये सिंपल।
अब इसमें है एक होस्ट है एलपीटीए प्रोसेस
नेम है chrome exc प्रोसेस यूजर है c डॉट
कॉन्व हम टारगेट फाइल है cov डाउनलोड्स
cash mmp4exee फाइल है एमot जो है फ्री
कैट वीडियोस host ठीक है एंड फाइल md5 ही
है हां तो ये तो आपका मतलब ये आपका ट्रू
है मतलब दिस इज़ ट्रू क्योंकि ऑब्वियस सी
बात है यहां पे जो Chrome डॉट प्रोसेस का
नाम Chrome exc है द प्रोसेस नेम इज़ द
रियल नेम Chrome.exec बट यहां पे प्रोसेस
यूजर एक एस कॉन्व कॉन्व जो है अब टारगेट
फाइल ये क्या कर रहा है? एक mp4 ये टारगेट
फाइल कहां पे डाल रहा है? उस यूजर के
डाउनलोड्स में एक फाइल है कैट्स 2024
25.4.exe
सो दिस इज़ द ट्रू पॉजिटिव। ऐसे ट्रू
पॉजिटिव क्यों होगा? क्योंकि यहां पे
हमारा मेन प्रोसेस Chrome.exe है। बट इट
इज़ बीइंग टारगेटेड अगेंस्ट अ फेक अ
मलिशियस फाइल जो कि ओरिजिनल Chrome का
फाइल या Chrome एसोसिएटेड फाइल नहीं है।
तो ये एक फेक मलिशियस फाइल को टारगेट किया
जा रहा है। दैट्स इट। तो हमारा यहां पे ये
ट्रू पॉजिटिव होना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से।
तो एक काम करते हैं। अ वर्डिक में ट्रू
पॉजिटिव करते हैं। अह सीवियरिटी इज़ हाई।
असाइन तो खुद को कर ही लेंगे और स्टेटस
क्लोज पे कर देते हैं। अ यहां पे लिख देते
हैं। इट्स अ इट्स अ ट्रू पॉजिटिव
अ लॉट। कुछ भी लिख दिया कुछ भी करके सेव
कर देते हैं। दैट्स सी हां ये ट्रू
पॉजिटिव था क्योंकि ऑब्वियस सी बात है
यहां पे ये फाइल सस्िशियस फाइल यहां पे
थी। तो यहां पे हमारा ट्रू पॉजिटिव जो है
फ्लैग ये आ गया। अच्छा कुछ लोगों ने कुछ
लोग पहले से बोल रहे हैं। कुछ लोगों ने
ट्राईगमी पहले से सॉल्व कर लिया है। तभी
वो पहले से एकदम तुरंत अभी लैब अभी अभी आ
ही नहीं रहा तब तक वो बता दे रहे हैं कि
ऐसा ऐसा होगा। इसका मतलब है पहले से पहले
से सॉल्व करके बैठे हुए हैं कुछ लोग। चलिए
अच्छी बात है। अगर आप पहले से सॉल्व करके
भी हैं तो इट्स गुड। इट्स गुड।
इट्स ट्रू।
हां हां हां हां भाई हां हां हां बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल सही बात है। इट्स बिल्कुल करेक्ट
कि सीवियरिटी क्रिटिकल हो या हाई हो उससे
मतलब नहीं है। इसका मतलब ये नहीं है कि वो
आपका रियल इंसिडेंट हो जाएगा। इट डजंट
मीन।
ठीक है?
इट डजंट मीन राइट? कि अगर आपका सीवियरिटी
अ बहुत ज्यादा एक क्रिटिकल है या हाई में
भी आ रहा है तो इसका मतलब ये नहीं है कि
वो ट्रू पॉजिटिव ही होगा और सीवियरिटी लो
है तो इसका मतलब ये नहीं है कि फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव ही होगा। डिपेंड करता है कि किस
टाइप का सिचुएशन है। क्या डिस्क्रिप्शन
है? क्या पूरा का पूरा आपको पढ़ना है वो
डिस्क्रिप्शन। किस तरह का सिचुएशन है? वो
पढ़ना है। तब जाके आप उसको सॉल्व करेंगे।
ठीक है? दैट्स इट। लव यू फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर। वि फ्लैग डिड यू रिसीव आफ्टर यू
करेक्टली ट्रैक द थर्ड प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट?
थर्ड प्रायोरिटी अलर्ट कौन है भाई?
क्रिटिकल हो गए। हाई हो गया भाई हमारा।
अच्छा ये लो वाला है। डाउनलोड फ्रॉम गीब
रिपॉजिटरी। हैं लो वाला है। अरे कोई
डाउनलोड फ्रॉम गीब रिपोजिटरी। इसका क्या
है भैया?
दिस रूल डिटेक्ट्स एनी डाउनलोड फ्रॉम गीब।
व्हाइल GH स्टोर्स लॉट्स ऑफ़ ग्रेट
प्रोजेक्ट्स दैट आवर आईटी टीम यूसेस। इट
आल्सो स्टोर्स मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड
एक्सप्लइट्स दैट मस्ट नॉट बी डाउनलोडेड
बाय यूज़र्स। तो GitHub Facebook रिएक्ट सी
चैंडलर
सोर्स होस्ट जो है LPT आईटी 063 है। सोर्स
नेटवर्क जो है वीपीए डेवलपर्स हैं। हां
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब बताइए
सोर्स नेटवर्क है वीpए डेवलपर। ये सोर्स
सुनो सुनो। सोर्स नेटवर्क है वीpए डेवलपर।
सोर्स होस्ट है एलपीटी आईटी। ठीक है?
चलेगा। अब यहां पे एक एक्सेस यूआरएल है।
gh.com Facebook रिएक्ट एंड सी चैंडल का।
अब मुझे ये बताइए आप जस्ट इमेजिन कीजिए कि
इसको ट्रू पॉज देखो जो लैब ऑलरेडी बना
चुका है वो मत बोले वो नहीं बोलेगा। जो
जिन्होंने नहीं बनाया है वो बताएं। प्लीज
जिन्होंने लैब ऑलरेडी सॉल्व किया मत बताओ
यार। फिर बाकी लोग को बाकी लोगों को आंसर
मिल रहा है ना? सो प्लीज प्लीज डोंट टेल।
ठीक है? तो जो न्यू यूजर है प्लीज बताइए
कि इसमें कौन सा ऑप्शन हमें चूज़ करना
चाहिए? बताइए। कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं ट्रू
पॉजिटिव। कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव।
बस बस हो गया यार आदेश। जस्ट 2 मिनट्स।
बताइए कौन सा चूज़ करना चाहिए? जल्दी बताइए
यार। न्यू यूज़र्स हैं बस वही बताएंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बताइए।
कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। कुछ
लोग बोल रहे हैं ट्रू पॉजिटिव। फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव, ट्रू पॉजिटिव, ट्रू पॉजिटिव, अ
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव।
देखो, मैक्सिमम लोगों का फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव आंसर है। इसका रीज़ कोई
बता सकता है तो बताइए।
बताइए।
बताइए इसका आंसर। कोई अगर रीजन है तो
बताइए फॉल्स पॉजिटिव का और अगर ट्रू
पॉजिटिव है तो उसका भी रीजन बताइए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बनाइए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो इस गिट रपोजिटरी को कॉपी करेंगे एंड
यहां पे हम इसको ओपन कर लेंगे। इस गीब
रेपोजिटरी को हम कॉपी करेंगे। ओपन करेंगे।
जब हम इसको ओपन करेंगे तो यू विल सी कि
देयर इज़ अ गटब रेपोजिटरी एक्चुअली
प्रेजेंट हियर। ये मेलिसियस रेपोजिटरी
नहीं है। इट्स नॉट अ मेलिसियस रेपोजिटरी।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो इसको डाउनलोड किया
जा सकता है। इट कैन बी डाउनलोडेड। यह कोई
मलेशियस रेपोजिटरी थोड़ी ना है भाई। है ना?
तो इसको हम ट्रू पॉजिटिव में डाल देंगे।
एज सिंपल एज दैट। ये ऑलरेडी एक एग्ज़िस्ट
करता है ये हमारा। राइट? समझ में आ रहा है
आपको?
गॉट इट? कि ये मलिशस रेपोजिटरी नहीं है।
तो इसको हमें करना है ट्रू पॉजिटिव ही
करना पड़ेगा। राइट? आई थिंक यू गॉट इट?
राइट?
सभी को समझ में आ गया यह चीज अभी करके
देखते हैं एक बार लेट्स सी फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
वालों को ज्यादा खुश नहीं करना चाहता हूं
मैं तो यहां पे ट्रू पॉजिटिव असाइनिंग खुद
का लो तो लो है ठीक है स्टेटस में क्लोज्ड
इट्स
करेक्ट कुछ भी लिख दो मतलब ऐसा सेव करते
हैं
कौन सा कर दिया भाई
कहां क्या
कुछ गलत कर दिया क्या? कुछ गलत कर दिया
क्या? ओके जस्ट अ सेकंड।
ओके। अच्छा ओके आप लोग आप लोग आप लोग यहां
पे बताइए क्यों ये गलत क्यों है? तब आ
गया। मैं 2 मिनट में आ रहा हूं। बताइए आप
लोग।
हां जी तो आंसर क्या है आप लोगों का बताइए
अगर मैं अगर मैं बोलूंगा मैं बोलूंगा कि
कुएं में कूद जाना है तो कुएं में कूद
जाएंगे आप ये ये बताइए
बताइए मैं बोलूंगा कुएं में कूद जाए तो
कुएं में कूद जाएंगे आप
बता
अरे ये ये तो देखो नहीं देखो मैं आपको
बताता हूं जैसे हम इस अ पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल
पे आए हैं। हम यहां पे एक रिएक्ट उस पे आए
हुए हैं। अ रेपोजिटरी पे आए हुए हैं। राइट
वी हैव कम ऑन द रिएक्ट रेपोजिटरी। तो अब
यहां पे हां बताओ बताओ बताओ। इसलिए फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव हो। वाह क्या लॉजिक दिया है मतलब
क्या क्या लॉजिक दिया है मतलब? वाओ क्या
व्हाट अ लॉजिक?
अरे यार एक बात बताओ ट्रू मशियस नहीं है
फिर भी टूल ने मलेशियस समझ के डिटेक्ट
किया है ट्रू मलेशियस नहीं है फिर भी टूल
ने मलिशियस समझ के डिटेक्ट किया है राइट
तो फिर उसको भी तो आप ट्रू पॉजिटिव नहीं
बोल सकते ना उसको भी तो ट्रू पॉजिटिव नहीं
बोल सकते
उसको भी तो ट्रू पॉजिटिव नहीं बोल सकते यह
भी तो सोचो जरा सा
मतलब
[हंसी]
नहीं नहीं नहीं देखो यहां पे एक चीज है
यहां पे एक लॉजिक है लॉजिक अच्छा लॉजिक
किसी को अभी आई थिंक समझ नहीं आया
लॉजिक नहीं समझ में आया मुझे लगता है किसी
को किसी को लॉजिक यहां पे पता है इसका
मुझे नहीं लगता है नहीं आपको लॉजिक नहीं
पता है
लॉजिक इज नॉट अ
करेक्ट ऑफ योर्स
आप में से किसी का लॉजिक सही नहीं है।
बताइए अब मुझे बताइए। इवन जो लोगों ने
अच्छा आप लोगों में से बहुत लोगों ने
ट्राईक का लैब ऑलरेडी सॉल्व किया है। आपका
भी लॉजिक सही नहीं है। आप एक्सैक्ट
एग्जैक्ट लॉजिक बता दीजिए कोई। कोई बोल
रहा है डेवलपर
कोई फाइल नहीं डाउनलोड किया है।
कोई अ फाइल नहीं डाउनलोड हुआ है। डेवलपर
है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव बिकॉज़ डेवलपर यूजुअली
डाउनलोड फ्रॉम GitHub आल्सो इट इज़
ट्रस्टेड डोमेन विथ रेपो। तो यह फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है। यह क्या बोल रहे हो? डेवलपर
है इसलिए फॉल्स। फॉल्स कैसे है? पहले यह
तो बताओ।
फॉल्स इसलिए है? फॉल्स पॉजिटिव इसलिए है
क्योंकि बिकॉज़ डेवलपर्स यूज़ली डाउनलोड
फ्रॉम GitHub आल्सो इट इज़ अ ट्रस्टेड
डोमेन विथ रेपो। ये इनका कहना है। देखो
यहां पे अब मैं आपको बता देता हूं यहां
पे। देखो यहां पे यहां पे इसका कोई लॉजिक
नहीं है। सिंपल सा फंडा है। यहां पे कोई
लॉजिक नहीं है आपका। डिस्क्रिप्शन में
यहां पे सिंपल सा लिखा हुआ है। दिस रूल
डिटेक्ट्स एनी डाउनलोड फ्रॉम GH। किसी भी
तरह के गीब का डाउनलोड जो है उसके लिए रूल
है। Ghub स्टोर्स लॉट्स ऑफ ग्रेट
प्रोजेक्ट्स दैट आर आईटी टीम यूजसेस जो
हमारी यूज़ कर रही है आईटी टीम। ठीक है? अब
यहां ध्यान रखिएगा आईटी टीम यूज़ कर रही
है। इट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आल्सो
स्टोर्स मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड
एक्सप्लइट्स दैट मस्ट नॉट बी डाउनलोडेड
बाय द बाय द यूज़र्स। बाय द यूज़र्स। यूज़र्स
के द्वारा डाउनलोड नहीं किए जाने चाहिए।
राइट? समझ में आया आपको? समझ में आ रहा है
कुछ? यूज़र्स के द्वारा डाउनलोड। यहां पे
क्या लिख रहा है? लॉट्स ग्रेट प्रोजेक्ट्स
दैट आर आईटी टीम यूसेज। आईटी टीम यूज़ करती
है। बहुत सारे ऐसे गेट के जो हैं
प्रोजेक्ट्स हैं इनके जो आईटी टीम यूज़ कर
रही है।
राइट? बट इट आल्सो इन इट आल्सो स्टोर्स
मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड एक्सप्लइट्स दैट
मस्ट नॉट बी डाउनलोडेड बाय द यूज़र्स। बट
यूज़र्स के द्वारा मलेशियस जो एक्सप्लइट्स
हैं जो जो भी लाइक स्क्रिप्ट्स हैं वो
डाउनलोड नहीं होने चाहिए।
अब उसके बाद जो है आपका यहां क्या आ रहा
है?
ये प्रोफाइल है। सोर्स यूजर कौन सा है? जी
चंद जी चैंडलर। यह हमारा सोर्स यूजर है।
सोर्स का होस्ट क्या है? एलपीटी आईटी 063
यह आईटी टीम का बंदा है। दिस इज एन आई
आईटी टीम पर्सन। नेटवर्क क्या है? वीपीए
डेवलपर्स। एंड कमेंट जो हमने किया है वह
तो कुछ भी कर सकते हैं आप। अब यहां पे
क्योंकि ये एक ऐसी यूआरएल है उसको एक्सेस
किया गया है बाय अ यूजर।
बाय अ यूजर।
तो इसको आप सही कैसे बोलोगे? अकॉर्डिंग टू
द डिस्क्रिप्शन हाउ इट हाउ यू विल से इट अ
करेक्ट और ट्रू पॉजिटिव अकॉर्डिंग टू द
डिस्क्रिप्शन। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
इसका लॉजिक तो समझ में आना चाहिए। अब मान
लो आपने सॉल्व कर लिया होगा। कई लोग आप
लोगों में से ऐसे भी हैं जो गीट पे जाए जो
ये लैब सॉल्व करके एक बार ट्रू पॉजिटिव एक
बार फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। जब फॉल्स पॉजिटिव में
सही हो गया फिर वो बोलेंगे कि हां सही हो
गया। ऐसा भी होता है कि हां भाई फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव सही है सही है। उनको कुछ लॉजिक भी
उस समय समझ में आ गया होगा कि हां लॉजिक
ऐसी है ये है लॉजिक ये भी समझ में आ गया
होगा। बट यहां पे आप इस चीज को लॉजिक को
समझना जरूरी है कि यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन के
अकॉर्डिंग आपको काम करना है और उसके बाद
जो एक्सेस यूआरएल यहां देख रहे हैं ये ये
यूआरएल एक्सेस की गई है बाय हुम बाय सोर्स
यूजर जी चैंडलर
और ये हमारे जो है जी चैंडलर जी इन्होंने
एक्सेस किया है। सो हाउ इट कैन बी ट्रू
पॉजिटिव।
यह बोल तो रहा है यहां पर कि गेट
प्रोजेक्ट्स क्यों किए जा रहे हैं बट
मैिशियस स्क्रिप्ट्स भी हो सकते हैं,
एक्सप्लइट्स भी हो सकते हैं। तो कोई यूजर
के तरफ से इसको डाउनलोड नहीं होना चाहिए।
सो दैट्स इट सिंपल। तो यहां पे जब मैं
इसको रिस्ट करूंगा। आपको समझ में आया किसी
को कि नहीं समझ में आया?
आपको समझ में आया कि नहीं आया?
क्या समझ में आया बताइए जरा मुझे नहीं लग
रहा समझ में आया बट ठीक है बता दीजिए क्या
समझ में आया बताइए क्या समझ में आया आपको
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कोई बताओ यार जब इतने लोग यस सर यस सर बोल
रहे हैं ना मुझे बताओ क्या समझ में आ गया
तभी मैं इसको आगे आगे प्रोसीड करूंगा।
नहीं तो फिर समझ नहीं आएगा तो मजा नहीं
आएगा। अब मैंने अगर ट्रू पॉजिटिव लगा दिया
तो तुम ट्रू पॉजिटिव हो गए। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
लगा दो तो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव हो गए।
करेक्ट। करेक्ट। बिल्कुल सही बोला।
करेक्ट। यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन में ही लिखा
हुआ है यार। सिंपल है यार। कैसे मैं बताऊं
यार? यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन में ही लिखा हुआ
है। यह जो रूल है यह डाउनलोड फ्रॉम Gh
रपोज़िटरी यह जो रूल है यह डिटेक्ट करता है
किसी भी तरह का डाउनलोड GH से सिंपल
डाउनलोड डिटेक्ट करता है ना इसने क्या
किया है एक्सेस किया है ये यूआरएल दिस
यूआरएल हैज़ बीन एक्सेस्ड
एंड डाउनलोड अगर कोई मलिशियस स्क्रिप्ट या
एक्सप्लइट भी होती है उसको भी डिटेक्ट
करता है क्योंकि वो भी कंटेन होती है इसने
एक्सेस किया है ये चीज़ यार तो ये ट्रू
पॉजिटिव कैसे होगी कहां कहां कहां मतलब
क्या डाउनलोड हो रहा है व्हाट इज गेट
गेटिंग डाउनलोडेड
मुझे बताइए ना
यस यस सिंपल सिंपल कि ये एक नॉर्मल सा
बंदा जो है इसको एक्सेस कर रहा है। एक
नॉर्मल सा कंपनी का बंदा एक्सेस कर रहा
है। बस यही तो डिटेक्ट हुआ है। तो इसमें
यहां पे किसी तरह का एक नॉर्मल सी एक लो
सीवियरिटी की ये बग है तो ठीक है चलेगा।
सही है ये बिल्कुल सही है। राइट? तो इसमें
कुछ ऐसा तो नहीं आ रहा कि हां भैया कि हम
इसको बना दें कि हां ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव ही
है। नॉर्मल सा बंदा है। वो कर दिया। तो ये
फॉल्स मतलब कि सही या गलत है। तो भाई यहां
पे जो ये जो चीजें डाउनलोड करने वाली चीज
है उसको डिटेक्शन में आ रही है तो ऑब्वियस
सी बात है ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव में आ जाएगा।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है सिंपल सा फंडा है कि ये
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव में आ जाएगा कि ये एक्चुअल
चीज नहीं है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव का मतलब ये
नहीं मत समझना कि गलत है भाई।
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव का मतलब मत समझना कि गलत
है। फॉल्स मोटिव यह गलत एक इंडिकेटर है।
एक गलत सी इंडिकेटर आ चुका है कि भ एक
डिटेक्शन जो आई है ना ये गलत डिटेक्शन आई
है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव का मतलब ये होता है कि
ये जो डिटेक्शन ये गलत है। इसने नॉर्मल
एक्सेस किया है। सही है। सही किया है
एक्सेस। बिल्कुल सही किया है।
यही चीज़ मैंने पहले जब आपको डाला था ट्रू
पॉजिटिव। सो ये चीज ही तो देखना था कि आप
एग्जजेक्टली
क्या उस पे आपका क्या रिस्पांस है उस पे
मतलब आप क्या सोच रहे हो क्या समझ रहे हो
इस पे तो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव ये तो है ही फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव ना सही तो किया एक्सेस बिल्कुल
सही नॉर्मल सा आदमी है टीम का आदमी है
आईटी का बंदा है उसने एक नॉर्मल एक सही
रेपोजिटरी को एक्सेस कर लिया बिल्कुल सही
है
अब तो समझ में आ गया होगा ना कि अब यहां
पे ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव क्यों हो रहा है
स्टेटस को मान लो अगर तुम क्लोज भी कर दो।
यहां पे कुछ भी टाइप कर दो। व्हाटएवर यहां
पे सेव कर दो। तो ये अब तो आ जाएगा। लेकिन
ये अब आपको समझ में आ रहा है ये क्यों हो
रहा है ऐसा?
आर यू गेटिंग?
मेन मुद्दा है कांसेप्ट को समझाना। मेन
मुद्दा है
कांसेप्ट को समझाना।
बाकी चीजें नहीं। ऐसे लैब्स तो आप में से
मुझे पता है बहुत लोग पहले भी सॉल्व कर
चुके हैं। आप अभी भी सॉल्व कर लेंगे।
इनफैक्ट आप लोगों में से हो सकता है बहुत
लोगों ने मुझसे बहुत ज्यादा लैब सॉल्व किए
होंगे ट्राई एककm के क्योंकि आप लोगों में
से बहुत लोग करते रहते हैं। ठीक है? तो आप
लैब सॉल्व कर सकते हैं। बट वो कांसेप्ट
कहां से लाएंगे?
बात ये भी है ना ये भी तो समझने वाली बात
है। वो कांसेप्ट तो लाना समझना पड़ेगा कि
क्यों हुआ फॉल्स पॉजिटिव? क्योंकि फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव का मतलब है ये एक गलत इंडिकेटर
है। ये एक गलत अलर्ट है। ये जो लो का भी
अलर्ट है ना ये गलत है। क्योंकि ऐसी कोई
चीज डाउनलोड तो हुई नहीं है यार स्क्रिप्ट
या कुछ ऐसा तो डाउनलोड नहीं बस एक्सेस कर
रहा है वो बंदा तो ठीक तो एक्सेस कर रहा
है। सही रेपोज़िटरी एक्सेस कर रहा है। अगर
वो उसी ने गलत रेपोज़िटरी एक्सेस कर लिया
होता इसके जगह पे ये Facebook रिएक्ट वाली
रेपोज़िटरी ना हो के कोई मलिशियस रेपोज़िटरी
होती तो ये हो जाता फिर ट्रू पॉजिटिव।
देन दिस वुड हैव बीन अ ट्रू पॉजिटिव।
हां बिल्कुल सही है। बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल
सही। बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल परफेक्ट।
बिल्कुल सही। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[हंसी]
हां बिल्कुल रोहित रोहित राज बिल्कुल सही
बोला था आपने। बिल्कुल सही।
थैंक यू आदि। थैंक यू रोहित। अच्छा आपने
अच्छा जवाब दिया था रोहित। पहले ही आपने
दिया था। नहीं आप में से कुछ लोगों ने तो
बिल्कुल सही बोला था। रोहित आदि ये सब
लोगों ने सही बोला था। बट एग्जैक्टली मेरा
मेन मोटिव उनको बताना समझाना नहीं है जो
ऑलरेडी जानते हैं। इसलिए मैं ज्यादा मतलब
फोकस नहीं कर रहा था। बट यहां पे अगर मैं
आपको अब मान लो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव पे भी नहीं
मिलती फ्लैग तब तो तुम ये भी सोच में पड़
जाते ऐसा क्यों हुआ? हो सकता था पॉसिबल
है। तो उसके भी पीछे का रीज़न जानना
पड़ेगा।
तो जब ऐसी चीजें होंगी जब रूम होम और
सीटीएफ वगैरह होंगे तो मेरे भरोसे मत
रहना। मैं अगर कुछ कर रहा हूं इसका मतलब
यह नहीं कि वह सही होगा। तुम अपना जो अंदर
का एक वो है ना पॉइंट वो रखा करो कि नहीं
सर ये होगा। सर वो सर गलत है सर वो होगा।
तब तो समझ में आया कि आपको समझ में भी आ
रहा है। नहीं तो फिर क्या ही आप फिर तो
मुझे वही लगेगा कि मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
और वही चीज आप समझ के और वही गलत हो सही
हो उससे मतलब नहीं है। बस हो गया खत्म
कहानी। ऐसा नहीं है।
ठीक है? तो बस यहां से सिंपल यहां पर फाइल
अरे तो फाइल डाउनलोड भी हुआ हो ना? एक
जस्ट एक बंदा बोला है फाइल डाउनलोड हुआ
है। चलो फाइल डाउनलोड हुआ है। मैं मान
गया। मैं [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मान
गया फाइल डाउनलोड हुआ है। तो फाइल डाउनलोड
भी हुआ है। तो ये उसी का तो अलर्ट है ही।
डाउनलोड फ्रॉम गीट अप रिपोजिटरी। ये अलर्ट
ही उसी का है। बट इस बंदे ने करेक्ट
रिपोजिटरी को ही तो खोला है। और वहीं से
तो फाइल डाउनलोड मान लो फाइल डाउनलोड। अरे
यार मैंने मैंने मैंने बोला कि चलो मान लो
फाइल डाउनलोड भी किया तो करेक्ट रिपॉजिटरी
से ही फाइल डाउनलोड किया और ये उसी का
अलर्ट है तो इसने अलर्ट दे दिया लो
सीवियरिटी का कि एक फाइल डाउनलोड हुई है
बट क्योंकि ये करेक्ट रिपोजिटरी है तो
बिल्कुल सही क्या दिक्कत है डाउनलोड की है
हो गई है तो इसको फॉल्स पॉजिटिव ही तो
बोलेंगे कि मतलब ये गलत इंडिकेटर है ये
इंडिकेशन ये जो अलर्ट आया है ये गलत है ये
सही अलर्ट नहीं है तो ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव हो
गया बस दैट्स इट
गॉट इट गॉट इट गाइस?
अ नॉन आईटी यूजर डाउनलोडेड कंटेंट फ्रॉम
गीट व्हिच इज अगेंस्ट द पॉलिसी
डिस्क्राइब्ड द अलर्ट करेक्टली डिटेक्ट्स
दिस एक्टिविटी। सो इट इज़ अ ट्रू पॉजिटिव।
द कंटेंट इटसेल्फ इज़ लेटमेट्स। नहीं नहीं
यार ऐसा नहीं है। ट्रू पॉजिटिव नहीं है।
आई थिंक फिर समझ फिर आई थिंक यासीन अगेन
आई थिंक यू आर गेटिंग आउट ऑफ द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट। ट्रू पॉजिटिव नहीं होगा यह
क्योंकि ट्रू पॉजिटिव का मतलब हो जाता है
कि यहां देखो ना
डिस्क्रिप्शन में है दिस रूल डिटेक्ट एनी
डाउनलोड फ्रॉम गीट किसी भी गीब को ये
डाउनलोड को डिटेक्ट करता है। ठीक है?
व्हाइल गिट स्टोर लॉट्स ऑफ़ इट आल्सो
स्टोर्स मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड
एक्सप्लइड दैट मस्ट नॉट बी डाउनलोडेड बाय
द यूज़र्स। स्क्रिप्ट मलिशियस को डाउनलोड
नहीं किया था। तो ये डिटेक्ट डाउनलोड
डिटेक्ट किया तो इसने डाउनलोड ये लिंक
एक्सेस हुआ डिटेक्ट हुई एंड दैट्स इट तो
इसका फुल मोटिव ही तो फुलफिल कर रहा है ये
अलर्ट उसने बस एक दे दिया कि हां ये हुई
ये ये चीज हुई है तो इसने मशियस डाउनलोड
नहीं हुआ है इस पर्टिकुलर चीज से कोई
मशियस स्क्रिप्ट या मशियस एक्सप्लइट
डाउनलोड नहीं हुआ है दिस स्क्रिप्ट डोंट
लीड टू अ मशियस स्क्रिप्ट और मलेशियस
एक्सप्लइट्स यहां पे मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट या
मशियस डाउनलोड्स नहीं है। तो यहां पे ये
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है क्योंकि एक जेरिक
डाउनलोड है। जेरिक एक्सेस एक्सेस है। ये
एक ट्रू मतलब एक नॉन मैलिसियस फाइल का
एक्सेस किया गया है। तो ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
है। सिंपल इट्स नॉट गेटिंग इट्स नॉट
क्रिएटिंग एनी काइंड ऑफ़ ट्रबल फॉर
एसोसिएटी।
आई थिंक अब समझ में आ गया होगा। जिन जिनका
जिन्होंने बोला था कि किसने बोला था।
आई एम फॉरगेटिंग द नेम याशीन आई थिंक मे
बी यासीन हैव गॉट दिस नाउ आई डोंट नो बट
यही चीज है
हां हां हां ऑब्वियस सी बात है ना मलिसिस
डाउनलोड नहीं हुआ है तो मलिसिस जब फाइल
डाउनलोड नहीं होगी तो दैट इज नॉट
क्रिएटिंग एनी काइंड ऑफ ट्रबल सिंपल
या
हां हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सही है सही है
ठीक है चलो आई थिंक इट्स क्लियर नाउ फ्लैग
मिला था शायद पता नहीं मुझे कॉपी किया था
कि नहीं मैंने डाल देते हैं यहां पे
[संगीत]
हां यार अब ये देखो यहां पे फ्लैग में भी
देखो ना क्या लिखा हुआ है अब फ्लैग में
देखो ना क्या लिखा हुआ है तुम्हें फ्लैग
से अब देखो अच्छा फ्लैग से क्लियर हो
जाएगा तुम्हें फ्लैग से भी क्लियर करवा
देता हूं फ्लैग में क्या है शुड वी अलाउ
गिट फॉर डेव्स डेवलपर्स के लिए गिट अलाउ
करना चाहिए तो भाई डेवलपर के लिए ही तो
गेट होता है तो भैया ये यहां पे जो
डेवलपर्स डेवलपर ही तो है जो एक्सेस कर
रहा है बेसिकली जो यूजर है जो यूजर है
डेवलपर यूजर ही है आईटी टीम का यही तो
एक्सेस कर रहा है
तो इसने कहा कुछ गलत एक्सेस इसका अगर इसी
अगर इसका एक्सेस करना भी फ्लैग हो जा रहा
है तो ये गलत है ना भाई डेवलपर एक
जेन्युइन गीटब रेपोजिटरी को एक्सेस कर रहा
है तो इसको फ्लैग थोड़ी ना करना है इसको
थोड़ी ना इसको अलर्ट दे देना है कि भैया
कुछ हो रहा है अगर डेवलपर ने एक्सेस किया
है
तो ये फ्लैग नहीं होगा तो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
है सिंपल ट्रू पॉजिटिव का मतलब है कि हां
आप एक्सेप्ट कर रहे हैं कि यस डेवलपर ने
एक्सेस किया है इस रेपोजिटरी को तो ये
फ्लैग्ड होना चाहिए। ये गलत चीज है। ये
गलत है। तो ये ऐसा ये तो गलत है ना भाई।
समझ में आ गए?
हां सर अभी समझा सिनेरियो प्रॉपर्ली।
यासीन पटेल चलो अच्छी बात है। अगर आप समझ
गए यासीन एंड सभी लोग समझ गए तो इट्स अ
वेरी गुड थिंग। फाइनली मेरा मेहनत सफल रहा
आपको समझाने का आप लोगों को सभी लोगों को
बेसिकली बहुत दिमाग खपा है इसमें क्योंकि
क्योंकि मेरे को पता था इस पॉइंट पे
गड़बड़ी होगी इस पॉइंट पे कोई भी आके
कंफ्यूज हो जाएगा एक टाइम के लिए लिटरली
कोई भी कंफ्यूज हो जाएगा मैं भी कंफ्यूज
हो गया था मैं भी बहुत बार इस पे मतलब जब
तुम आओगे इस पे कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे बस इतना
जान जाओ लेकिन डिस्क्रिप्शन को पढ़ना
जरूरी है जब मैं भी पहली बार आया था तो
मैं भी कंफ्यूज हो गया था कि ये है क्या
ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव ट्रू पॉजिटिव एक टाइम पर
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है लग रहा है फिर फॉल्स लगता
है ट्राई हैक की गलती है ऐसा कुछ हो गया
ऐसा कुछ लगा था मुझे बट जब क्लियरली इसको
समझोगे इस पूरे सिनेरियो को कि एक डेवलपर
एक जेन्युइन गीट रेपोजिटरी को एक्सेस कर
रहा है ये अलर्ट कैसे हो सकता है भाई हो
ही नहीं सकता पॉसिबल ही नहीं है डेवलपर्स
को तो अलऊ होना चाहिए एंड यही इसके फ्लैग
में भी लिखा हुआ है शुड वी अलाउ गिट फॉर
डेवलपर्स डेवलप डेवलपर्स दैट्स इट चलिए
फीलिंग हंग्री ओके ओके
अरे भाई ऐसा क्या ऐसा क्यों बोल रहे हो
यार ऐसा क्यों बोल रहे हो एनोनिमस एनोनिमस
ऐसा क्यों बोल रहे हो यह बताओ
आदि की आर्ट आदि की आर्ट सर मैं आपका
स्केच बनाऊंगा आई एम एन स्केच आर्टिस्ट
वाओ व्हाट अ व्हाट अ ग्रेट हॉबी यू हैव या
प्रोफेशन भी है अगर आपका तो स्केच
आर्टिस्ट होना बहुत बड़ी बात है भाई और
अगर स्केच बना लेना तो मुझे जरूर बताना
दिखाना जरूर Lindin या
हमारे कहीं पर WhatsApp पर मैसेज वगैरह
करना जरूर। ठीक है? थैंक यू वेरी मच।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बस
आई होप यू गॉट दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग एंड
यहां पे भी हमने कंप्लीट कर लिया है।
कंक्लूजन में तो कुछ होता नहीं है शायद।
तो यहां पे हम कंक्लूजन में हटा देते हैं
इसको। ओके। सो इट्स डन नाउ। अ [संगीत]
इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं फिलहाल के लिए।
अगेन यहां पे ये हमारा Twitter एक्स पेज
है। इसको जरूर प्लीज आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
गाइस। यहां पे मल्टीपल चीजें आपको आने
वाले टाइम में मिलने वाली है Twitter बेस
पे। यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है डेफ़्रॉनिक्स
साइबर सिक्योरिटी। यह हमारा हैंडल है
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी। एंड WhatsApp का ग्रुप
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट का ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा।
सारे अपडेट्स सारी रिसोर्सेज उसी पे
आएंगी। ये पीडीएफ, रिसोर्सेज जो भी हैं
चैनल को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा एकदम याद से। एंड
YouTube चैनल अगर आप सब्सक्राइब्ड हैं तो
बेल आइकॉन ऑल पे प्रेस करके रखिएगा। याद
रखिएगा। नहीं है तो सब्सक्राइब करके ऑल कर
दीजिएगा ताकि नोटिफिकेशन जो है आपको मिलती
रहेंगी। दैट्स इट फॉर टुडे गाइस। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में। एंड
थैंक्स फॉर वेटिंग पेशेंटली अभी तक आप सभी
लोगों का 100 लोग जो अभी हैं जाते टाइम एक
बार लाइक ठोकते हुए जाइएगा और अपने
दोस्तों के भी शेयर जरूर कीजिएगा वीडियोस
को ताकि सब जगह पहुंचाएं और जब भी हम
गिफ्ट वाउचर वाली चीज लेकर आएंगे तो आपके
पास स्क्रीनशॉट्स होने चाहिए। तो जब भी
जहां भी शेयर करेंगे आप उसके स्क्रीनशॉट
लेके रखिएगा अपने पास कलेक्ट करके। जस्ट
फॉर प्रूफ।
ठीक है।
आई थिंक समझ में आ गया हो आप लोगों को।
हां, बिल्कुल सही बोला प्रिंस एब्सोलुटली
करेक्ट कि आपको समझना पड़ेगा कि राइट
मीनिंग ऑफ़ ट्रू पॉजिटिव एंड फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
क्या होता है? इवन फॉल्स नेगेटिव्स भी
होते हैं। ये बात याद रखिएगा। फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव ही नहीं होता। फॉल्स नेगेटिव भी
होता है, ट्रू पॉजिटिव होता है, फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव होता है। चलो मैं एक दिन आपको एक
क्लास में बता दूंगा। इसका एक्चुअल
डिफरेंस बता दूंगा। आपको ज्यादा समझ में आ
जाएगा। ठीक है? सो गाइस सेशन जब आप दोबारा
वीडियो को वॉच कर लीजिएगा तो कमेंट जरूर
कीजिएगा आके कि कंप्लीटेड एंड आपका फुल
नेम एंड Lindin पे पोस्ट करके हमें टैग
कीजिएगा। थैंक यू वेरी मच। मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट सेशन में। गुड नाइट एंड टाटा।
बाय-ब टेक केयर।